want to be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back
a lack of belief in yourself you watch
these videos because you know you've got
something more inside you
you've got michael jordan level genius
at something so today let's live
your best belief life and learn the best
of evan carmichael's motivation
enjoy
what do you say when you see yourself in
the mirror when it's just you when
you're all alone
it's just you you see yourself in the
mirror what do you say
do you say great things or do you beat
yourself up
most people they might act confident and
seem like they have it all put together
but secretly they're fighting their own
battles and at home
in private the comfort of their own home
they're their own worst enemies
the secret is to be your own biggest
critic as well as your biggest fan
the push you give yourself has to be
from a place of
love and potential not lack and despair
so i recently posted on instagram a
little cartoon of me
passing by a mirror and you see my
reflection in the mirror
and the caption says i love you and then
i challenge people to say hey what do
you what do you say to yourself when you
look in the mirror
and giving them an 18-day challenge to
say every time you see a reflection of
yourself
to say something positive whether it's i
love you or give yourself a compliment
something positive because i think most
people live in the land of negativity
all we see is all the negative things
that we're doing and all the things that
didn't work out and things that could
have been better
and that can actually be very healthy i
think you need to be your own biggest
critic i think you need to have
higher standards for yourself than what
you're currently doing but it
only works being your own biggest critic
only works when it's based off a
foundation of love
when it's based on a foundation of i am
an amazing human being and i love myself
and i suck at all of these skills
the problem that most people have is you
see that you suck at a skill that you
didn't get the result that you're not
good on camera the first time you go out
you didn't get the result you didn't
land the sale you didn't make the deal
you didn't get the date
you know whatever it is you didn't get
the result and then you think that you
suck as a human because you don't have
the skills
it's the opposite you're you're amazing
as a human
it has to be from a foundation of love
that you love yourself
and that you suck at the skills and then
you can beat yourself up over how do i
get better how do i improve how do i
acquire the skills how do i move forward
towards my goals
your environment has been perfectly
created to keep you exactly where you
are
everything around you your friends your
family the media
you consume all keeps you exactly where
you are
if you want to raise your standards and
raise the quality of your life
it starts with raising your environment
so here's a story i haven't told in a
while
when i was building up my youtube
channel and i closed my first multi-year
deal with a big brand
it was with a ceo high-powered ceo one
of the largest companies in the world
especially in the entrepreneur space and
it was going to be me and him on my
channel
every month answering questions from you
guys from the audience we did a live
stream every month
and it wasn't me interviewing him or him
interviewing me it was both of us
talking about a certain topic and then
taking questions and i remember
driving with my dad he was getting a new
car
and we had this long drive out for
whatever reason the place we wanted to
buy the car was super far away and so it
gave us
this chance to talk in a car and i just
told him about this new deal that i had
signed
i remember him asking me evan what gives
you
the confidence to feel like you're on
the same level as this guy
and he didn't mean it in a in a negative
way it was
it was in a more awesome way it's like
man look at where you've come from
because
my family is very humble like you have
to be very humble you have to appreciate
what you've got
and so how am i now how do i see myself
on the same stage as his high-powered
ceos being his equal answering questions
and the question took me aback and i
thought you know what he's right i mean
if this was evan the five years prior i
would have felt
not worthy i would have felt like i
couldn't do it i would have felt like
this is too big an opportunity for me
like i couldn't be the guy to do it
so what changed five years ago to where
i was at that point
it was my content it was my channel was
all the videos that i'm i'm putting up
because in my head it was a big deal and
that
this is the largest deal i had signed
for three years
but more that i'm around oprah every day
and and
then pena every day and kanye west every
day and all these people
every day and so i feel like i'm with
them
and and so this ceo deal wasn't that
huge a deal because i had changed my
environment
right i'd raise the stakes in my
environment and that raises your
standards
and so i realized man this is crazy how
important my channel is to myself at
least to my own growth if it's not to
you at least to my
own growth because you often can't see
it on a daily basis i could not pinpoint
the one video i uploaded or the one day
that i felt this is it it's happened
but if i look back over a five-year
period a one-year period a six-month
period even a three-month period think
about who you were three months ago
if you're investing in yourself by
watching these videos or reading books
or anything else if you're investing in
yourself
even just look three months back and
think have i grown
how much have you grown in the past
three months you may not see it on a
daily basis
but with months and then more months and
then more months and then years if you
keep on the path
you'll see some tremendous results may
not even recognize the person who you
used to be
and that's why it's so important you
raise your environment if you are not
focused on your goals
you either don't want them or you are
afraid of them
you might just not want to do them you
might be in the wrong thing
you might have picked the wrong goals
for the wrong reasons
or you're afraid of your goals you're
afraid of failing
you're afraid of it not working out and
what that means
either way the answer is action if you
don't love it
move on immediately and if you're afraid
of it move
into it immediately focused action is
always the answer so one of the
entrepreneurs that i've invested into
his name is alex he helps me run toronto
dance salsa which is the largest salsa
dance school
in canada maybe north america and we're
sitting down reviewing his goals and
reviewing his habits and making sure
that you know what he
said he was gonna do matches to him
accomplishing his goals
and there were a couple things that were
big things on the list that he had to
get done and he was afraid of making a
mistake
so for example we're trying to create
the interior of the studio
and make a wall that speaks to the
purpose of the company it speaks to the
the mission the vision what we're trying
to accomplish and we want to have
something beautiful that people
want to take their pictures on and he's
so afraid of getting it right
he's so afraid of doing the wrong thing
that he does nothing
and every time he opens up the file to
look at what he wants to do and
different ideas
he's afraid he's going to make a mistake
he's afraid he's going to invest
time energy dollars my money into
something that then when people show up
saying huh and it doesn't work out he's
so afraid to fail that he doesn't take
action which becomes the biggest failure
of all
so here was our solution procrastination
power
hour i said every day pph
put it into your calendar for one hour
this is your pph time
the thing that you have been
procrastinated on right the thing that
serves the business if if you
procrastinate on it and you don't like
it and doesn't serve the business
great get rid of it that's not we're
talking about it's the things that
you're afraid of
the things that you don't want to make a
mistake on that you're just pushing
aside because there's all this busy work
that comes in because yes we have to
respond to customers and yes we got to
do
all the work that goes into the day to
day of running the company but if you're
so focused on just the day to day
and never focus on the things that will
actually help you grow the bigger
picture stuff then guess what happens
you never do the bigger picture stuff
especially if it's because you're afraid
then you have to take action
so we plan the daily procrastination
power hour that he puts into his
calendar
and he looks at it when he gets there he
thinks what am i procrastinating the
most on
and he's got this list and he starts
attacking it and having that in his
calendar
is the thing that actually started
building momentum for those big projects
let's start with this purpose is not
passion
they're related but they're not the same
thing passion is also not that hard to
figure out
neither is purpose people just have not
been given the right tools
so let's simplify it for you today and
if you're someone who's struggling to
figure out what your purpose and your
passion are
this video is going to be insanely
helpful for you i have a who why how
process
who is your most important core value
we're not going to dive into that in
this video
but the next two are your why and your
how your why is your purpose and your
how is your passion
so let's start with purpose your purpose
is your why your purpose comes from your
pain your purpose
is whatever the thing you struggled with
the most in life think back to the most
painful moment
in your life what was it what was
happening what was around you what was
that moment
for for positive entrepreneur optimistic
people this actually might be a
challenge for me it was a challenge
because
i don't want to think about the bad past
i don't think about
what happened to me i'm focused on what
i'm doing now and going forward not
not rearview mirror stuff what happened
back then doesn't matter except it does
because the thing that will fill you up
the most is helping people who are
currently going through the thing that
you struggled with the most
so whatever was the most painful moment
in your life
from when you're born until right now
that you can remember not physical pain
psychological pain mental pain the thing
that made you feel terrible
what was that thing your purpose
is to help other people who are feeling
that right now
and so imagine who you are now and
imagine who you used to be whether
that's a year ago
five years ago 10 years ago go back to
whoever that person was let's just say
it's five years ago
great the person you are now can help
the person who you were five years ago
you may not have all the answers you're
still on your path you don't know
everything
but you've grown you've you've come out
of the hole you're better than you were
five years ago
talk to the person you were five years
ago helping that person
is your purpose you've climbed up the
staircase
right you've you've grown there's still
a lot more stairs to grow you don't want
the staircase to end
that staircase is your growth is your
professional and personal development
for life you want to keep climbing
and every time you take a step what you
want to do is reach down
and help somebody else up but you can
only help people to the extent that
you've grown
if you've taken eight steps on the
staircase that's all you can help people
up to get to step number eight
you get the 20 you can help people more
so we want to keep growing
keep climbing those stairs and then keep
reaching back and pulling people up and
giving them a hand that's your purpose
for life you'll you'll like serving
people and helping people
and it's tied to your core value your
who your one word we're not talking
about it much in this video
but you'll just like helping people
because service is hardwired into our
brain
helping people is hardwired to your
brain it has a similar impact on your
brain
as food and sex it's hardwired you'll
like it you want to help people you want
to serve
but who you serve will be different
it'll have a different impact
i love helping people in general but if
you're an entrepreneur that's something
extra special
there's so many great causes in the
world there's so many great causes
why this instead of this because you
have an emotional connection to it an
emotional attachment to it
why because you went through it because
you suffered through it and you want to
make sure
that nobody else has to suffer as much
as you suffered
your purpose comes from your pain period
it'll fill you up for life
helping entrepreneurs will fill me up
for the rest of my life
it will never get old when i'm tired
when i have no energy when i'm depleted
i will still meet with entrepreneurs
because it fills me up your purpose
comes from your pain
you have to find it now let's talk about
passion so your passion is your how
your passion is the things that you're
doing how you're going to actually
execute
against your why execute against your
purpose what are you doing
it's great that you believe an
entrepreneur is amazing but what are you
going to do
how are you going to go about doing it
so for me
it's making videos for me it's doing
speaking gigs for me it's writing books
for me it's helping people one-on-one
for me it's doing
events right that's my how but that will
evolve that will change
right i started doing this helping
entrepreneur thing when i was 22 years
old
and that started just by doing speaking
and then then it became my website
and a hundred thousand plus pages of
content and then i shut the thing down
overnight
and i focused on youtube and it's been a
10 year plus journey on youtube
and and maybe in 10 years that's gone
and i'm doing something totally
different
i don't know the how will change a lot
what you get passionate about or to
mel's point about energy what you get
energy about
will change with time but it has to be
connected to your purpose
just because it gives you energy it's
not going to fill you up it's got to be
connected to a deeper source which is
your purpose
also if you want to have more confidence
self love self belief check out my 254
series
the sign says it can take up to 254 days
of consecutive action to build a habit
so i've designed a special free program
to help you get it where i will send you
an unlisted video
to your email for the next 254 days to
shift
your self belief forward the link to
sign up for free is in the description
below
if you're doing work that you love
you're more likely to follow through
you're more likely to do it because it
doesn't feel like work because you love
doing it
don't worry what the first step is
people write in and say what's my first
it doesn't matter
something do something and then do
something again tomorrow and do
something again the next day
and every day you get a little bit
better they're great because they can
help you
one navigate the waters of dealing with
publishers
and creating a proposal that's really
gonna win because you might only get one
shot with a publisher
so she has a new author and if your
proposal sucks they
likely won't want to look at it again
unless you've done something dramatic on
your audience size
to really build up notoriety around
yourself the difference between
outstanding and average is what you do
when it gets hard people with an average
mindset
only do things when it's easy because
it's easy anyone can do it
but life is coming for you setbacks
they're coming for you and that's what
separates the average from the
outstanding
your goals they don't count until it's
hard
so i had a new guy on my team who's
writing to me to say evan
super important is urgent i need help
with my schedule i'm just not staying
consistent i'm not staying on my goals i
know what i want to get done
for you but also for my life and and
it's not unless it's some deadline or
you're on me it's not happening
i'm not consistent on it how do how do i
get going how do i stay consistent
and so we worked together through the
schedule and we created his calendar and
said what are your goals and
put it in your calendar and how do you
want each day to go and he he plotted
out his saturday to sunday you know the
whole week
and then i asked him okay now put in
your morning routine what do you want to
do every day
right so we plotted that into his
calendar now he's got this weekly
schedule of what he's going to do every
morning and then
every day doing different things and how
he wants his ideal life to go
awesome and then i told him what really
mattered
like this is great your actions map to
your ambitions it's really important
but follow and throw in your calendar it
doesn't count until it's hard
maybe maybe today is going to be easy
for you maybe tomorrow's easy for you
because we talked because you're
motivated because you're inspired he's
like yeah yeah yeah i'm going to go do
it
awesome what happens when you don't
sleep well what happens when something
happens in your family what happens when
the website crashes what happens when
something happens what happens when
you've lost some motivation
energy what happens when you get some
bad news what happens what do you do
this is where most people crumble this
is where most people
as soon as there's one little tiny thing
that interrupts them they're gone
they fall off their entire schedule and
routine your goals
suddenly don't matter anymore you don't
think they're possible
your goals don't count until they're
hard that's what i told them
i said listen listen to me this is a
great plan
that life that you wrote that's a great
life what you wrote down on your
calendar that's a great life for you
that's what you want imagine if you did
that every day
for the next year how different would
your life look like one year from today
if you were consistent and staying like
oh yeah yeah amazing i mean
great doesn't count until it's hard
none of this matters until it's hard
life is coming for you
get ready and what i want
him and i want you to realize is that
you need to expect it because you're
working your calendar and it's great and
here we go we're getting our getting our
objectives and going for our goals and
then when something hits us in the face
you're surprised by it you're shocked
and then you fall off course don't be
surprised expect it
expect the difficulty expect a road bump
expect somebody to punch you in the face
like expected it's coming
and this is your chance to be
outstanding
because everybody else is going to be
average the reason why you don't follow
through on your vision
is because you don't trust it enough it
makes sense that it's going to happen
but it's not happening yet people aren't
saying yes there's no momentum
there's no money coming in and you start
to wonder who am i
to have this big dream so then there's
this temptation to give up
and go do something else and not follow
through on your vision but you know in
the back of your head you know
you know that eventually for someone
it's going to work out
you need to stay on it you need to
follow through
otherwise someone else is going to make
money off of your idea
they're going to make it happen without
you so look at what i'm trying to do
here with with this channel with my
youtube content with my
my mission my purpose i'm trying to
solve the world's biggest problem i want
to spread more belief
right the world's biggest problem is
that people don't believe in themselves
enough
i think everybody is a genius everybody
has michael jordan level talent at
something they're just not living it
they're not doing it they're not
expressing it and so they end up
living a life that they don't like
knowing that they're capable of more
like this is the problem
i'm trying to solve it's one that that
i'm never going to fully solve in my
lifetime and i wake up every day trying
to do it
and it's easy to get up and think well
there's so many people trying to do the
same thing that
there's tony robbins and there's all
these other people who am i to go off
and do this
and i remind myself that i may not be
tony robbins i may not ever have as big
an impact i may not sell as many books
as simon sinek i mean
i may never have that big an impact but
i was able to help some people
you know we have 2 million subscribers
across the channels
we have 300 million views across the
channels it's having an impact it's
helping people
i can get better i need to get better
but what i'm doing
is already having an impact in helping
people so i need to keep going
and that's what i find really helpful
just reminding yourself that that you
matter that the work you do matters even
if it hit
one person it made a difference it
matters and so you have to follow
through
you need to be your biggest critic as
well as your biggest
fan people are usually their biggest
critics
you point out all the flaws you tell
yourself all the reasons why you suck
i actually think that's a good thing
being your biggest critic
forces you to get better but it's only
healthy if it's paired with you
also being your biggest fan you think
that you suck
but you also feel like you're amazing
like you're a gift to the world like
you're the best thing ever
you suck and you're amazing you're the
worst and you're the best
both i think that's the healthy balance
you have to be your biggest critic
as well as your biggest fan both at the
same time
people don't show up for one of three
reasons number one is you're afraid
you're afraid of rejection you're afraid
of failure you're afraid of it not
working out and so you just don't show
up
number two is you're not consistent you
show up some days but you don't show up
other days because you don't have the
routines
and habits in place to make you show up
consistently every single day
and number three is you don't want to
you don't want to show up because you
don't actually enjoy the thing that
you're about to do
you would rather procrastinate on it
because you don't love it
and showing up is more painful than just
sitting around
so my goal today with this video is to
help you bust through these so that you
can show up for
life and have the impact that you want
to have so i think the fear of showing
up is actually a good thing
it means that you are doing something
different something outside your comfort
zone something that is that is not
normal that is new
and that's good you want to be pushing
the envelope if there was nothing that
you were afraid to show up to
today tomorrow next week then you're not
growing you're not learning you're not
pushing against your boundaries and
comfort zones
and so even today i had to show up but
and again it should be every single day
so today
i was procrastinating on sending out an
email to grant
as well as a couple other people where
i'm looking at doing more collaborations
more work on my youtube channel
more cost pollination connection to
other successful youtubers
to help the whole entrepreneur youtube
community grow right i want to get the
message out there i want to be
playing a bigger game and so i emailed
grant and emailed for the people with a
new idea that i had
so when the idea was first suggested to
me about doing this and reaching out
i had a little bit of nerves like okay
it's gonna require an ask
i might get rejected it may not work out
and i had it scheduled for today because
it was my youtube day
and so i look at the list today like uh
maybe i should start with
one person or two people or just pick
the easy people
and just the fact that i felt that just
the fact that that was one of the
reasons meant
i had to go and do five i had to do a
bigger number i had to go after
the harder people i had to do the people
that i thought
may say yes may say no may make me look
bad if they say no
and a lot of it is just head games the
honest truth is
grant's probably not gonna care grant's
probably gonna say yes
like 98 chance he says yes and he passes
on to somebody on his team we start
working together and we create the
collaboration
uh one percent chance he ignores it and
one percent chance he says no
but it's not the logical rational things
that hold us back it's the emotional
fearful things and so what i've trained
myself to do is anytime i feel that
that that oh my god it may not work out
then i have to do it i have to do it i
have just to show myself
because the worst thing you can do is
get to the edge of the cliff
and say you're gonna jump and then not
jump it's better not to catch that
you're nervous it's better not to even
come up with the idea
to just float around in ignorance
ignorance is bliss
then to catch it and then play small and
so as soon as you catch it i've trained
myself i want you to do the same thing
as soon as you catch it train yourself
to do it even if it doesn't work out
just training yourself that you don't
back down when you are afraid
the problem isn't that you're not a
genius that you're not talented that you
don't have
wisdom and abilities and resourcefulness
and that you're not michael jordan
that's not the problem the problem is
you're not focused you're not doing the
things that you need to do
i just came back from video marketing
world in dallas
and i was being asked about where to
spend your time which social media sites
to spend time on and i think
this is a classic example of where
entrepreneurs fail
is you're trying to do everything and as
a result you suck everywhere and feel
burnt out tapped out and not building
momentum if you get to the end of a week
and you feel like you worked your face
off
but you look back what did i get done if
that's how you're ending a week
you worked hard and you feel like what
did i get done you're not focused you're
switching between tasks
too much instead of having all of these
social media sites at the same time pick
one and crush it
i quoted andrew carnegie at my event and
my speech
my favorite quote from him is put all
your eggs in one basket and then watch
that basket everybody's saying diversify
diversify diversify
have 18 different multiple streams of
income look at the people
who are who are one person show with 18
streams of income they're making no
money
you're making 10 a month from this and
25
a month from that and 18 cents from this
you're not making money
now as you build and scale and grow and
you have a team like
i do i've got 24 people on my team okay
great now it might be time to diversify
but as a solo person you can't do
everything
yourself and you are a genius you have
michael jordan level talent at something
and that's what you need to find and
that's we need to spend as much time as
possible on
until you're making money you can invest
back into your business and continue to
grow
this is why it's so important that you
love what you do it's why it's the
number one rule for success that comes
up
over and over and over and over again is
people love
what they do the people who are winning
at the highest level
they love what they do that allows them
to be relentless because you could talk
about being relentless and giving it all
you've got and going all
in and grinding and giving 110
but if you don't love it you're gonna
quit it may not be after a day may not
be after a month may not be after a year
but you're gonna quit
when it gets too hard and you don't love
it you will
quit this is why so many entrepreneurs
fail because you're just chasing an
opportunity you're just looking at
the fastest way to make a buck in 2019
in 2020 in 2021
the fastest way to make some money
you're gonna give up
unless you love it now money's important
it's gotta be in your top five but it's
not number one
it can't be number one if money is your
number one you're gonna fail
you just won't put in the work the
people who win have something that they
put
above money and that's what allows them
to wake up and be relentless and put in
the work
you're looking at a guy here who sucked
at making videos you can go back on my
channel you can watch the first videos
i was nervous i was shy i still am an
introvert
but it's through practice through being
relentless i've had my channel for ten
years i've made five or six thousand
videos across
my four more than four now nine or so
channels five or six thousand videos
that's crazy right that's crazy who does
that
you have to love it it doesn't feel like
work making these videos
is fun for me still 10 years later is
still fun for me i'm excited
the second that it gets to be oh i got
to make videos
that's it i'm out because the people who
love doing it will crush me
i was looking at my youtube thumbnail uh
examples i'm doing a youtube course
right now
where i'm teaching people how to have
success on youtube how to get your first
million subscribers get
where is it get get get there that gold
button get one of those for you
right you're a thought leader you're an
expert i want you to get a million
subscribers that's that's the course
that i'm launching right now
so i'm looking at my thumbnail
experiments i have 130
thumbnail experiments happening right
now on my channel i'm testing 130
different variations
then i want to complete it and what
we've completed and gone through
1100 something completed thumbnail
experiments just on thumbnails
just testing my thumbnails we've done
over 1100 different experiments that's
crazy
right testing big changes like not
having text on a thumbnail and making it
purple and crazy colors
to really little tiny changes like what
if we just tweak this person's eyes
what if we alter the shade of orange
just little tiny changes that most of
you probably never notice
why i love it i can't help it
i love i wake up when i think about this
stuff
and that's what i want for you that's
what you need to be doing and it can't
be forced
jerry seinfeld calls it the torture that
you can endure the torture that you can
endure most people talk about passion
and purpose which is great
but it it's torture for other people i
think everyone is born an optimist
and then your environment sucks the soul
out of most people
when you're a baby you don't stress out
about how you look
what you're wearing or how you're
smelling when you're a kid
you don't hate your life and complain
about the world
if there's negativity in your head it
was put there by someone
and if you want to change it you need to
change your environment
so i've had the good pleasure of seeing
one of my friends mark drager great
friend of the channel
been involved with the channel for a
number of years become more optimistic
become more positive and he was
wondering could i even do it is it
possible
he was a guy who was naturally naturally
pessimistic
he had a lot of stuff happen to him like
we all have a lot of situations a lot of
circumstances
that made him see the the negative of
what's happening of be pessimistic of
not being the typical optimistic
everything's going to work out great
entrepreneur and so what changed over
the past 12 months
he's made a significant investment in
himself i've been hanging around with
him a lot more
we've co-hosted a podcast together he's
hanging around
me my content garyvee's content tom bill
used content more he's been the tony
robbins seminar
twice in the past year brought his team
with him
and he's slowly inching towards more
optimism more positivity that more
things
are possible because of the negative
upbringing that he had
it takes a lot of unwiring it takes a
lot of shift in your focus it takes a
lot of
with purpose with intent changing your
environment changing the people you hang
out with
changing where you the physical
environment that you're in
to make a change i went to mark's office
and he's moving his office he's
creating his own office he's putting a
picture on the wall of himself and then
what he wants to be
as as positive inspiration every day
he's looking at
what kind of colors and what kind of
furnishings and what kind of
the core can i have in my office to make
me feel bold to make me feel alive
every single day it's possible
and i think that's a starting point for
a lot of people it's possible
to change your outlook it's possible to
become more optimistic
that negativity that was planted in your
head was put there by somebody else who
hates their life
you are not born to wake up and hate
your life you're not born to wake up and
think that
it's just negativity all around the
world you're not born to wake up and be
a pessimist you're not it was put there
by somebody
somebody else who hated their life and
we need to eject that person we need to
unwire
the years or decades of training
and in that void you replace it with the
thing that you want
if you want more optimism you you
surround yourself with the most
optimistic people you can find
in person on your team in video format
in the books you read and the clubs
you're hanging out with
you first limit access from the negative
people
limit exposure you may not be able to
completely wipe them out like maybe
they're your parents
but you can limit exposure you limit
access either with time
or just topics that you're covering and
then inject more positivity optimism to
the people books resources
environment that you have around you
people don't push themselves to the
extreme
they just don't it's because it's too
hard
it's too crazy hard that you're not
likely to do it on your own
and so i think when those opportunities
come
learning to embrace them learning to
take them on learning to say this is my
chance to show myself and the world
what i am made of this is my chance
but is it still your limit so let me
give you a couple examples
this morning i woke up and i didn't have
a lot of sleep i went to bed at three
something
last night i woke up at 7 20 this
morning i turned off the alarm but still
woke up
at 7 20. force a habit and i'm not on a
lot of sleep and i need to make a bunch
of videos for you guys and i want to
bring my best
and i put pressure on myself that every
video needs to be my best i want it to
be better i want to grow i don't want to
just
do the same thing over and over and over
again but it's a challenge
and so it's easy to say oh i'm so tired
i don't have energy
i wish i slept more or like an excuse
after excuse but no i'm gonna go do it
and here i am and i've made i don't know
how many videos already today
i'm closing in on finishing up and i
still have energy and i'm pumped for how
it went
and and the story i'm telling myself is
i'm awesome like i had
very little sleep it's not how i want to
be living every day
but when that happens what do what do
you do how do you stand up how do you
show yourself what you're made of
but even that is not the biggest extreme
you know like i feel like i'm capable of
way more
my tour was the most that i'd ever
pushed myself
not just mentally not just facing fears
but physically
physically pushing myself where i broke
my neck in two spots
um i had a concussion i've never had a
concussion before it's wild
don't wish on anybody if you haven't
experienced it yet i had three staples
in my head
i compressed my spine it was brutal
and i had to cancel my event in denver
where i was
because it was that night and then the
next one was going to be in kansas city
this is what i wore for for 60 days
i wore these and i took them off for 10
minutes a day
60 days right like this is what i made
this is what i'm capable of i'm
complaining about
having four hours sleep i did i had
my neck broken and continued on my tour
across the u.s for 30 more days and
another 30 days here in toronto
seeing entrepreneurs sitting in pain at
the front of the room with ice packs and
pillows and not quitting and going home
even though
i was in massive pain like this is who i
am and i'm complaining about
not having sleep the night before right
like perspective
the greatest point on the tour for me
was in kansas city was my next stop
we refunded everybody the money because
i wasn't going to be able to go for
three hours but i said hey we already
booked this hotel venue
you guys already booked your night off
why don't you just come out anyway just
come on out and i'll go for an hour and
take pictures and say hi and just
show some kansas city love
and i showed up and we went for an hour
and a half and then my wife pulled me
off
because my lips are starting to get dry
because i wasn't being able to
you know answer questions as clues i'd
like because i was still suffering from
the concussion you know the the neck
pain is one thing
that's just sitting still i can't do
anything about it but the concussion
you're not supposed to think you're not
supposed to have
uh conversations it makes recovery worse
and so she she was watching me like a
hawk the whole night she's watching me
and then she sees me start to fade he's
like okay that's it i gotta take kevin
home
quick pictures and we gotta go i've
never
been pulled off a stage before
never for like for sucking or definitely
for a physical
issue never never never it's never
happened
this was me at my physical limit
that was it i was done i had actually
nothing left like somebody had to come
and say you are done
the best right
i mean it sucked but at the same time
it's like man this is it i actu i got to
the edge i got to the physical
limitation i can't go anymore i'm being
told i need to step down
and there's something so amazing that
you feel about yourself that you were
able to
go that far now you don't want to do
that every day you want to take care of
your health
of course of course of course don't
don't do stupid things
and at the same time the pride
the feeling of awesomeness that
you've hit that mark i can't explain
so i started telling the people around
me my wife my agent the people on the
tour
that we're planning a 2020 tour and it's
not going to be as good
this will be great we're going to hit 23
cities 90 days east coast texas mexico
you know montreal it's going to be fun
but it won't be as good because i'm not
gonna break my neck
right i'm not gonna hit i'm not gonna
forcefully go break my neck just because
right that's that that's stupid don't do
that
don't don't don't go do that just
because and so i'm not going to face the
same challenge
and so the point is i also have a great
time it'll still be amazing
but what we went through what i had to
go through in 2019
this year is
foundational like i'm gonna remember
this forever this is who i am
this this this is who i am
not the guy who thinks that four hours
sleep and making some videos is a big
deal
right it just resets who you are and
reminds you if you step up to the
challenge of what you're capable of
the people who are telling you that your
idea won't work
are not the people whose life that you
want
so why are you listening to them your
uncle joe
your aunt susan the rest of your family
the people who you grew up with from
high school
look at their life look at their life
right now take away their words and what
they're telling you remove the emotion
from it
look at their life do you want a life
like theirs because their advice will
lead to a life like theirs
if not then you probably should be doing
the exact opposite of what they're
telling you to do
now i think there's two types of people
who will give you negative feedback you
got the haters
and then you got the people who are just
ignorant and there's a big difference
between those two
so let's start with the haters the
haters i call the little man the haters
their entire role in their life is to
bring other people down maybe they took
their shot
this is actually quite frequent they
took their shot they tried
they didn't work they failed and so now
nobody around them can be successful
they get their value they get their
self-love by destroying other people
because it makes them feel better about
themselves it's like watching some train
wreck on reality tv show
right watching relationships and lives
fall apart because it makes you feel
better about your life
you feel better about your life when you
see somebody else's life be a total mess
right those are the haters now how do
you deal with them
it starts by understanding that if you
believe like i believe that humans are
built to serve right people are built to
serve you want to do good
people are good right both of those
things humans are good and we're built
to serve
then what would get somebody who was
good and built a serve
to leave a nasty negative comment or to
tell you that you suck or your deal's
not gonna work out
what would drive them to do it they
really hate their life
right like empathy is the first step
just feeling bad for them not not
sympathy in in
and using that as a negative against
them not saying well your life sucks so
i'm not gonna
that that's not gonna help anything it's
actual genuine empathy
if the highlight of somebody's day is
coming to this video and leaving a
negative comment
it's okay i feel bad for that person
if that's the highlight of your day then
you must be in a really rough spot if
you're
if you believe that people are good and
they're built to serve and so what that
does is remove the sting out of the
comment when somebody is
raging on you that that you suck and
that your idea is never going to work
having empathy to understand wow this
person is likely in a really tough spot
that removes the stinging of the words
and allows you to then be
more practical less emotional
to respond emotionally and feel like oh
my god maybe they're right maybe they
have a point maybe i do suck
say wait wait a minute wait a minute
this person they hate their life
why am i listening to them right just
like the wake up call
out of the the head game that you're in
listen to their advice so those are the
haters remove the sting and then allow
you to make a practical decision
the second part are the people who are
ignorant they're your friends your
family the people around you
who they actually love you right chances
are your parents love you
your mom probably loves you right most
moms love their kids
your parents probably love you so why
would they be telling you not to go do
something why would why would they be
telling you advice against what you
want to hear because they grew up in a
different era
your parents are pilgrims your parents
don't understand the world that exists
your parents don't understand that
you can have a full-time business from
this it doesn't make sense
when your parents were your age they
couldn't do the things that you can do
so they want you to be successful the
people around you who love you
want you to be successful they have a
different definition of success
success to them looks different than it
does for you because they're from a
different era
and that's okay again starting point is
empathy
understand that these words that are
coming out of their mouth
is love they're trying to express love
they're concerned for you
they want you to win they just have a
different version of what winning looks
like
burnout is real but i think most burnout
happens because people are not doing the
thing that they actually love doing
it's not just about being busy and
keeping your mind occupied all day
you can be busy and hate your life and
get burnt out if i was an accountant
i would hate my life and burn out in a
day
because i don't like being an accountant
but doing this thing that i love i put
in way more effort way more work and i
love it it's been
10 plus years of still having my youtube
channel and i'm not burnt out if
anything i'm pushing harder than ever
before
because i love it and so i think it's
not just about being busy it's about
being busy on the thing
that is your mission for life now
compassion fatigue is a thing
doing it so much that you burn out
yourself is possible
but again that is not why most people
are burning out
most people i believe are burning out
because they're spending too much time
too much energy too much effort doing
things that they hate
and if you wake up and hate your life
and hate the job you're about to go to
then there's no wonder why you feel like
you're burning them so i recently came
back from going to tony robbins event in
dallas he invited me to sit in the front
row
and i'm super blessed and grateful to
have tony support
and i went there with alex friend of the
channel who helps me run trying to dance
salsa
and we're on a super crunch timeline
because alex was teaching classes
the the evening before we left and then
the day of the last event
and we we rushed down there alex was
flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day
and it's non-stop if you've been to a
tony robbins event it's
it's all day all night it's eight in the
morning to midnight and then up again
the next day and doing the same thing
and and it's wild and it's fun it's
amazing and my favorite thing to do
whenever i travel
is actually meet believe nation meet you
guys and so
all through the event i wear my believe
hoodie and i'm not wearing grand stuff
i'm wearing
evan carmichael stuff with the plane and
the believe on the back and people are
stopping me
and that's actually the best it doesn't
take away from my experience tony's
often on stage at the top at the
beginning of every event saying
hey i have some friends of mine you
might know them don't be celebrities
leave them alone don't talk to them let
them have their own experience
and it always makes me sad when he says
that because
for me meeting you guys meeting people
who recognize me and that's a group that
i over index because people who watch
tony videos you know they're probably
going to find my content
i like it i like it more when people
come and say hi it adds to the
experience for me
and then on the last day before we
rushed out to go to the airport
i set up a meet-up right i had an hour
open before having to get to the airport
so let's do a meet-up
let's do a local dallas richardson texas
meetup
right and and it could have spent the
time doing something else or sleeping in
or
writing my book or doing anything else
but
it's not burnout for me like that fuels
me that gives me more energy
i love it hanging out with believe
nation gives me more
energy than it takes away and then took
an uber
to get to my to the airport and the guy
who drove in the uber was actually in
the the meetup in richardson's like i
got to leave early because i got to
start my job okay great and then i book
an uber
and there he is total fluke but amazing
and so it's a lot of work you know i was
all day all night
not connecting with my team not doing
the things that i'm supposed to be doing
and i still make time to be with people
and and
make a one hour meet up because that
hour was open
and it fuels me but if it was something
that i hated
just that half an hour just 15 minutes
i'd start to feel like i'm burning out
like i don't want to be here but this is
terrible
and so i think it's really important
that you're doing work that you love
that would be a burnout for other people
but not a burnout for you because you
love it so much
you rarely regret the things that you do
it's what you don't
do that you regret the most it's all the
missed opportunities
the times you wanted to say yes but were
afraid the moments that you
wanted to bet on yourself but you were
scared
those moments that's what you want to
minimize
because it's way better to know and to
fail than to never know it all
self-confidence comes from doing
difficult things
from trying failing getting back up and
trying again
a different way your goals don't count
until they're hard
you won't make yourself proud unless
it's hard
and it's time to start making yourself
proud of your effort
so i'm in the process of writing a new
book and i sent the book out to 30 of my
friends and friends of friends to get
their feedback
and i'm on a crazy deadline with the
publisher got i got it i got it here
this is
this is the copy this is this is what i
gave out to 30 different people
and they gave me all the books back
on the same day and then what i had to
do was go through each copy
and underline i underlined can you see
kind of blurry i
underlined anytime they underlined i
underlined
because i wanted to see what they cared
about as well as catching typos and
everything else
and i looked at that pile of books i had
30 books i had to get through
in one day i had to basically read my
own book 30 different times make one
master copy underline it
the whole day and and it stressed me out
i looked at that stack of books and said
how am i going to get through all this
stuff
and i just started taking action i just
started doing it
and here's the thing halfway through i
started getting massive pain
my neck was was really hurting me my
back was really hurting me
my neck mostly because i broke my neck
in march and i'm still healing and
recovering from it
and i had to spend the whole time i had
to spend the whole time like this right
i got the books here on the table and
i'm flipping through it and i'm doing
this
and it takes a toll the whole day doing
it like this so a couple hours in i'm
having massive
neck pain
[Music]
it's the best right like i gotta get
through it this is the time it doesn't
count until it's hard
i don't want to be doing this every
single day right if that's every day you
need to change your life you need to
change your habits
but in those rare moments when you get
the chance to push yourself
either physically mentally or just
courage because you're afraid of doing
something that's your chance that's your
chance to show yourself what you're made
of
humans are built to serve period
serving others is hardwired into our
brain it triggers the same area of your
brain
as food and sex if you're not happy
it's because you're not serving either
serving the world on this big mission
that you have
or serving the 25 closest people to you
if you're not happy it's because you're
not serving
so one of the hacks that i do in my life
to get me to do the things that i'm
afraid of or don't want to do
is through service if i can connect any
of my actions like making videos
i don't necessarily like just sitting
here talking to a camera but i connected
to service
that i'm making this video people are
going to watch it hopefully they get
inspired enough to take some kind of
action and it's meaningful to their life
or business that makes me feel good
that's service
as soon as i can connect the action to
service
i'm all in and that's a way to hack me
you want something for me
whether it's my wife or my team or
general public
if it makes me feel like this will serve
other people and it would have a big
impact
then it's much easier for me to get a
yes it's easy for me to say
i am in saying i never have the time
is the single greatest excuse that is
preventing you from accomplishing your
goals
you are not allowed to say it anymore
stop it stop
believing your own lies whatever story
you're telling yourself as to why you
can't do it how much time you don't have
somebody else who made it had it way
worse than you did
they made it and had it way worse than
you did
if they can make it you can do the only
difference is the story you're telling
yourself
you don't have enough time to do it so
i'm gonna give you a more fun
example on this one uh i wanna get to
being a better league of legends player
okay i would play league of legends
i don't know once or twice a week
depending on what was happening in my
calendar
i started sponsoring a league of legends
player my first esports venture
this guy named kyle menko and he plays
teemo team was a character in the game i
play teemo he's the best teemo in the
world
in any region around the world he is the
number one guy
and i said kyle menko i want to sponsor
you
and part of the deal is you're going to
coach me i want you to coach me and how
to get better
i want to get better i want to climb i
was in bronze which is the second worst
division in league of legends
i said what was the best you've ever
done said silver which is the third
worst division in league of legends
and so he said okay i can help you how
often are you practicing
i said i don't know once or twice a week
it's like okay that's not enough
i need you to play three games a day
three games a day
and a game takes 35 to 40 minutes
sometimes longer depending on how long
it takes to get into the game could be
45 minutes maybe even up to an hour
i'm thinking my head three games a day
are you nuts i don't have time to do
this
i can't make that happen i got all these
other responsibilities right
if it's important you got to stop
telling yourself that you can't do it
how do i justify playing three games a
day
when i have all these other stuff i need
to do i need to run a business i want to
scale i want to grow my youtube channel
i want to grow my impact i need to write
my book i need to launch my youtube
course i need to spend time with my wife
and my family
i got lots of other things that i need
to do i need to sleep
you know all of it how do i justify
spending three games a day
to improve my teemo i don't have the
time
your actions map to your ambitions i
look at my calendar i made a way
i'm going to do it i want to get better
i want to improve
now i don't do when i'm traveling so i'm
here in la right now so i haven't played
my three games since i've been away
but when i'm in toronto pretty much
every day that i'm in toronto i'll get
my three games in and i've gotten better
the results speak i went from bronze to
silver
and now i'm climbing up through silver
and i'm hopefully the goal is to get the
gold
by the end of the year so that's the
fourth worth fourth worst
division and you're starting to get
once you get in the goal and you get a
little bit higher now you're starting to
get some kind of
not reputation but significance and just
like you're actually a
semi decent player right so i'm i'm
chasing down
my league of legends goals because your
personal goals you may be watching to
think about what it's like why are you
wasting your time
doing it's a personal goal to me it
might be a waste of time to you
maybe building a deck for your backyard
is a big waste of time for me
maybe making your own clothes or
whatever other hobby you have cooking or
crafting
is a big waste of time for me right so
don't judge somebody else's
personal goals this is a personal goal
of mine i want to chase it down and i
want to not tell myself that i don't
have the time right as soon as you hear
yourself say i don't have the time
you're not taking control of your
calendar you're not taking control of
your life
of course you have the time you choose
not to prioritize it
that's that's the change in language you
need to make you're not allowed to say
i don't have the time instead i choose
not to prioritize it
because now you're in charge now you
have nobody to blame because when it's
somebody else's fault when you have the
time
that's not your fault it's somebody
else's fault that's everybody else
who has demands on your time right you
can't do anything about it so let's just
stay here and never accomplish your
goals
you choose not to prioritize it once you
take accountability once you take
responsibility
say i'm going to take control of what i
want to do in my life
that's when everything starts to change
like you look at the people who've made
big money they've been
they've been chasing something that they
love doing
because otherwise you won't put in
enough work if you're just chasing an
opportunity
you're probably not going to make it if
you don't love it enough
the people who love it will crush you
like if salsa dancing was the hot trend
for
2020 you can say great i'm going to make
tons of money salsa dancing being a
being an instructor
and then i'll do that for three years
and then retire and go travel the world
and do what i love
you'll never make the money salsa
dancing because alex is going to destroy
you
sorry yeah because he loves it right
because you'll you'll be uh a wannabe
and you'll never put in enough work to
actually get great at the thing
like if you're if you're gonna work with
somebody who's gonna be in your in your
production
and they're just they just want to make
it as an actor because they think it's a
path to make tons of money because brad
pitt makes 40 million
a movie or whatever it is but they don't
actually care about being a good actor
they're not going to get into your show
like you're gonna spot that out and say
no i need people who
actually care about the crap you don't
have to be an extrovert to sell
you also don't have to be a slime ball
to sell either
all you need to sell is a vision that
you believe in
and a passion to make it come true and
if you don't learn to effectively sell
that
genius idea that you have in here that
can serve the world
will never come to fruition and you'll
never get the impact that you're after
so i'm here in la and over the past two
days i've been on the podcast for jordan
belfort
wolf of wall street and jay abraham
who's the legendary
marketing guru for tony robbins and
damon john and a whole bunch of other
people
and i'm on their podcast i'm telling
them that they need to be on youtube
that they need to get their message out
i want to see them more heavily invested
i want to see their message reach the
world
and five years ago
evan or five years ago would have been
too afraid
to humbled to worry that i might not be
perfect
that i wouldn't be able to persuade them
to do the thing and so i wouldn't have
tried it
and i still have a bit of that in me
when when jordan belford asked me
how good are you like how good at
youtube are you
and the answer that i gave was within
the thought leadership world
if you you want to help entrepreneurs
i'm i'm top three five in the world
even as i said it feels weird saying it
because the the canadian
or carmichael kind of humbleness is
pumping in
but it's also true because when you're
talking to somebody
who is not super familiar with what
you're doing they're trying to get an
understanding when i'm talking to jordan
belfort
and trying to give him an understanding
of what i do and why my message is so
important for him i'm trying to serve
him i'm trying to help him i want him to
win
so the credibility is important backs it
up and me not
strongly believing in myself means that
he won't believe in me either
and one of my favorite messages from
jordan and i told them this at the
beginning of the podcast interview was
sales is about a transfer of certainty
of all the things i've learned from
jordan belford that is the number one
thing
that still rings true in my head sales
if you want to sell people you want to
persuade them on something
again not for nefarious reasons not to
screw somebody over not just to get
their money
you want to persuade them i'm here
trying to persuade jordan
trying to persuade jay trying to
persuade lots of other people
to take their message and put it up on
youtube
to spread it to the world it's for them
right i got frustrated with jordan
halfway through the interview and he
said why are you frustrated because he's
making it
a joke and some and having fun and he
loves having fun on the show and
and it's a more entertaining show he's
way more funny and entertaining than i
am
i told him you're doing this for the
audience because people watch the show
i'm doing this for you like we're here
at a limited time and i want you to win
i want to get this out of my head into
yours so you can go take action on it
right so the ability to sell
and persuade is based off your ability
to transfer certainty
and so when you fully believe in the
thing
when you fully believe in a thing like
this is right this is the thing that has
to happen
in service in service for your customer
in service for your audience you have to
do this
not for me but because it's the best
thing for you when you fully believe it
then you have to go all in on it the
fastest path for you to get the success
you're after is to model success
the idea here is simple you find people
who have already done the thing that you
want to do
learn from them understand what they did
to get there and then try on their hat
right see what worked for them and apply
it to your business this is what worked
for me this is what saved my company
bill gates saved my first company even
though i've never met him i haven't yet
we're going to make it happen hopefully
hopefully hopefully soon
i was struggling i had a upstart
software company that wasn't making
money and
i quit on my business partner and i woke
up the next day and said i need to find
a way to make this happen
like i can't quit on this too soon
because i'm going to regret it if i
don't keep going
and so i said who has done this before
who's done this and i thought of bill
gates which is the first person that
came to mind was bill gates so i looked
at his story and how did he
build microsoft well it was through
partnerships and so
i started making partnerships in my
business i had nothing else to lose i
was already at rock bottom right here
quit on my partner it was hopeless so
let's just give this a shot
and within i don't know a couple months
maybe even sooner
i landed my first partnership deal for
13 and a half thousand dollars and at
the time guys i was making 300 bucks a
month so that money
meant the world to me like that was that
was bank and and more important than
that it it gave me hope you know like
this could happen this this business
could actually work
and it gave me a model to then go and do
it again and again and again and ever
since then
whenever i don't know what to do i'm
model success i find someone who's done
it
and i try to apply their strategies and
make it work for me
but this is the important thing not
every strategy is going to work the same
way
for them as it did for you so maybe
waking up early is your ticket maybe
waking up later
is going to be your ticket there's
people who've done both which is the one
that's going to work for you
you won't know by sitting on the couch
and thinking about it the best thing you
can do
is just go and try you try on their hat
right bill gates did this dan lok does
this bruce lee does this
awesome try it try it and see people
pre-judge
so early your actions have to map to
your ambitions in a one-off situation
you can always be grateful for what
happened when i broke my neck in
colorado
i'm grateful for the opportunity i'm the
opportunity to learn
to push myself to get better but did it
map to my ambitions
right whenever you're stuck in a one-off
situation you can yes
always default to gratitude but if you
get the choice this is the difference
between
living an intentional versus a
reactionary life
if you're just grateful for everything
that happens to you and see it as a
journey
yes and you've learned yes great but
it's the journey that you want to be on
it's a journey that will get you to
where you want to go because if the
person who wants to hit the town
ends up on the farm maybe he's not happy
maybe that's not his ambitions now you
might say
that actually served him that is
something that he should have gone down
right every road leads to somewhere but
is it the road that you want to go down
do your actions map to your ambitions
i think it's really important the guy
who climbed the tree amazing
right if his goal was to be there
fastest to take the shortest path
that's the path he should take and yes
he was right and the others were wrong
he was right for him because he wanted
to take the shortest path do your
actions map to your ambitions
you have goals look at your calendar
look at how you're scheduling your time
look at where you're spending time what
you're doing it on
will the actions that you're taking lead
you to accomplish the goals that you're
trying to go after
if yes amazing if not switch things up
i think too often people have hopes and
dreams and desires and ambitions but
then their schedule doesn't match up you
say you want to do this but when i look
at your calendar
it doesn't show me that you're doing it
if you want to have a youtube channel
show me in your calendar where you're
making youtube videos
for too many people it's never you're
just not doing it ever
so then it just becomes a hope a dream a
wish a someday
some day is not a day of the week right
you got to put it in your calendar make
sure your actions map to your ambition
nobody wakes up every day and says this
is going to be the greatest day ever
not dan lok not evan carmichael not tony
robbins
nobody you wake up and you're tired and
you have stuff in your eyes and you have
lines on your face from the pillows the
difference between
successful people is that they demand
excellence from themselves to the habits
and routines that they do
daily the problem is that thinking that
these people are different
that if you're not waking up with tons
of motivation ready to take on the day
that something is wrong with you the
only thing that's wrong with you is you
don't have the habits that set you up
for success
every single day and today i want to
change that
so i have a 5s morning routine that i go
through
every single day that sets me up for
success that demands excellence i'm
going to share with you guys today
the first s is sing the fastest way to
change your state
is to put on music the fastest way to go
from feeling low energy
tired bored into an energy of i am ready
to go
is music put on the song not that makes
you feel the current way that you're
feeling this is where most people mess
up you put on music for how you're
currently feeling if you're feeling
really sad and low energy
you're gonna put on really mellow slow
music what does that do
it keeps you in the same state that
you're in it it keeps you exactly where
you are what you want to do is put on
the music for how you want to feel
and so i have a playlist on my main
channel called the believe playlist
which is the songs that i listen to
these are the songs that i listen to
every day they may work for you they may
not work for you there's no perfect song
for everybody there's a perfect song for
you and so build a playlist are the
songs that make you come alive
here's the criteria if this song came on
it would force you to start moving if
the song came on you find yourself doing
this
if the song came on you would get out of
your chair and want to move around
doesn't mean you're going to dance like
crazy doesn't mean you're going to start
building up the lyrics that may be you
awesome
but if you're a little more introverted
or don't like to dance something that
would make you move
something that would get you at least in
your chair doing this that's what i want
make a playlist and put that on it's the
first thing that you do
every single morning it'll make a huge
difference to setting the tone
changing your state and giving you
energy and momentum to start the day
s number two is sun i like getting
outside i think there's something about
getting outside of your home of your
condo your apartment
getting outside getting some fresh air
just being out in nature
makes a big difference getting some
getting some vitamins on your face
from the sun outside but also signifying
that you're
you're leaving your bedroom you're
leaving
the condo the apartment the home you're
leaving what happened last night and
you're ready to go off and start the day
this is especially important if you're
working from home because it's easy to
have your
you know office right next to your
bedroom or maybe your office is your
bedroom
and carry that bedroom energy that tired
i just woke up i want to stay in bed i
want to sleep
energy into your work and you won't do
great things if that's the energy you're
carrying to your work
so having some kind of ritual that
splits up
sleeping energy to i'm ready to go
energy makes a big difference and i find
the easiest way to do it
is to get outside and get some sun bonus
points if you're in a condor apartment
to take the stairs instead of the
elevator
s number three is sore and this is the
most important thing for me if you only
take
one of the five i think this is the most
important one to take
what is the thing that makes you sore
every day what's the thing that makes
you feel alive bold confident
what is that and put it into your
morning routine at some point in your
life you felt bold
you felt unstoppable you felt confident
it's happened to everybody
the problem is you don't feel that way
consistently every day
you go through these bursts these
moments of man i could do such amazing
things
but then the next day you wake up and
you're a different person you're back to
the
i don't know if i can do it i don't know
who am i to go do this crazy thing
that's the problem so whatever the thing
is that makes you feel like you can come
alive that gives you that boldness and
confidence
plan it with intention every single day
into your morning routine
for me what i do is i record a message
on my phone to to instagram to my
stories to
i put it to linkedin and twitter right
now i'm putting it everywhere but i need
to make a message
so i think of somebody that i helped
yesterday i think of somebody who
commented on a video who i met in person
who i coached on my instagram live
somebody that i helped yesterday and
then i make a message
channeling that person i won't say the
person's name but i have them in my head
i need to remind myself that the work
that i do is important
it's easy to get lost in numbers it's
hard to imagine that
two to three hundred thousand people
watched my videos yesterday that's crazy
it's a wild number right it's
wild it's hard like what does that even
mean i don't know i'm just sitting here
talking to a camera in my office and two
to three hundred thousand people are
watching my videos it's crazy
i need to think down to the actual
person i need to think about an
individual
that this matters to somebody that the
work i do
really means something to them and then
i need to record a message and share it
that helps me soar and i do it every day
what is the thing for you
what makes you sore maybe it's watching
the 254 series that i put up
every day maybe it's watching the
espresso videos like this that i
put up every day and some people every
day this is part of the morning routine
is watch an espresso video and i'm
humbled to be a part of your morning
routine
for other people it might be meditating
they might be watching a video or might
be reading a book and listening to a
podcast
i don't care what the thing is but you
have felt bold unstoppable and confident
at some point in your life what led you
to feeling that way
and then demanded of yourself every day
by putting it into your morning routine
the third s is sore it's the most
important one the fourth ask for me is
sweat
this is just about being healthy having
a healthy lifestyle and i want to do
something that makes me sweat so whether
it's a hit workout a cardio workout a
weights workout
i put that into my daily routine because
i want to bust a sweat and i want to
stay healthy into my 40s which is coming
up
and then into my 50s and beyond and then
the last
s for me is scare i want to do something
every day that scares me what i'm doing
right now is i take a cold shower so
after sweating i need to have a shower
don't want to
show up to work all smelly and so hop in
the shower but
right away start turning the colder and
colder and colder and colder and colder
and then right at the very end i go all
the way cold and i freeze
and even just thinking about right now
it sucks
which is the best right you want to do
the thing that scares you every day
you're teaching yourself that i do scary
things
so whatever is scary for you whether
it's taking a cold shower whether it's
making a phone call whether it's sending
an email making a video and posting it
doing scary things teaching yourself
getting that out of the way right from
beginning
i find really helps me people are afraid
to tell the truth you're afraid to tell
the people around you the truth
the truth that could actually help them
that could serve them you're afraid to
tell them the truth because you're
afraid that they're going to judge you
you're afraid they're going to reject
you you're afraid they're not going to
take it well
you're afraid they're going to be
sensitive but you're actually doing
everybody a disservice
and you're going to walk away from the
conversation feeling like i could have
helped them i could have been more
valuable to them i could have saved them
for making a really bad decision a
really big mistake
all because you were afraid to tell the
truth whenever i'm meeting somebody i go
to an event i just came back for an
event
in dallas video marketing world whenever
i'm meeting somebody
that i want to learn from i will start
off saying hey man
tell me why i suck tell me why i suck
if i'm looking at my youtube thumbnails
or my titles or me on camera or any part
of something that i want to improve and
work on tell me why
i suck now why why do that
well it's not just because i'm a glutton
for punishment right i don't want people
just
yelling and raging at me it's because
when you do that when you lead with that
when you say tell me why i suck
it gives the other person the permission
to be honest with you
because they have advice that can help
you they have advice that might be
able to change your business or your
life but they're gonna hedge
they're gonna play it safe they're not
gonna tell you what you need to hear
because they're afraid of offending you
they're afraid of hurting your feelings
and so you open up and you say tell me
that i
suck and why and then invariably what
the answer is is
well you don't suck but you know you
could do this
this and that and they'll tell you what
you need to fix
where otherwise if you didn't lead with
the tell me why i suck
they would hedge and they wouldn't tell
you everything that's on their mind they
wouldn't tell you the thing that you
need the most
which is their honest brutal opinion on
what you do
now it doesn't mean that you suck as a
human you're amazing as a human it just
means you don't have the skill set
you're not good at this
one thing that this person is an expert
at and can help you
and so the next time you're going to an
event or you're talking to somebody who
might be able to help you
lead with it leave it and say i love i
respect you i love what you do
i'm trying to work on this tell me why i
suck
and then watch the honesty come through
you need to make the big decisions
in your life with your heart and the
small ones with your head this is where
so many entrepreneurs
fall down this is where so many
entrepreneurs make mistakes
because you see a trend you see an
opportunity you see something that makes
sense it just makes sense on paper it's
so clear that it's gonna happen
but if it doesn't energize you if you
don't love it if it's not in your heart
to say
i can't wait to go off and do that thing
you're never gonna win
you're never gonna win because you're
going up against people who love it
you're going up against people who love
it who breathe it who sleep it who dream
about it
and for you it's just an opportunity
you're never gonna win big look at all
your heroes all your mentors people you
look up to the people who've done it
like
i want to be like this person in my
field i want to be i want to do it like
she did it like he did it
they love doing the thing they love
doing the thing
doing it gives them energy i look at
what i do i'm
here in dallas i'm about to speak at
video marketing world
an annual summit of some of the top
creators on youtube
to help share give back help the
community give feedback
train on youtube i love doing this stuff
what
am i i'm in the parking lot filming
videos for you guys
not because it's a strategy not because
i need to make a video a day
because i love it this this is this is
the best
i'm about to go into this meeting to
this conference and i'm going to hang
out with entrepreneurs
all day long from the time i get in
there until whatever
time a.m i'm going to be hanging out
with entrepreneurs and helping them with
their business helping them with their
channel
because i love it and if that
sounds exhausting for you amazing don't
do it and if it sounds energizing for
you
yes go and do it you need to make the
big decisions with your heart
and then your head's still important
it's like don't list it's not the
message is not don't listen to logic the
message is not
don't look for opportunities it's look
for opportunities
within the thing that you love right if
i love making videos and i love making
content and i love helping entrepreneurs
but i went all in on my space right now
i'm gonna lose
it's not the right strategy right you
need both
it's working hard plus working smart
it's following what you love doing plus
chasing opportunities
but what takes precedence what's the
most important thing your heart
the energy if you're saying oh man
monday
if that's your mindset around monday
you're doing the wrong thing you're in
the wrong career you're in the wrong
business
you will never be the top player in your
industry it'll never happen for you
if that's your mindset if you're itching
to get back to it if you can't wait to
go to that meeting can't wait to
code can't wait to make that piece of
art can't wait to go and make that video
can't wait to sit down and write lyrics
for your next song
if that's the thing then you're going to
be successful it's not going to be easy
it's still a long road it's still a path
you still have to put in the grind and
the effort and use strategies to help
you get there faster
but it has to start by doing things that
are energizing to you
you're going to spend so much time
working guys you're going to spend so
much time
working as an entrepreneur why not do
stuff that makes you come alive
why not do stuff that gives you energy
and so i want you to get out of your
head i want you to stop making decisions
first from your head i want you to stop
making decisions
only because it's going to help you get
some goal a short-term thinking
and you're never going to win doing it
big decisions with the heart
big decisions that give you energy look
at your calendar are you energized about
the week that's coming up
look at your account go load your
calendar right now load it on your
computer load it on your phone
however you're loading your cat look at
it look at your calendar look at the
week ahead are you excited
are you excited about what you're about
to do if not you're doing the wrong
stuff
if you're only excited about 10 of your
calendar
you're only pouring your genius your
michael jordan level talent into 10
of your time you're not going to get to
where you want to go you need to flip it
even if it doesn't make practical sense
at the beginning
because all great things are made from
the heart
all great things every great business
every great song
every great creation started
from here from a place of passion from
place of purpose
from place of energy and i want to put
some pressure on you guys to go off and
chase it down because
so many entrepreneurs fail and they lose
a lot of money
it's not an easy game but one of the
biggest reasons if not the number one
reason
is because people pick an industry
people pick a business idea
solely because they're chasing an
opportunity down
and they didn't love doing the work
there's a reason why
in my videos i say you have michael
jordan level talent i believe it it's
true you
you have michael jordan level talent at
something you are the best
the absolute best at something in the
world
most people either one don't believe it
they don't believe that they're world
class at something or two
they found the thing that they could be
world-class at but they don't have
enough guts to chase it down they don't
believe in themselves enough
to chase him down here's the thing you
need to first explore
you need to explore you got to search
you got to say yes you got to try things
you don't know that
that tim hortons is your favorite coffee
cup until you've tried it right you
don't know that sushi is your favorite
food until you've tried it
sushi doesn't make sense right this is
how we think our logical brain
starts to analyze things and because it
doesn't make sense we don't try it
sushi doesn't make sense you're gonna
take raw fish
mix it with rice put seaweed around it
and then eat it that sounds nasty
right if you've never tried it before it
sounds nasty
but it's the best a lot of the things
that you might be great at
you are judging you're dismissing
because it doesn't make logical sense
you don't need to wrap your head around
it you need to wrap your heart around it
you have to feel it you have to say yes
and be willing to try it at least once
if you don't know what you're great at
you have to say yes and try things
and you pay attention to the feeling the
most important thing is you pay
attention to the feeling how does it
make you feel you might not be great at
it
i expect not to get results at the
beginning of anything especially if it's
a new skill you're learning right
expect to suck at the beginning you're
gonna suck it's okay it's normal
but how does it make you feel does it
energize you do you want to come back
and do it again
this is why i think 10-year plans are
almost useless because if you are
chasing down your dreams
then your goals will change so many
times over the next
10 years think back to who you were 10
years ago take today's date and imagine
yourself
10 years ago could the person who you
were
10 years ago actually predict what a
great life would be for you right now
today 10 years later if you've had any
kind of growth over the past 10 years
then it's no it's in no way you've grown
so much
the person five years ago two years ago
let alone 10 years ago
has no idea of what you're capable of
and so the danger of creating these
10-year goals for yourself
is you can hit your 10-year goals you
can have a goal
and hit it in 10 years i just think that
it's small compared to what you could do
because if looking back 10 years the 10
year younger version of you
could not actually predict what would
make you happy right now then what makes
you think that you right now
can create a great plan for you looking
forward 10 years you can't
and that's the best now i don't think
goals are useless i think goals are
great i think goals
are a stepping stone along the path of
your dream you have to just make sure
that your goals constantly align with
your dream nobody has the exact life you
want
nobody this is why so many people have a
challenge learning from mentors
because you're looking for one person to
teach you everything that one person
does not exist because you want a unique
life
because the perfect you doesn't exist
out there yet
you have to create it it's on you and so
the way to get through it is to model
from different people
it's to look at i want to learn this
from this person and this from that
person and this from this person this
from that person
and mix all those things together to
build an amazing life for yourself
this is partly why i created my channel
i want to be able to
model success from all sorts of
different people and every video that i
make i've learned something from
all the people that i've profiled i've
learned something from them if i
personally me even chronicle
haven't learned something from that
video then i don't post it
i think too many people settle too early
on in life for the wrong aim
people settle for the wrong business
people settle for the wrong career
people settle for the wrong relationship
because they're in such a rush
to get to their aim that they end up
with a life of suffering
if you don't know your aim yet that's
okay it's normal
and maybe you found it but lost it that
can happen too there may be many times
in your life where you don't know your
aim
the solution is to taste is to test is
to try is to explore
until you find it because otherwise you
live a life filled with regret
knowing that you are capable of more but
you settled for less
reading should not be your priority
learning should be your priority
there used to be only a small number of
ways to learn it used to only be
reading or maybe going to lectures and
learning from people but reading
was one of the fastest ways to learn
because you could take somebody's life
and in one book and that's the whole
thing all the lessons and here you go
chance to learn now though there's so
many different ways to learn
there's podcasts there's videos and so
you need to understand what is the best
way that you learn
reading does not have to be in your top
priority but learning
has to be the difference between where
you are today and where you will be in
five years
that growth will be in direct relation
to how much you learn how much you feed
this brain right here
with knowledge that shifts the way you
think but it doesn't have to come from
reading
so looking at my story as an example i
used to read all the time growing up i
used to read i'm
39 now so i used to read a lot growing
up it was the only way to learn and the
idea of
be able to look at any famous
entrepreneur and look at their story how
they got started
that was a lot of knowledge that that
allows you to step into somebody's world
right if you don't like your environment
you don't like the people around you you
don't want to become
your parents or the people in your
community you want something better you
want something bigger
then you need to start to surround
yourself with those people and reading
is a great way to step
into their world and so i used to read
every single week
not quite every day but almost i was
reading a lot i was voracious
but as soon as video came out i quickly
shifted
i would much rather watch a video then
read a book
i just learn better that way i would
much rather have
an elon musk video watch him and see him
tell his story and look at the body
language
than i would reading a book about
somebody else telling elon musk's story
that's me that's how i learn i listen to
zero podcasts
because auditory is the slowest way for
me to learn
if it was the only way if the only way
to learn was to listen to podcasts and i
would be all over it and i would force
myself to do it
because i love learning but because
there's so many different options and i
love video first
i default to learning through video like
this
videos like this on my multiple channels
and so video is by far number one for me
and i consume video pretty much every
single day of my life
number two would be reading and a huge
drop down to number two i'll read maybe
three to four books a year
and then number three would be auditory
which would be podcasts and i
consume zero podcasts i don't know that
i've listened to an entire podcast
all the way through it would have to be
some person
that i can't find a video or a book on
and the only information the only way to
get it is to listen to a podcast
as long as you love it you have to keep
going
you cannot quit maybe one day somebody
does throw you a bunch of money and you
can stop sleeping in your office
or maybe it's just a slow grind up and
it takes you 10 years to become an
overnight success
you'll never know how long it will take
you to be successful but what you do
know
is that if you quit on something that
you love you will end up regretting it
for the rest of your life
as long as you love it you have to keep
going you can't
quit so look at my story it wasn't easy
being an entrepreneur growing up that's
why i do so much to help
entrepreneurs because i don't want you
guys to struggle as much as i did
in my first real business when i was 19
i had to decide between
earning a hundred thousand dollars a
year and traveling around the world in
my dream job
versus owning 30 of a company making 300
bucks a month
and being unsure if anything's gonna
work out or not and i decided that i had
to keep going i had to try because i
didn't want to
end up being 85 years old looking back
and said i never did it i never went for
it i would rather no one fail than not
know
because the things that you regret are
really the things that you do it's the
things that you didn't do
the things that you had a chance to do
you had an opportunity you thought about
it
you felt it but then you backed down
because you were afraid
those are the things that you regret
that's what you regret most i didn't
want that to happen
but starting off my business wasn't easy
i struggled i suck i i made it harder on
myself because i told my friends
that i was living the entrepreneur life
and i couldn't hang out with them
meanwhile that 20 was just too expensive
for me to go out and have beer with them
right i isolated myself i made myself
lonely
i felt worthless as a human being and
the worst day of my life came when i
told my business partner that i quit on
him
that it was just too difficult that i i
couldn't keep going that
i needed to feel like i was contributing
that that my time meant something that
all this work i was putting into
something
i just need to feel valuable again that
i was contributing to something
because when you wake up every day and
you're working and it's just not getting
results
it can be real hard to keep going and so
i told them that i quit i hung up the
phone and then just started
crying and the next day i woke up and i
just thought i can't
i can't i can't quit on this not yet i
haven't given everything i've got
because i felt like in a year and two
years and five years and 20 years i
would look back and regret
that i gave up if i knew that i gave
everything i had and it didn't work out
i was okay with the failure
it was just an idea of that thing
lingering that i could have given a
little bit more
that i still liked this thing and i
needed to see it through and i
and i didn't that i quit on it i knew
that would eat me up forever
and so i had to get up that next day and
tell myself i'm not gonna quit yet
i just have to find a different way to
stand what i've tried so far has not
worked
it has not worked i'm making zero money
well 300 bucks a month
but it's not working out and i hate
myself i hate my life
i hate how i feel about myself i have to
find a different way to stand
and that energy allowed me to keep going
that energy allowed me to
then ask myself who else has done this
before and i looked at bill gates and
how he started microsoft and that
started the path up
for my business and then two years later
i sold my company
it happened pretty quick all because i
refused to quit
on the thing that i knew i needed to see
through you have michael jordan level
talent at
something but instead of being world
class at that thing
you settled for being just above average
at something that you should not be
doing
albert einstein once said everybody is a
genius but if you judge a fish by its
ability to climb a tree
it will believe its whole life that it
is stupid that's most people's problems
you are a fish and you're trying to
climb a tree instead of going and being
great
at swimming this is the exact problem
that i'm on a mission to solve
so i recently had a young entrepreneur
come to one of my toronto q a meetups
that are free that i host every week
and he said evan i have a problem i'm
trying to decide between
what my parents want me to be which is
an architect and what i
feel a yearning towards which is being a
musician and i don't know what to do
i know how to decide i don't know how
i'm going to be a success as a musician
i don't know how it's going to work out
and my parents want me to be an
architect and there's this clearly
defined path for how to do it
and he's afraid and i think that's so
many people
there's a safe perfect path that has
been designed that
people have done forever and ever and
ever and ever and ever or this is new
crazy messy unrealistic
unsafe unsure path which is following
your passion being an entrepreneur
and trying to figure out where you're
supposed to go here's the thing
if you only go down that safe path if
you only take that job if you only
listen to your parents or other people
and you do what they want you to do
you're always going to be unhappy you're
always going to know that there was this
thing inside you
that you could have done that you didn't
take action on and you hate it
it's never been easier to actually be
yourself and build a business and have
success being uniquely you
right this was not open to your parents
and definitely not your grandparents the
ability to be an entrepreneur
on the side making money using your
phone is something that your
grandparents don't understand it's just
it's totally wild and so you are a
unique individual right you are i am we
all are you have unique
interests personality traits belief
systems you're unique you need to do
something unique
if you are unique you need to do
something unique
if you're stuck doing the same thing
that somebody else wants you to do
you're never going to be happy now there
may be some alignment you may not
absolutely hate the job that you're at
but you know you're capable of more
you're michael jordan
you are the michael jordan of something
you're a genius an
absolute bona fide genius
at something this is why i think it's
the world's greatest problem
this is why i do what i do every single
day and making this content videos for
you because i want to
unlock people hopefully more than one at
a time but even if it's just one person
who watches this video
and gets unlocked i'm pumped because i
think
if everybody is off doing the thing that
they are a genius at
man i want to live in that world every
time youtube updates their algorithm
you should be pumped anytime facebook
linkedin
instagram makes an update you should
celebrate
because this is your chance to win as an
entrepreneur everybody else who's ahead
of you who've made it on the old
algorithm before the update happened
they're complaining and wishing that it
goes back to the way that it used to be
it's not going back and the faster you
can get on that train and understand
how the new algorithm works you are
going to soar past
everybody else so whenever something new
comes along it's going to happen guys
the new things that are coming along
is only going to speed up there's going
to be more new things not fewer new
things
every time a new thing comes along you
don't necessarily need to be the first
one on it
i'm not saying that you have to go off
and try everything but when something
new is coming along
embrace it because this is the future
right so many people say well i'm not on
social media oh that's for the kids
you've got to get on it if you're an
entrepreneur you need to be on social
media
and not just giving it off to your kid
your niece or your nephew to do
you you need to understand it doesn't
mean you need to be the best at it but
you need to understand it
because this is not just where marketing
is going it's where marketing
is your business is suffering because
you don't understand how to play the
game
so rome wasn't built in a day but it
didn't crumble in a day either
if you're not on social if you're not
taking advantage of new technologies
your business is slowly starting to
crumble and i don't want that for you
most people are so afraid to lose that
they don't even
try so when you have nothing when you're
at the bottom
you've got nothing to lose and so it's
very easy to go off and try
but as soon as there are stakes as soon
as you've won just a little bit
now you risk losing something and this
is where most people
back down and play small for life and so
you need to decide
are you playing life to win or are you
playing life
afraid to lose so i look at my youtube
channel as an example
when i started it there was no risk
nobody knew me nobody's watching my
videos i could go and fail
didn't make a difference i could try a
whole bunch of different things whenever
the algorithm changed i got pumped
because the people who were ahead of me
were complaining and would would be
romantic
and would want it to go back to where it
was i'm like hey
algorithm change amazing let's go i'm
going to learn that new thing
but now i've gotten bigger right now i
think i have more views than anybody in
the entrepreneur
space on youtube and it's easy to now be
protective it's easy to say well i built
this thing i don't want to lose and i
hate that
i need to i need to destroy that i want
to be constantly losing
constantly testing constantly risking no
not risking it all
not not putting everything on the line
just for one thing
but to be willing to test willing to
fail as an example
i split up my channels i split up my
channels into eight different channels i
got an
advice from matt gielen he's one of five
people who who i
put on my hand as people who i listened
to for youtube advice
right he was one of the five and another
one of the five said
don't do it so i got five people who i
listen to about youtube
one person says split up your channel
one person says don't do it what do i do
i have to do it just to see because i
know what not splitting up my channel
looks like it's what i'm currently doing
but splitting my channel i won't know if
it's gonna work or not until i actually
go off and do it and so i did and here's
a news flash
it's not working yet right my other
channels the most i think has 8
000 subscribers i have two around 8 000
subscribers and the others are
smaller and they're growing every day
and they're gaining momentum every day
but overall
my subscriber growth is down my views
are down
my revenue is down everything is down
it's all down watch time is down
everything is down is it a big failure
i don't know maybe i'm going to give it
more time and see
i'm going to give it more time and see
it's a risk right i went from making
three videos a day
on one channel to making one video a day
across a couple channels
and then you know once a week on some
channels and we have eight different
channels now
it's more headache it's more management
maybe ultimately it will work out or
maybe
in six months i'll come back and say man
that was a giant
failure that sucked
but i won't know until i try and that's
that's where you need to risk it that's
where you need to try you need to see
you need to test you need to taste it
humans are built to serve you want to
help people it's hardwired into us
serving other people touches the same
part of our brain
as eating food and having sex you need
it
but how do you serve what is your
purpose how do you find your passion
i'm gonna answer that in this video so
earlier this year i went across
90 days 23 cities across the u.s on a
tour
speaking tour and in my head my plan was
to talk about how to overcome
judgment how to take the two percent
difference and just start acting on your
ideas and i had this
template for what i wanted to talk about
and as i started getting more questions
the single thing that came up over and
over and over again from 23 different
cities across the entire country
from pittsburgh to san diego and back
was how do i find my purpose what's my
passion what am i supposed to be doing
and in every single city i had to walk
people through this process
and because it became so important i
started to write a book on it because
i basically went through interventions
with people where i had them stand up
and
and had them go through a three-step
process that i'm going to walk you
through
in this video in a minute and they got a
result
and suddenly after years or decades of
no clarity they had clarity on what they
should be doing and what their purpose
was what their passion was and what
their path forward was
step one is who step two is why and step
three is how
so let's start with step one it's your
who it's your most important core value
humans are built off of core values
and there's one that's more important
than all the others if you had to decide
what is your single most important core
value what is it you may not know
exactly but you're gonna get pretty
close just just go down this thought
exercise for now
what is one important core value that
you hold
that if if people around you were the
opposite of it it would be toxic to you
it's important to figure out because
when people don't know what their most
important core value is you get pulled
into a whole bunch of different
directions you get pulled to
follow somebody else's purpose somebody
else's mission and settle for it but
what you're settling for is crumbs
it's crumbs of purpose because it's
their purpose that you're just kind of
helping instead of you actually living
your purpose
makes a massive difference it starts
with what is your single most important
core value
and you can look at that by what are all
the things that have made you come alive
in the past the people you love
the relationship that worked out that
the thing you learned from your teachers
the most
why you love those people so much is a
common thread and when you figure that
out
it allows you to build a better life and
business going forward with intention
around your most important core value
and bringing people alongside your
mission to support you
so you're working with the people who
are like-minded instead of having
a random assortment of people who might
have great skills with different values
and it doesn't work out
step two is your why this is your
purpose your purpose
comes from your pain your purpose comes
from your pain
think about the most painful moment you
had growing up in your past
it doesn't have to be from eight years
old maybe it was something that happened
two years ago but the most painful
moment in your life what was it
where you felt not physical pain but
emotional pain that you felt worthless
as a human being
when did you feel the most worthless as
a human being that moment
helping other people is built into you
right humans are built to serve
but helping people who are exactly like
that will be the people that you love
helping for the rest of your life
because whether that was two years ago
five years ago 20 years ago
let's just say it was five years ago for
this example the person who you were
five years ago
you've grown a lot since then you may
not be out of the woods you may not have
figured it all out this you're still on
your journey you're still learning and
growing
and you never want to stop learning and
growing but you're way better than you
used to be you're way better than you
were five years ago
now there's a lot of people who are
exactly who you used to be
five years ago and they're struggling
and they need help
and they need guidance and they're
afraid and they don't know what to do
you can help them just like the version
of you right now could go back five
years and help the person who you used
to be
there are a lot of people who are what
you used to be
they currently are what you used to be
you can help them and helping them it's
not just a matter of you can
it'll fill you up it'll never get old
for the rest of your life
your purpose comes from your pain and
then step three is your how this is your
passion
so how did you get out of it how did you
solve the problem again you might not be
totally out of the woods you're still
learning and growing amazing but you've
learned a lot
since the person you were five years ago
how did you get out of it what did you
do
was it watching youtube videos was it
meditation was it
getting in shape eating better food what
was it what did you do what did you do
to save yourself
that was not a random occurrence that
was not something that can just work for
you
that's a recipe that you can apply to
help other people as well
the path that you took to get out or at
least get a little bit better than where
you used to be
is something that is teachable that you
can help other people with as well
and give them hope and give them
momentum and give them confidence
and again that will fill you up for the
rest of your life your fear of other
people's judgment
is the single biggest factor holding
back the success
of your life you want to serve others
humans are built to serve others
you need it it's your purpose but
serving
requires someone else and as long as
you're worried about
that person's judgment and opinion of
you you'll stay still and never act
so you've got one foot on the brake and
one foot on the gas
pushing hard spinning your wheels and
never going anywhere
knowing that you're capable of a lot
more but afraid to take action
i don't tell a lot of stories about my
parents they had a huge impact on my
life they're here
on the wall behind me i'm eight or nine
years old and that's them above me
they're really private people so i keep
the stories that i share about them to a
minimum
but one of my favorites are when i was
in school
i was in art class and teacher told me
to do a project and he said paint a
window
and so i painted a window and then i
added a sailboat and i added
sunshine and i painted i had had some
curtains and i added a lot more to the
painting
and i failed the assignment because the
teacher said
i asked you to paint the window and you
did all this other stuff and so my
parents went into school
later on and said hey uh what was the
assignment that you asked evan to do and
said well paint the window like well he
clearly
painted the window i mean he did what
you told him to do
and and they they stood up and became a
shield for me
and i was blessed to have an amazing
parents you might have amazing parents
you might not it doesn't matter either
way
but wherever you learn and however you
learn you have to learn it
that you need to go off and express
yourself you need to go off and create
the thing that you want to create
even if the rules tell you that you
can't do it even if your teachers tell
you
that that's crazy even if your parents
tell you you'll never make it and they
want you to do something safe
and practical you have to do it because
otherwise you're teaching yourself to
play small
and that permeates for life you have
ideas you're a genius you've got michael
jordan level talent or something
you should be off creating amazing
things but you're afraid because of
other people's judgment and as long as
that is the thing
that is in the back of your head that
you're not afraid of failing you're
afraid of failing in front of somebody
else
you'll sing in the shower but you won't
sing on the street because you're afraid
of what other people are going to think
about you and as long as that is the
reason why you're not taking action
then you lose for life you love
difficult things
you do difficult things are amazing
difficult things are the best
difficult things are the only way that
you grow think about it
what's the opposite of difficult easy
safe inside your comfort zone boring
the single greatest thing that you can
ever do for your confidence is teach
yourself that when
things get difficult you don't shrink
down you
rise to the occasion so in my keynote
presentations i used to always use
slides as well i had powerpoint up and
and i wouldn't read the text off of the
slides but i have a picture
and i tell a story about it and it would
always keep me focused on where my
presentation was going
and then i got offered to do a speaking
gig in paris that was the keynote speech
at this big event for this software
company and i was gonna close the show
for them and i had this idea in my head
that what if i didn't do slides
what if i spoke on stage for i forget
how long 45 minutes to an hour
closing keynote and i just had one slide
and it was a picture of a rabbit because
i was telling a story but
trying to teach a rabbit to climb a tree
and
it scared me i thought it's difficult
and because that's what i thought then i
had to do it because in my head
is well what if i don't remember where i
go what if i forget the stories what if
i
lose track of where i'm at and i'm
sitting here on stage the closing
keynote been paid all this money to come
and i just suck and because that was the
reason that i had to do it
i had to do it so i said i'm just going
to have one slide
and when the tech team said hey what do
you want to show on screen
here it is it's just one slide yep no
videos nope
no audio nope one slide that's it put
that up
and i practice and i practice and i
practice and and because my greatest
fear in the world disappointing people
i probably over practice and have my
speech down and i went and crushed it
but even if i didn't it was the
willingness to try it's the willingness
to do difficult things that as soon as
you
feel yourself playing potentially small
based off of something being difficult
that means it's go time that means you
have to do it because teaching yourself
that you think of something that's big
and scary
and then you crouch down and you shy
away and you don't do that
that's that's an ongoing lesson that
you're teaching yourself that you suck
you're telling yourself if i went and
said what about doing just one slide
in france right for my paris keynote
what if it's just one slide and i'm
scared of it
and i don't do it i'm teaching myself
that i suck
that's what you do anytime you approach
something big and you don't do it you're
telling yourself you're not capable
you're telling yourself that you suck
and so
everybody else might let you off the
hook you may not even tell anybody else
about this crazy idea that you have
but you playing small is not acceptable
when something is difficult you have to
attack it head-on
to make a real change you have to hate
your life
good is the enemy of great if you're
good
you're good it'd be nice to have more
but you're not willing to do the crazy
scary painful things
that require to get great because you're
good
you need to realize if only for a few
moments
that you hate your life you hate it
you're capable of more
way more this is nowhere near this is
nowhere near maxing out this is nowhere
near the max of your capabilities
you should hate that you need to hate
that and then you make a powerful
decision to change
so if you've ever been to a tony robbins
unleash the power with an event a three
and a half day event his most powerful
exercises that he does
is his dickens exercise and what he has
you do is write down
your limiting beliefs he has you write
down what are the things that that you
do that
is holding you back the belief system
you have that is holding you back the
things that you know you need to act on
that you're not doing why is it that
you're not doing it and what is it
holding you back from accomplishing
and that's a great thought exercise but
unless it's emotional
you're not going to take action right
you know
fixing that would be nice it'd be good
it'd be nice right yes but you still
like your life
it's the problem you don't hate your
life you're not desperate enough to make
that happen you think well i'll do it
tomorrow i'll do it next week i'll do it
next year no you need to hate your life
right now or that thing will never
happen and so
what tony has you do is you take those
three limiting beliefs
and then you project forward and it
takes you down i think five years and 10
years and 20 years into the future
so now you imagine your life five years
into the future that thing that you're
afraid to do that thing
that you have in your head that limited
belief of yours you haven't fixed it yet
what's the result what happens what do
you look like in five years that you
still haven't done the thing
what happens during five years and then
in 10 years and then 20 years it
takes you deeper into the pain basically
each time
that your life is terrible right you
never fix this thing
you never chase that opportunity you
never go after the thing you know you're
capable of
and he puts so much pain on you through
this exercise
blasts i don't know maybe 20 minutes he
puts so much pain on you
but then it forces you to want to make
the change right now
and then he'll snap you back the idea
isn't let's stay negative forever right
as entrepreneurs we don't we don't want
to do that i don't want to be negative
forever
it's using negativity and negative
forces
in a really acute sense in these little
pockets these little moments to force
you
forward to force you into action because
when you hate something you're gonna
change it
when you've hated something in your life
it's an immediate change i need to make
that change
immediately but again when you're good
you're good you don't do anything about
it
and so whatever it is that you want in a
life you have to be desperate to go and
chase it down you have to
and the only way to do that is to hate
your current situation
raising your game starts with raising
your standards
raising your standards starts with
raising your environment
and raising your environment starts with
a decision
to make it so i just finished my
three-day workshop here in toronto where
i teach people how to become thought
leaders and transform them so they can
take the ideas that they have here in
their head
and blow it out to the world start
building a business making money having
an impact
and i was super fortunate to have two
people there at the workshop
who i've known for a decade plus friends
of mine who i've known for a long time
typically it's people who fly in from
around the world but i was really
grateful to have these two people here
and it was a really interesting
conversation that came out of it from
both of them
and then that led to my wife and other
people who i've known said over the last
two years evan you've really
turned it up a notch you you seem to
have access
a different level and and i want to know
how i can access that too
i know i felt it too i mean it's great
hearing it from these people who've
known me but but i know i felt it too
and maybe you guys have felt it too if
you watch back in my videos that are two
three five years old
you've seen a shift i'm still talking
about believe
a lot of the message is exactly the same
but the confidence the standards the
expectations
have gone up in the videos i've gotten
better
i care more now how did that happen i'm
not some magical unicorn creature
you can do it too it happened because i
chose to
continue to surround myself with
excellence
with the videos i make my videos for me
the top tens that mentor means this year
like i make it for me
because i want to be around excellence
every day
and here's what happens when you're
around people who are pushing the limits
and doing amazing things every day
slowly it seeps into you
it doesn't happen on a daily basis but
it's a cumulative effect
where if you're around steve jobs and ap
janine
and well my parents and howard schultz
and kanye west if you're around them
every day
if they're talking in your ear every day
if you're watching the top 10's and
mentor me
every day you're around it slowly it's
going to seep into you the more you're
around success the more that success
mindset
will seep into you it just will
and what that does is change your
perspective and gives you more
confidence and gives you more courage
and that made me step up that maybe go
and do things that otherwise i would
have been scared to do that made me go
and
do this crazy tour of 90 days 23 cities
when i broke my neck and then kept going
on the tour all of these
things that seemed impossible to me at
the time that then i said
i'm gonna do it the thing that gave me
the strength and courage to do it
is all of the content that i've been
consuming it's the people i've
surrounded myself with who've had
success that make me want to be more
successful myself
where you start from does not have to be
where you end up
you didn't choose your parents your
community your neighborhood you didn't
choose that being born
but at some point you become an adult
and then it does become a choice to stay
exactly where you are or break free
all of your heroes all the people you
look up to all the people you respect
and want to be like
they started with less than what you
already have right now they started from
a worse
upbringing from fewer opportunities of
what you currently have available to you
right now so you have to decide
do you want to win big like they did do
you want to escape do you want to break
free do you want to come back and be an
inspiration
and lift the world around you up or do
you want to blame
complain about where you started and
stay there forever
rejection leads to success all you have
to do is look at the people that you
look up to
look at the people that are profiled on
my youtube channels and what you'll find
is rejection after rejection after
rejection
so rejection lead to success you know
this intellectually you already know
this
but when you get into the situation
where you have to face rejection
then your emotions take over your fears
take over and you don't do the thing
that you might get rejected for
even though you know logically because
in that moment your emotions your fear
are greater than your logic i had a
life-changing fear of rejection
situation happened to me in paris when i
was
18 years old and i was there when i was
on the street
outside the notre dame cathedral and i
had a map in front of me and this cute
girl comes up to me and she asks for
directions
and i wanted to ask her out and i was
too afraid i was too embarrassed i was
too ashamed
i was too worried that i might get
rejected in my head
the only thing to think of was i want to
ask her out
and she might reject me she might say no
and so what did i do nothing now
if i had logically stood to the side
press
timeout you know pause the situation say
evan logically what makes sense
logically you know she might say no
and you're okay you move on with the
rest of your day logically she might say
yes why is why is she coming up to you
asking for directions why is she asking
for directions when
she already speaks perfect french and
she seems like a local
right logically that's what makes the
most sense
logically i should have summoned the
courage to go off and do it
but in the moment your emotions take
over your fear takes over
that idea that you might get rejected
takes over and so what did i do
nothing i let her walk away
and ever since that day i reminded
myself that
i would rather know and fail than not
know
and i use that painful moment to
whenever i am thinking about
doing something i'm afraid of rejection
for afraid of it not working out
then i have to do it that that moment is
what led me to become an entrepreneur
because a year later when i had the
chance to have my dream job and make
100k a year
travel around the world or be an
entrepreneur on 30
of a business and make 300 a month i had
that picture in my head
where i was thinking i can't let this
happen again i don't want to live with
regret i would rather know and fail than
not know
what would the boldest version of you do
think about your mission
think about your goals think about what
you are trying to accomplish
you've got what you're doing now but
think about what the boldest version of
you if you summon the boldest version of
you
into existence right now what would he
or she tell you to do
so when i did my tour earlier this year
it was 90 days 23 cities
and at first i want to do it for free i
love doing free coffee shop meetups
every time i travel to a new city
and i told my agent steve in new york
hey man this is my idea
he said you need to charge for the event
you got to play bigger you got to you
got to do a bolder version of you and it
it's freaked me out it scared me because
i don't want to disappoint people
in the idea of charging for something
and then me disappointing people
and then hitting that fear every four
days
because i got up in a new city every
three to four days for 90 days
was me being able to conquer my fears
and so steve pushed me and i have
steve's voice in my head it's like you
need to play bigger you got to do
something
bolder what's the next step and so i'm
looking at my next tour coming up
in 2020 around my book built to serve
and i'm trying to think how do i make it
even bigger how do i make it even bolder
because what i've done has been great
and it's not trying to take away from
what i've done it's amazing i'm proud of
myself
i'm grateful awesome and i know i'm
capable of more
and i know i need to do something at the
next level because if i want to go off
and accomplish my mission
i need to because at the rate i'm going
right now i'm not going to hit a billion
people
i'm not going to solve the world's
biggest problem i'm not going to have
the impact and reach that i know i can
have
unless i demand more boldness bigger
scale from myself on a daily basis and
so for me
having steve's voice in my head having
elon musk's voice in my head having
steve jobs and ippa giannini and my
parents and kanye west and howard
schultz
constantly in my head the content that i
make is for myself
it's selfish for myself and then i share
with you guys and thankfully you like it
so i could build a business around it
and hire your team and and keep creating
more
what makes you bold what makes you come
alive and how do you
summon that creature on a daily basis
when you
if you wake up and you daily every day
consistently
are bringing the boldest version of you
even for one year if you woke up every
day for one year and someone the boldest
version of you
your life is going to look dramatically
different one year from today
stop thinking that you should be
fearless
if you go through life fearless that
means you are playing small
and not doing anything that is worth
doing you should be dreaming big
you should be pushing boundaries and in
that push
comes fear instead of trying to be
fearless
adopt the mindset that you want to feel
the fear
and do it anyway otherwise you will
never take on big projects and you'll
never accomplish your mission
and you'll always live below the
potential that you know you're capable
of
not asking for help is selfish you might
think
that trying to do everything yourself is
selfless
that it's wrong to ask for help and
noble to do everything yourself
but you love helping people you love
helping others
remember that joy you feel when you help
somebody and brought a smile to their
face knowing you made their week
by you not asking for help you're
cheating people of that opportunity to
bring a smile to their face
stop being selfish and start asking for
help
i came up with this idea when i was at a
video game cafe
so here's what happened i was i was on a
call with
one of my big customers at the time and
i was in los angeles and we're doing a
google live streaming to my youtube
channel
lots of people watching youtube live i'm
interviewing him
and then the internet goes down like
what happened the
power went out across all of los angeles
the power goes out and it and it's down
i got nothing
the stream is still live but i'm not
there anymore i left my client
live on the stream and he's he's not
sure what happens he just sees my camera
goes down
and then he keeps going by himself for
another 15-20 minutes waiting for me to
come back
and he's he's embarrassed and it's
awkward he doesn't know what he's doing
because
the host who has the audience there is
now gone
and then eventually he just leaves
because well i don't know where evan is
but
thank you guys for watching and it put
him in a really
difficult situation i felt terrible i
went back to watching the livestream
after like oh my god i can't let that
happen
now it's out of my control i you know
the internet goes down in los angeles
what am i supposed to do there's no
power anywhere so as soon as the power
gets back up i message
my my client and say hey man i'm really
sorry about that let's reschedule it
let's do it again
when i'm back home in toronto where i
know i have stable internet
and and i want to do it again for free
no extra cost
uh even though we had almost finished
the live stream together
we're gonna do a whole other one for
free just because i want you to i want
to make this right for you
great so we come back to toronto it's
like a week or two later
and my internet is pretty rock solid in
my home office i've never had an
internet
issue really happen while i was doing a
live stream but i wanted to make
extra sure extra sure that this time
nothing happened because if
something happened the second time like
just it would not be a good thing
so i asked my friend jay rise and i said
j rise i need i need a place
that has rock solid internet that i'm
gonna do this live stream and nothing
can go wrong
and he said i got a place there's an
internet cafe that that i go to
i'll introduce you to the owner i know
him and and you can do it there
like thank you so much so we go there
i'm there an hour early i'm setting up
i'm talking the owner
i'm testing the gear my microphone the
headset all of it the camera testing all
of it
just to make sure that everything is
working smoothly i'm nervous because the
last time
it failed on us my client comes on we go
live for
half an hour an hour i don't remember
and and it was smooth
perfect no issues crisp amazing internet
blazing fast speeds great time with the
audience and we delivered an awesome
product
sigh of relief right i'm so pumped i go
talk to the owner say dude thank you man
it was perfect no complaints no problems
thank you so much
how much do i owe you and he said well
you were on the computer for about an
hour and a half and
j raj is on the computer for about an
hour and a half but i'll just bundle it
together so
i think what he told me is like five
bucks or seven bucks or ten bucks or
something like are you kidding me
i would have paid a thousand dollars i
would have paid a lot of money just to
make sure
that this went smoothly because it's the
it's the relationship with my client at
the time right
i said okay well let me great here's
here's the seven dollars that you wanted
awesome
let me buy let me buy some some stuff
from behind
the counter though let me buy some
snacks from my friend jay rise jarrow's
was hungry
he needed to eat so like here here's 20
bucks 25 bucks let me just
buy out a whole bunch of your snacks and
give it to him he's like no no you have
to do that man don't worry about it like
no i want to do it
let me buy the snack no no don't worry
about it
the owner thought that he was doing a
good thing the owner thought
that he was being selfless said hey
don't worry but you don't have to do it
that just
just paying for the internet was enough
for him but he was actually being
selfish
in that moment he was being selfish
because he
cheated me of the opportunity of one
saying
thank you i wanted to pay more i want to
pay more
you're cheating me of the opportunity to
do it and you're cheating me of the
opportunity to
help my friend jay rise and give him
some food because he was hungry so we
had to go somewhere else
you need to be willing to bring other
people in
you need to be willing to ask for help
yes you don't want to waste your time
yes you want to be respectful yes but
people love helping others we are built
to serve
you want to help other people that joy
that you feel when you help somebody out
allow it to come into other people's
hearts too if you quit on something too
soon that you still love you will regret
it for the rest of your life
if you don't love it anymore quit move
on
you will never win doing work that you
hate but if you
love it you love it and you move on to
something else you will look back
on this day and regret it for the rest
of your life that you did not see it
through
most people spend their entire life
living with regrets
don't let that be you the hardest
decision i ever had to make in my life
was being an entrepreneur i struggled a
lot with the decision do i want to be an
entrepreneur
and had this opportunity to make 300 a
month and earn 30 percent of a company
versus going to work at a job that i
thought i wanted a job that i've been
preparing myself for
that this is what i wanted to do was in
my high school yearbook of this is where
i was going to be
and here it was earning six figures
traveling around the world doing the
investment banking i thought i wanted to
do
versus making 300 a month and only only
and owning 30 of a company and the thing
that allowed me to push through
and be an entrepreneur was me saying i
don't want to live with regret
that i would rather no one fail than not
know and i gave myself a year
i said i'm going to give myself a year
to do this i could always go back
and get another job i may not be the
same job probably wouldn't be the same
job may not be as much pay may not be
traveling as much as this job was off me
to travel
but this entrepreneurial thing this
opportunity that i had
i never knew if it would come back again
i thought maybe this will never happen
to me again
and so i decided to go for it and we
struggled and
it was hard but i never ended up having
to go back and get another job
and so if you're at an inflection point
if you're thinking about
which path should i take a or b
lean in with your heart stop using your
head your head only understands the
world that currently exists lean in with
your heart
and ask yourself which decision will i
regret more
if i don't do and then go take that
action
i became an entrepreneur because i
didn't want to regret
not having at least tried and a great
moment in my life came a number of years
later
where one of the people i went to
university with came back and said evan
i went down that path i became the
investment banker
and i hate my life how do i become an
entrepreneur
and i looked in his eyes and i saw the
desperation and the sadness
and helped him but also was so grateful
that that wasn't me because it could
have been
if you want to figure out your purpose
you need to figure out what you stand
for as a human i brought a whole book on
it it's here it's called your one word
it's about finding your most
important core value who are you when
you understand what your single most
important core value is
everything else becomes so much easier
so for me it's belief
right believe is my single most
important core value how does that help
well with every decision that i make
it's seen through the lens of belief
every video content that i make is about
belief it has to be
every interaction i have every workshop
every book every meeting
all of it has to be run through the
believe framework right the glasses i
believe
if i'm hiring somebody onto my team
skills alone aren't enough
it's great that you can write copies do
you believe in entrepreneurs
it's a big difference so when you
understand your core value everything
else becomes clearer and you're less
likely to follow what other people want
you to do
everybody around you they have a goal
for you
even if it's well intentioned they have
opinions on what you should do with your
life everybody around you
this is what you should do with your
life everybody has an opinion you don't
know which way to go
if you don't know which way to go it's
because you don't know what you stand
for because you're standing on quicksand
but when you understand your one word
your who
your most important core value it's like
you're standing on a rock that nobody
can push you from
so how do you figure that out quickly
right i mean this is 200
something pages let's boil it down super
quick for you
you want to think about all the people
that you love
your favorite teacher what you loved
about your parents think about your
favorite musician your favorite band
your favorite song your favorite movie
your favorite book all your favorite
things i think that when you are around
consuming it reading it being with them
it makes you feel bold alive
amazing confident unstoppable right
we've all had those moments
it's just not consistent enough yet
we're gonna make it for you it's just
not consistent enough yet
and so write down a list of five to ten
things that make you come alive again
people
your favorite teacher movies all of
those things that make you that you love
that you love like you could
get lost spending time with them or
reading them or listening to them
then write down three key words that
describe each of them
so your favorite teacher why did you
love mr jones
it's not because he taught you grade
four math right there was something else
about mr jones that you love
why do i love seabiscuit the movie
because it's about
an oversized jockey and an undersized
horse and an owner that has no money and
all of these things and they all come
together it's believe right
my parents taught me that i'm evan cause
really carmichael i can do anything that
i believe that i can
right and so through all the things that
i love believe is the common thread what
is it for you you have to figure it out
you have to figure it out it doesn't
have to take you years of work just
write down
all of the people and the things that
you love three key words for each like
do this
this is important just do it today it'll
make a huge difference in your life it's
worth it this is the best
15 minutes you can spend in your life do
it
pause the video and do it and then just
see what comes up consistently
what word comes up over and over and
over and over and over and over again
chances are
that's your one word that's your who
then when you discover it you have to
start living that life
so you know if my word word is believed
then i got to think okay who around me
is not believe what am i doing that does
not believe what projects am i working
on that are not believe and it gives you
clarity
and forces some tough decisions and the
more unhappy you are right now in your
life for business
is because you are out of alignment with
your one word
if i was doing something that was
anti-belief if even i've made tons of
money i'm not going to be happy because
against who i am it's against my core
value
same thing for you if you are unhappy
it's because you're doing things that
don't align well with your core value
and you don't know what your core value
is most people never manifest their
ideas because you don't
trust your ideas that bold idea that
came to you that made
sense to you in the moment the next day
feels too bold
too crazy too insane to not for someone
like you
i believe that the decisions that come
to you when you're feeling bold are
actually the right ones for you and you
have to take
immediate action on because otherwise
your head gets in the way
and talks you down from doing the things
that you should be doing so right now
i'm in the process of looking for
a creative director for my business
someone to
look at all my content suggest ways to
make it better to
to be focused on the branding and
opportunities for me
and this was a suggestion from mark
drager friend of the channel a long time
personal friend of mine as well
he helped film my very first video he's
the reason why i did top 10 moves to
success
long story with mark and he said evan
you need a creative director for your
business creative director or brand
manager or ceo
somebody to be in charge of all the
creative decisions
and getting me out on the stages that
they need to be out on so how do we make
these videos better
that's that person's role and so in my
head
when he first said it i'm i'm a little
afraid i'm scared like
how do i find this person i need to vibe
well with them i don't i can't just
bring anybody into that role
i'm i'm a pretty weird duck and so this
has to be a good you know long-term fit
for me
how much is this person going to cost
how do i fit into my cost structure
right now with my business
how are we going to deal with conflicts
it's all of the negativity all of the
things that
are reasons why it's not going to work
and so in setting to focus on
this is a bold idea and i need to at
least
explore it i need to try it i need to
play it out maybe it works maybe it
doesn't
but teaching yourself teaching myself
that i do bold things
i do scary things i do difficult things
and being scared is not a good enough
reason for not to take action
and so those ideas that come to you
trust that they came to you for a reason
if it came to you and you're thinking
about it and you feel both like man i
would love to go off and do that the
best thing you can do is just start
going off and doing that
because what's going to happen is you're
going to plan plan plan plan plan
you're going to spend all your best
energies just stuck in planning mode
instead of actually going out and taking
action you're going to tell your friends
about it they're going to tell you it's
a stupid idea
you're going to sleep on it you're going
to wake up and tell yourself it's a
stupid idea
and then what happens is no momentum the
biggest thing that is missing
from your life is momentum
nina's happy i'm just smiling she's next
to me filming that's always missing
you're a genius you have great ideas
great
genius amazing ideas you're just missing
momentum
because once you get the idea you sit on
it and then you tell yourself
why you can't do it instead of going off
and proving to yourself that you can
self-love comes from doing difficult
things self-love comes from
doing things that you think are beyond
your comfort zone that you're not
capable of doing
and just getting up and trying to do it
that's when you love yourself
when something is easy and you win you
actually don't feel that great about
yourself if you were to go and
run a race against three-year-olds and
you won great yeah
you won you might even post about it on
instagram but you don't love yourself
you don't feel good about yourself
because you played small because it was
easy because you were expected to win
because it was inside your comfort zone
when you play inside your comfort zone
always you don't love yourself
it comes from doing difficult things
that's how you build respect that's how
you build credibility it's how you build
self-love for you forget about how other
people respect or look at you
it's how you feel about yourself that's
the game and that comes from doing
difficult things
so if you ran a race against
three-year-olds and you won great who
cares you don't feel great about
yourself because you were expected to
win
but if you ran a race against usain bolt
and he ran backwards on one leg he would
still probably destroy you
but you should feel great about yourself
because you did the thing
when it was hard to do the thing you
might have lost to the same boat but you
got in the race against him
that's how you build self-love when you
tie yourself respect when you tie your
self-worth
when you tie yourself love to the effort
that you put in on a daily basis
that's when you start to win when you
tie yourself love to winning
to getting results you lose when you tie
your self love to how many likes you
have on instagram reviews or subscribers
on youtube
you lose it's about the effort are you
putting in the effort every day
because if you are proud of your effort
on a daily basis i promise you you are
going to crush it
but if you are only proud of yourself
when you win here's what's going to
happen
you're only going to take on small
things you're going to play small your
entire life
because you're only gonna take on
projects that you have a pretty high
chance of winning that
because that's how you have love for
yourself and that's a losing game
because you're capable of more you're
capable of doing a lot more stuff
you keep a little playing a bigger game
you're capable of having a bigger impact
you have to it's your duty it's your
duty to love yourself
when you love yourself you'll be able to
spread that more and help other people
and so how do you love yourself it comes
from doing difficult things
it comes from when your heart's beating
like crazy and you're scared
and it's a big project and you say i'm
going to try
i'm going to try to do that scary thing
i'm going to try to record a video in
public
where people may be watching you doesn't
mean your video has to be great chances
chainsaw's gonna suck
but you tried and you should feel great
about yourself
you have michael jordan level talent at
something
but instead of being world class at that
thing
you settled for being just above average
at something that you should not be
doing
albert einstein once said everybody is a
genius but if you judge a fish by its
ability to climb a tree
it will believe its whole life that it
is stupid that's most people's problems
you are a fish and you're trying to
climb a tree
instead of going and being great at
swimming
this is the exact problem that i'm on a
mission to solve
so i recently had a young entrepreneur
come to one of my toronto q a meetups
that are free that i host every week
and he said evan i have a problem i'm
trying to decide between
what my parents want me to be which is
an architect and what i
feel uh yearning towards which is being
a musician and i don't know what to do
i know how to decide i don't know how
i'm going to be a success as a musician
i don't know how it's going to work out
and my parents want me to be an
architect and there's this clearly
defined path for how to do it
and he's afraid and i think that's so
many people
there's a safe perfect path that has
been designed that
people have done forever and ever and
ever and ever and ever or this is new
crazy messy unrealistic
unsafe unsure path which is following
your passion being an entrepreneur and
trying to figure out where you're
supposed to go
here's the thing if you only go down
that safe path if you only take that job
if you only listen to your parents or
other people
and you do what they want you to do
you're always going to be unhappy you're
always going to know that there was this
thing
inside you that you could have done that
you didn't take action on
and you hate it it's never been easier
to actually
be yourself and build a business and
have success being uniquely you
right this was not open to your parents
and definitely not your grandparents
the ability to be an entrepreneur on the
side making money using your phone
is something that your grandparents
don't understand it's just it's
totally wild and so you are a unique
individual right
you are i am we all are you have unique
interests personality traits belief
systems
you're unique you need to do something
unique if you are
unique you need to do something unique
if you're stuck doing
the same thing that somebody else wants
you to do you're never going to be happy
now there may be some alignment you may
not absolutely hate the job that you're
at
but you know you're capable of more
you're michael jordan
you are the michael jordan of something
you're a genius an
absolute bona fide genius
at something this is why i think it's
the world's greatest problem
this is why i do what i do every single
day and making this content videos for
you because i want to
unlock people hopefully more than one at
a time but even if it's just one person
who watches this video
and gets unlocked i'm pumped because i
think
if everybody is off doing the thing that
they are a genius at
man i want to live in that world hope
without action leads to pain and
suffering
watching videos like this is not enough
it might give you hope
but hope that is not tied to action and
you doing something
will mean you never accomplish your
goals the answer is always action
it's hope and then action and when that
doesn't work out more action and when
that doesn't work out
more action so a couple years ago i was
in new york and i was meeting with my
agents
and one of them said what am i trying to
do what's what's my vision what's my
mission what i'm trying to accomplish
and i said i wanted to spread belief i
wanted to spread hope
and he jumped all over me about the hope
like you want to spread hope
hope's not enough you can't just do hope
and and i remember walking away he's
like what's he talking
hope is so important if you don't have
hope how are you going to
believe in yourself to go chase
something down without hope you got
nothing
right without hope and belief you got
nothing
where i realize the difference in the
thinking is the usage of the word is
people
hope things will happen it's not having
hope in something
it's hoping that it's gonna happen and
then they sit on their bed
sit on their couch sit at home and do
nothing that kind of hope
that's not a strategy hope and belief is
your first step
it's your first entry point in you have
hope that things will happen
but then you got to get up and do
something right
and so figuring out that message when i
was talking to my agent didn't come to
you right away in the moment
because at the same time as much as i'm
filled with hope and belief
in humanity and what we can all do i'm
working
right i'm taking action i'm making three
to four videos every day
we haven't had a day in the past five
years where video hasn't gone up
every single day i don't know what that
consecutive streak is but it's long
it's big i'm working my face off every
day
in the achievement of my mission but i
also love hope and belief
it's why i have this channel so i have
my other channels i want i want to be
around people who've done a lot more i
want to learn from
the greats i want to learn from people
who know more than me and when i
see that it gives me hope that it's
possible
it gives me belief that it's possible
that if they can do it i can do it too
but you still have to do it the ability
to do it versus actually
executing and doing it are two very
different things
right the difference gap is going to be
the action and so
yes i want you to have hope i think it's
important but it's not the only thing
you got to make sure you turn that hope
and not just rely on the strategy but
you're doing the daily work to chase
down your dreams
people aren't lazy they just don't have
dreams that inspire them they
default to thinking i'm a lazy person i
don't have ambitions i don't know what i
want to do in life i'm just
i'm just a loser no you don't have a
dream
that makes you want to go off and do
something and until you figure that out
you're going to be in this constant
cycle of feeling like a loser
it's one of the most common questions
that i get asked on my ig streams i go
live every single day on instagram
at least right now while i'm on my tour
and every single day i get asked some
variation
of evan i'm lazy how do i get out of it
evan i'm procrastinating
how do i get out of it one you don't
call yourself a lazy person there's no
such thing as a lazy person
if you are procrastinating or you're
being lazy but you are being lazy
doesn't mean that you are a lazy person
there's two reasons why you're doing it
there's two reasons why you are being
lazy
one you don't have a dream that's big
enough you don't have something that
inspires you you don't want to get out
of bed in the morning if i was an
accountant i would be a really lazy
accountant i would hate my life
not to knock accountants it's just not
for me if i was a video editor
i would be i would be lazy i would hate
my life i don't want to be a video
editor i don't want to be an accountant
actually there's most things in the
world that i don't want to be and if you
forced me to do that i would be lazy
that's 95 of america i think 95 of
america wakes up and drives to the job
that they hate
and then they're lazy there but they
have dreams
they have ambitions you have michael
jordan level talent at something
you just have to find it and so if you
don't know what that thing is then it's
your duty to go off and explore
you test you try you see you say yes to
a lot of stuff like this is the most
important thing that you need to figure
out in your life if you don't know what
your dream is
you have to go off and try things just
like you won't get married until you go
on dates
you won't get married to an idea until
you go on dates until you try it until
you say yes
and the asset test is did i like it do i
want to go back does this fill me up did
i enjoy the process of it can i see
myself doing this and having fun because
when you're having fun
doing the work
that's when it will fill you up that's
when you won't be lazy
and there has been times in all your
lives where you felt that we felt the
joy the energy the ambition the drive
and so you need to capture that and say
yes and find what it is that your big
dream
is everything in your life will change
when you realize that you do not want an
easy life
stop praying for easy stop praying for
convenience you don't want it
because you don't want to photocopy your
life every single day over and over and
over and over again
you want variety you want change you
want something different
but with that variety comes uncertainty
comes pain comes challenges and from
that pain comes purpose
ultimately your purpose comes from your
pain and the more pain you go through
the more challenges you take on the more
you stretch yourself in your comfort
zone
the more you're going to be able to
reach down and help somebody come up to
your level as well
you can only help people to the extent
and you have been through
something so the next time you're going
through some pain tell yourself
this is the best because it's your
chance to show yourself
and the world what you're made of and
will define the impact that you will
have
most entrepreneurs don't charge enough
you're so worried about getting rejected
or losing clients because of a higher
price
that you'll charge just enough so you
stay just above
their survival line that's not how
winning businesses are built
if you can't break your survival
mentality you'll stay in survival mode
forever
so the first brand deal that i ever got
was for 500
from a major telecommunications company
and they wanted me to write for their
website
and they hired me they hired nine other
people to write an article and they said
write 300 words we'll pay you 500 bucks
and for me 500 bucks at the time i
thought this is great
it's amazing i got my first deal 500
bucks is cash
i'm pumped but more important i'm
getting a link from a huge company and
for anybody
back in the old school seo days if you
get linked from a big company
that can mean a lot for your business to
take off for rankings so i would have
done it for free just for the link
so they gave me the 500 bucks but i
didn't just write the 300 words
because i wanted to give more value i
wanted to get paid
based off the value that i could provide
and so i had to show them
here's how much value i can bring and so
instead of writing 300 words
i wrote 1500 words right five times more
than what they asked
and then i made a video talking about it
and then i also promoted it to my
newsletter
list promoted to my audience let people
know when that article came up
here it was and so what happened as a
result of me doing all this work
i was the only one doing it so when they
came to the end of the series
i had my posts that were crushing it and
the nine other people were doing what
was asked the 300 words
the bare minimum what is asked of you is
the bare minimum
that's your ticket into the door if you
just did what they asked that's not
enough
that's not giving them insane value and
so i was the only one that they hired
10 of us went in i was the only one who
kept going because i brought them way
more value
now i started charging more what i was
doing i went for 500 bucks
per post to a thousand to fifteen
hundred to two thousand
kept increasing my prices because i was
bringing them the value and they could
see it
the thing that you keep getting
distracted by might be the very thing
that you should be focusing on
so many people keep asking me hey evan
how do i stop getting distracted how do
i focus on my work
if you keep getting distracted is for
one of two reasons
either one you don't like the work that
you're doing or two you're afraid of it
working out
the solution isn't to keep avoiding it
the solution is through
and chances are that thing you keep
getting distracted by
is actually the thing that you should be
focusing on you just don't know how to
make it a business
yet now i'm a big believer and as soon
as you get an idea you test you try you
tinker you experiment idea to action the
two percent difference let's go let's go
let's go
so a quick example with my top 10 series
when i first started the top 10 series
i didn't think it would become a series
i didn't think it would become
this huge thing that then later defined
my channel and became
the most popular series on my youtube
channel it started off because a friend
of mine mark
posted a blog about kanye west and how
he interrupted taylor swift
and this was multiple years after he had
actually done that and like
come on man you can learn from kanye
dude
stop hating on kanye yes he gets himself
into trouble
he deserves it but he's also a genius
he's also someone that you could learn
from
he's won more grammy awards than anybody
at his age he convinced john stevens to
change his name to john legend
because it had an old school voice
there's all these amazing stories about
kanye that you can learn from his
success
and so i thought forget this i'm not
just going to complain i'm going to take
action
and i'm going to make a top 10 rules for
success from kanye west
and i went out myself and researched all
these different clips
and i put them together and sure there's
a lot that you can't learn from kanye
there's a lot that you don't want to
model or copy
and emulate into your life and business
i get it but there's still 10 things
at least you can apply and learn from
him to make you a better version of you
and so i just did it and i released it
and people liked it it was meant to be a
one-off video
just to show my friend mark to say just
watch this mark
watch it learn from it you could learn
from kanye
and it was a distraction project right
i'm working on my business
i'm working on trying to create
something mark creates this blog post
and i get distracted by it and think i
want to make a video and i
put my business on hold instead of
saying i
no no forget that idea i need to stop
doing that i need to i need to just
focus and forget all distractions
no i said you know i'm going to put this
on hold because i can't stop thinking
about this
so i'm going to do this get it out of my
system and then i'm going to come back
to my main business
although that little thing that i did
just as a one-off to show my friend mark
ended up becoming
the entire channel you never know
and so it's idea to action that thing
that i got distracted by ended
up becoming the beginning of an entire
series
an iconic series on my channel and it
might be the thing for you too
your story is the secret to finding your
purpose
the thing that you feel is holding you
back and that you're afraid of is
actually the thing that you need to lean
into so that you can help
other people your purpose in life comes
from your pain
and you can either succumb to that pain
and let it control you for life
or you can use that pain to change the
world
so my biggest pain was being an
entrepreneur and struggling and
suffering and making 300
a month and only 30 percent of a company
and turning down
extremely high paying jobs to go off and
be an entrepreneur and live the
entrepreneurial life
and i was too embarrassed and ashamed to
tell my friends that i was struggling
and suffering and not making any money
and i hated myself and i felt like a
loser i felt like
i was adding no value i felt like i was
getting up
every day and working and working and
working the entire day and not seeing my
friends
and not doing any other stuff that i
wanted to do because i was so focused on
building my business and i wasn't
getting results
like nothing was happening every single
day
and i was tired of living way below the
poverty line and i told my business
partner that i quit
and that was the worst day of my life
that one day when i decided that i quit
eventually i woke up the next day and i
said i can't quit i'd rather no one
failed than not know and i'd
ask myself who else had done this before
who else had built a software company
how can i learn from that person model
their success to build my own company up
but i love helping entrepreneurs now
because i struggled so much as an
entrepreneur that was my pain
should you have a plan b or not depends
on your personality
for some people the only way they act is
if they are all
in if they don't have a plan b if they
burn the boats
but for others the best way to get them
to take action
is actually small starts to taste to try
to test if you want to quit smoking do
you go cold turkey and just quit
or can you use nicorette and slowly wean
yourself off both strategies can work
but it depends on your personality
the same thing applies in business i had
a guy call into my morning show today on
instagram and
he's in a bind he is making a lot of
money he's making 300 000
as a base salary pulling in over a
million with commissions
at his current job but he doesn't want
to do his job anymore he's tired of
doing his job he wants to have a bigger
impact he wants to
make more money yes but he wants to do
something that's fulfilling
you know he wants to do something that
is coming from his soul and he's worried
that
starting over starting from scratch he's
going to lose
all this money from this high paying
salary and he's not going to be able to
find success
great he's an all-in kind of guy
the challenge with alden kind of people
is you can't just do things on the side
the smart safe logical practical way to
do it would be
keep your job and in the evenings and on
the weekends start your business
get it going when your side hustle is
making enough to support yourself you
can quit your job and go all in on that
business
but you have something to fall back on
you've got your business it's growing
right you're making some money if you
can support yourself
part-time from your business then if you
can go full-time you'll make even more
money that's what makes sense it's
practical it's logical
but if you can't do it if you can't stay
consistent because you're an all-in kind
of person
that plan won't work for you the way to
get through it is you have to go all in
take a leave of absence go all in give
yourself a year and recognize that it's
not fatal
whatever job you're at if this is your
problem whatever job you're at you have
a skill set
what's the worst thing that's gonna
happen in the next year
well maybe you don't make it right maybe
your business is zero
right you make zero money from your
business you have to go back and get
another job
at least you know it's better to fail
and to know than not to know
you have a skill set you can go back and
get another job maybe you don't burn the
bridge with your company and you can get
that same job back if you want or maybe
you move on and get an even better job
it's not fatal you're not screwed for
life and if you don't do it you will
always regret it
and so he's wrapping up some of his
deals and then he's going to take a
leave of absence and go all in his
business to find out
to know because this opportunity that he
has in his head
has a limited time frame and if he
doesn't do it he's going to regret it
and hate himself for the rest of his
life
your environment has been perfectly
designed to keep you
exactly where you are the people you
hang with the videos you watch the media
you consume all of it
are perfectly designed to keep you
exactly where you are
right now today if you want to raise
your standards
it starts by raising your environment
first
so a friend of mine and friend of the
channel mark drager from fanta
gave me a really warm message yesterday
and he thanked me for helping
start the process for him to turn from
being a pessimist to an optimist from
being somebody who was always worried
and negative
to somebody who's having more energy
who's seen the light who's becoming more
optimistic who still has a road to go
but is
so far further along than where he was
before and he wrote to me to say thank
you for starting me down this path
he said there was one conversation in
particular that had special meaning to
him
where i told him that i i just really
believed in him that
i saw a lot of people around him i saw a
lot of his peers
and i just thought that he had so much
more potential than where he was
and i think maybe for the first time he
had an extra
bolt of belief pushed into him which is
what i do which is what i'm great at
which is what i enjoy doing
fast forward to now six months eight
months later
he's made major gains in his life he's
he's brought on
new team members he's now consuming
other content that is positive
and optimistic he's changing his
business around he's
investing more in himself he's happier
he's lost a lot of weight he's growing
he's
wanting to strengthen his relationships
he's just seen a big shift in his life
by trying to move more into optimism
instead of pessimism and so it started
with my conversation with him
he then promoted somebody within his
organization to become
ceo whose name was louie and he's also a
massive force for good and positivity he
started consuming gary's content which
is positivity he started consuming tom
bily's content which is
positivity he started now injecting all
these these people and resources into
his life
to make him feel more positive more
optimistic more happy give him more
energy
so that he has had to go take on his
goals and the challenges out in front of
him
and slowly move that needle from being a
pessimist
to an optimist i don't think people are
pessimists to be honest i think
everybody
is born an optimist i don't think people
are born
negative you know i think that's trained
into you i think you're pessimistic
negative because of the circumstances
you had and what was planted in your
brain by the people around you
i think people are good i think humans
are just good i think if we weren't good
we wouldn't be here anymore 99.99999
of people are good right some people
have a little bit of a miswiring up
there and it causes them to enjoy
killing people but
for the most part we're good i also
believe that people are built to serve
i believe that you get happiness from
helping others
by being of service to others that's
what actually makes you happy there
aren't very many happy moments in your
life that didn't involve somebody else
you were helping you were serving
they've shown the effect on your brain
of serving and helping somebody is the
same as food and sex
we're literally hardwired to help others
and to serve
and so if you believe like i believe
that humans are good and humans are
built to serve
then what would cause somebody to be
pessimistic and negative
how sad of an upbringing does that
person have to have had
the programming that was installed
inside them by other people
who just were negative and down on their
life but weren't
inherently bad people the people who
stole from my car in la the guy who cut
me off in traffic yesterday
i don't think they're bad people i still
think they're good people who are built
to serve
just circumstances and conditioning have
led them down a negative path
and so the good news is you can get out
of it just like my friend mark has
who was someone who would who was sworn
to say i'm a pessimist
right i just default to negativity
to now seeing the shift by changing the
people he's surrounded himself with
by altering his environment by consuming
content that is more positive
he's already seen a noticeable shift
over the past x number of months
and that's going to continue to grow
that could be you too
your biggest problem is a lack of belief
the only thing that's holding you back
holding me back
holding your friends and family back is
a lack of belief
it is the world's biggest problem and
that's why i created these youtube
channels
i've seen the impact not just on the
people around me but myself firsthand
myself
the value of having my own channel in
the work that i do i make it selfishly
for myself so that i learn that i get
better that i grow
that i challenge myself and it's often
hard to see it on a day-to-day basis
you may not feel a lot more confident
have a lot more belief from one day to
the next
you might have some big win you might
take on some big challenge and then you
feel good about yourself
but then you fall back down the next day
and you don't see that that's actually a
win
because the win that you had was so
small the growth that you had was so
tiny that on a day-to-day basis
you can't see it that's the problem but
if you consistently are doing the things
like watching this channel or consuming
a podcast or reading the book or hanging
around people
who are better than you who have more
belief than you who who are growing and
pushing
that inspire you if you're around that
every single day
and you look back on your life you look
back in the past x number of months
you'll see how much you've grown you
just will i've seen it in my own
business go back
and look at my old content i started a
new series on my other channel
where it's old oven versus new evan and
the first video we did was 2016 evan
versus 2019 evan and what do you think
and you may not see that big a
difference in me from
last week's video to this week's video
yesterday's entspresso to today's
entspresso
but when you go back three years see it
doesn't even look like the same person
go back 10 years go back and watch my
first videos
go back and watch their first videos the
content was still good the message was
still good but the delivery
the execution sucked because i didn't
know what i was doing
because it didn't have a lot of belief
and i'm still trying to chase the next
level you know i've grown and believed
but i'm never done
the thing that's holding me back it's
still belief it's belief in
the ability to get to the next step
because as you expand your comfort zone
there's still other things that are
outside your comfort zone you don't want
to ever get to the point where you're
not growing where there's not something
outside your comfort zone
but then everything inside becomes easy
right what used to scare you
now is super easy there will be moments
in your business where you will need to
have
super human strength to keep going where
it just demands
everything from you every single ounce
that you have
but if you need to have super human
energy every single day
you're going to burn out and fail so
whenever i want to try something new
when i'm testing something new
i always eat into some of my reserves it
may mean to go off into this new project
i'm going to sleep less i spend a little
bit
less time working on my book or a little
less time working on my youtube channel
right you eat into these reserves
but that's not sustainable if that's
what you're doing constantly you're
going to be unhappy you're going to burn
out you're going to fail
so quick example uh sad guru came to
toronto satguru if you don't know he's a
yogi he's an
indian mystic we did a top 10 on him he
then invited me to come to his event in
toronto and then do a one-on-one
interview with him uh close to the
toronto airport the island
was amazing great time out of that he
says evan i want you to come to my
multi-day event in the u.s i want you to
come be a vp guest there
it'd be amazing to have you awesome but
before you do that
you have to do my seven day program
where you have to meditate every day for
seven days and i think it's an hour plus
every day i didn't have an hour a day
right i mean that's not
part of what i had in my calendar every
hour in my calendar
is accounted for it doesn't mean i'm
working all that time but
i might be spending time with my wife
i'd be spending time with my son
every hour is accounted for and so to do
this i had to eat into some of my
reserves
and so for that one i asked nina said
nina
if you're going to come with me you have
to do this too do we wanna spend our
hour in the evening instead of watching
a show instead of relaxing
to to do this program for seven days for
meditation and she said yes
and so here's the thing we did it for
seven days and we went to the event it
was awesome
if it was something that we were going
to continue if we were going to meditate
every day
for an hour ongoing then i'd have to
readjust my schedule
your success comes from your habits you
need to figure what a balanced life
looks like for you
now ultimately i don't meditate an hour
every night
i do some healing meditation for my neck
every morning
but that habit didn't stick and that's
okay
so when you're testing new habits
testing ideas testing something for your
business
or some emergency comes up that you have
to deal with it's gonna tap
into your reserves you can't be running
your business
at full capacity already you can't be
running your business on zero on empty
because that means there's no extra gear
that means that when
life punches you in the face you can't
handle it that means if you want to try
or taste or test something else
you can't do it because you have no
reserves you have no battery there's no
more gas in the tank
and so that's where a lot of
entrepreneurs live that that's where
it's really troublesome that's where a
lot of entrepreneurs will end up burning
out failing and crushing their dreams
because
you're just running with no gas left in
the tank and so you can stretch yourself
i think that's normal i think that's
okay i think life will hit you in the
face and just when you think it couldn't
get worse
here comes another punch that will
happen but it's making sure that you can
live that balanced life whatever balance
looks like for you
you need people in your life to hold you
accountable because you will
never push yourself as hard as you can
go
you get a personal trainer not because
of what exercises you should do
you can look that up online the real
value of a trainer
is to have somebody right there in front
of you in your face telling you
to do three more reps of that exercise
when you want to quit
when you're gonna tap out and if you
were by yourself you'd say i'm done
and they say give me three more because
all of the growth
happens in that last set if there's
nobody around you to hold you to a
higher standard you'll
always know that there's another level
but you'll be too afraid to reach for
yourself
so let's use me as an example i want to
solve the world's biggest problem
i don't think people believe in
themselves enough it's why i created
this channel and all the other ones i
have and the
books and the speaking and everything i
do i want to go out
and do this impossible thing that's
never going to happen i'm never going to
solve the world's biggest problem and
yet i wake up every day
and i try to do it and i use a
combination of what i call aspirational
mentors which are
people like steve jobs and elon musk and
the people that i profile
on this channel and i also do it from
people who
challenge me one-on-one if you watch my
entrepreneurial advice channel i get
pushed every week
by my agent steve by psychologists in
australia by people who are coaching me
and how to get better
and they push me and they tell me i need
to do more they tell me
i'm being an idiot in these areas like
go this is the homework
and the more uncomfortable i feel during
that process
usually the better the advice is if i
think about the tour that i launched
last year
and now the tour that i'm doing this
year it started
as a free tour and became a paid tour
when my agency pushed me to do it
you need to charge for this and
immediately my heart's boom boom
boom boom i'm scared it means i have to
do it
having people around you who can push
you to do the things that you need to do
who make you nervous who make you scared
who see your blind spots
who cut through your bs who tell you
that's just fear talking
because we'll come up with really
logical reasons why we can't do
something
or aspirational mentors who when you see
how they react to things how they see
things how they
understand the world and then you look
at what you're doing it
forces you to be pulled up it forces you
to take the next step up on the
staircase
you need to do it because your
environment's been perfectly designed to
keep you where you are
your friends your family all of it it's
keeping you exactly where you are
and the difference between where you are
now and where you want to be
and where you can be in a year in two
years in five years in 10 years
is going to be the people you have
around you and how much they're willing
to
push you to believe in you to tell you
what you may not want to hear but you
need to hear
to grow to challenge yourself and get to
the next level
chasing down your dream even if everyone
around you thinks you're crazy
is the only way you're gonna win i like
to say that everybody has michael jordan
level talent at something
everyone yes you you right there you you
could be
the greatest of all time at something
the problem is most of us settle for
something
just over survival something just good
enough to get by
instead of going for something that you
could be the greatest
of all time at the toughest choice i
ever had to make in my life
was whether i should become an
entrepreneur or go take this six-figure
job traveling around the world
in investment banking and i thought i
wanted to be an investment banker
but i had this thing client nine at me
saying i need to at least
try this entrepreneurship path just to
test just to see
nobody in my family was an entrepreneur
i didn't have an upbringing of
entrepreneurship i didn't have
heroes or role models around me who were
entrepreneurs that i wanted to model and
be like them
i thought i wanted to be a banker but
when this opportunity came up
i did not want to live with regret
that's the final
filter through which i made my decision
i looked at the two decisions
this is where you can't just make your
list when you're faced with a really
tough decision you have to make your big
decisions with your heart
and the small ones with the head what do
i do
the the most difficult decision of my
life what do i do do i take this job
or do i try to be an entrepreneur make
300
a month and have 30 of a company what's
that what's the best call
i did not want to live with regret
i asked myself if i'm 100 years old and
i'm sitting on a rocking chair
and i'm in a retirement home and and i'm
i'm about to go this is it this is the
end of my life
when i look back on this moment right
now i look back on it
what will i regret more saying no to the
job or say no to the business
i thought you know what i can always get
another job i could it may not be the
same job
it may not be in asia like this one was
may not be traveling as much but i can
get another job that's similar
this business i don't know if i'm ever
gonna get the shot again i don't know if
i don't know if this will ever come
around again
i'm gonna regret it if i don't know and
i adopted a mentality that i would
rather
know and fail than not no i
hate spending money until i'm making
money i think this is how so many people
end up going broke
you take all the money you have pour it
into your business
and because you don't know what you're
doing yet you fail and end up losing
everything
taking that one shot may mean you're in
debt for the rest of your life
i want you to take a smarter path so i
look at my youtube channel as an example
i've started this channel 10 years ago
it's crazy just over 10 years ago
what a crazy ride but when i started it
i had nothing and i didn't want to spend
my money
on hiring a bunch of people and
investing into gear and equipment
and everything else and so i started by
just asking a friend of mine mark
who's been a long time friend of the
channel if he would come and film me he
had a video production company at the
time
he said mark can you come and film me
for one episode and he did and he came
in and he filmed me
and it was a lot of work and a lot of
editing afterwards
but he did it because he was a buddy of
mine but he wouldn't do
every video like that and so i had to
find other ways
i had to borrow equipment from my
friends
and when i couldn't borrow their camera
anymore i used
the i want i want to pull for my cell
phone but this didn't exist
10 years ago i didn't i didn't have this
capability 10 years ago
i used whatever phone i had whatever
camera i had these tiny little things i
don't know if you remember
the flip cam that i would just prop up
on
on a desk in front of me on a bookcase
and it would tilt
and so the video itself would be a
little bit looking like it was moving
because it wasn't
it wasn't fully stable sitting there on
the shelf i had
sold my business i had made some money i
had another successful business my
website had eight people on my team
but i don't want to spend money until
i'm making money i don't think that's a
healthy practice
maybe i'm a little too risk averse
maybe i care too much about protecting
my capital i don't know there are some
people
who go in and they they take out a huge
loan invest everything they have
and and sometimes they hit sometimes you
hit
that's that's the appeal that's the
attraction sometimes it's gonna hit
but most of the time it's not most
people don't hit their big goals because
they don't
believe that they can because you've
trained yourself that when you set a
goal
and when it gets hard you quit if you're
on a diet
and that food comes in and it smells oh
so good
you eat it you're training yourself that
you set goals
and don't follow through you set goals
and you don't follow through
you set an alarm to wake up at a certain
time and you hit the snooze button first
thing in the morning you set a goal
and you did not follow through and so
now when you set new goals
you've trained yourself you've
conditioned yourself that i'm the kind
of person
who doesn't follow through so instead of
do it anyway i'd switch it to
do it because i said i would sticking
with your goals
doing it when it's hard that's how you
build self-respect
self-esteem and self-confidence you
don't want an easy life
you don't want to sit on the beach and
just be served drinks all day long
that might sound appealing right now if
you hate your life but it's not
what you actually want you want to do
difficult things
your self-confidence self-respect
self-esteem
comes from doing difficult things
you want to be on a hero you want to be
on a journey you want to make an impact
all of the heroes that you look up to
right now look at where they came from
look at the journey they went on
they suffered a lot of pain to get there
you want to follow a similar road
so don't hate the pain recognize it for
what it is
your chance to show yourself and the
world
what you're made of so i recently came
back from doing my tour
22 cities 90 days and i broke my neck
along the way and thank you
everybody for the warm wishes and having
you guys
in my back pocket sending me all the
love every day was was super helpful and
i appreciate you
and so many people saw me doing what i
was doing
with this giant net bricks on with this
huge you know cut and scar across my
forehead
is it this side yeah this is still a
little bit of a scar right there
they saw that and said man you're so
inspiring i see you in the hospital
still doing a live stream and i and
telling myself some bs excuse as to why
i can't get up and go to work
and and that's amazing and that's
uplifting but the real reason why i did
it
why i kept going wasn't to try to be an
inspiration
to everybody watching it was to be an
inspiration to myself
it was to show myself what i could do is
that i'm in pain
every day at the beginning they had this
crazy concussion
but then once that subsided i still had
i still had pain i'm still in pain
that this is months later and i'm still
in pain i'm still recovering i'm still
going through rehab
just that hurts like so much it's crazy
i'm still in pain but i want to make
myself proud i want to be an inspiration
to myself
because when you do difficult things and
you get through it
that's how you build self-love not by
taking it easy and only doing the things
that are
within your comfort zone if you're in
your comfort zone all day long you hate
your life
it means that you're setting tiny goals
for yourself that you know you're going
to accomplish
and you're basically just photocopying
your life every day is the same
is the same is the same and it's all
inside your comfort zone that's not what
humans are built to do you want to grow
you're a hero you want to go on a
journey you want to do amazing things
you want to help others
having a cause will make you feel like a
superhero
it'll allow you to do things you never
thought you'd do and give you the
courage you never thought you'd have
all of your heroes had a cause and if
you want to stop selling sugar water and
change the world
it's time to find yours i love the steve
jobs story i'm a huge fan of steve i
have his poster on my wall as one of
five people that i look up to on a daily
basis
but one of the things that i really find
most valuable about having a cause
is it can allow you to have the courage
to
be the evangelical person even if it's
not naturally who you are i look at
steve jobs and i see someone
who is naturally talented who's a great
salesperson
who has the gift of gab who loves being
in the spotlight
who is that person who likes being up
front and center
and so it's easy to go off and be that
person now you combine that with a cause
and you get a company like apple but
having a cause can make you evangelical
even if you are introvert and shy and
don't like the spotlight
i know because i'm talking about myself
i
am an introvert i don't like talking to
people i don't talk to the person next
to me on the airplane being in front of
the camera makes me nervous
being in front of a giant audience makes
me shy much rather be at the back of a
room
than be the center of attention one of
the things i used to fight the most with
my agent about was
he would say that evan you don't want to
be famous that's a problem
like yeah i don't want to be famous it's
not about me it's about the cause
and recently it started to sink in that
by me becoming more famous i could
spread the message
more but it's one of the biggest things
that we kept fighting over because i
don't
crave the limelight where a lot of
people they absolutely have to have it
but when you have a cause it forces you
to the front
i make videos because i want to help
entrepreneurs i make videos because i
struggled so much your purpose comes
from your pain i struggled so much and
started my business
i want to make the path a little bit
easier for the next generation of people
coming through
i'm making videos and content and
speeches for
the 19 year old version of myself that
needed to hear this stuff
and so i feel it's my responsibility
it's my obligation i have to do it
and it forces me out into stages that
normally i would say you're crazy i'm on
this tour right now
right i gave up a quarter of my year 90
days to hit 23 cities
and do the thing that i'm most afraid to
do which is get up and potentially
disappoint people
every four days by doing another event
and i kept going even though i broke my
neck i broke my neck three weeks ago
in denver and and we kept going i only
cancelled one event completely
and it just got up and kept going and so
having that cause
feeling like the work that you do is
important and meaningful is the whole
thing
your vision alone is not enough doing
what you love
is the number one rule for success from
everybody that i've covered
but doing what you love following your
vision is not enough you need to balance
it with what
actually works this is why so many
people fall down and fail
if you just have a vision but don't pay
attention to the trends your vision will
never happen
it will die within you is simon's vision
is to help people be inspired to go to
work
i love it that's awesome i'm on the same
page that is a joint vision
amazing but how you go about doing it
matters he's not doing it through smoke
signals in myspace
right that era is gone but he's also not
doing it through virtual reality and
hologram simon's coming into your living
room right that era has not arrived yet
how you approach the work matters so how
does simon do it he does it mostly
through his books
right start with why he does it through
his speaking the ted talk that launched
his whole career
right how did simon get his mission to
take off how did simon get people even
aware about his vision
well he started by doing it just helping
his friends right he was he was just
being a good friend helping them out and
he said you should go and speak
and then he created that ted talk and he
blew up
he blew up through his tedx talk that
became a ted talk
and youtube and then through his books
right if he was not paying attention to
the trends if he did not go do his ted
talk if he did not get on youtube
if he did not write the book if it was
not marketing in the era that we are in
right now if he was not paying attention
to the trends that
oh people watch youtube videos oh people
go to ted talks oh people read books
if he wasn't paying attention to those
trends nobody would know simon sinek
that's the problem you start with the
vision 100
just paying attention to the trends is
not enough you start with the vision
but you have to know the trends too it's
always both people aren't afraid of
failing
you're afraid of failing in front of
other people
you'll sing in the shower but you won't
sing on the street corner you'll record
a video but you'll never release it
you'll be your own biggest critic but
you won't at the same time
also be your own biggest fan that needs
to change
starting today so my biggest fear is
disappointing people
i'm terrified of disappointing people
the idea that you would come to my
thought leadership academy
and i would teach you how to win on
social media and get the ideas out of
your head and pay two thousand dollars
to do it
the idea that that you would come and be
disappointed destroys me
and it's led to some positive things and
that i always over deliver i'm always
obsessed i'm always putting so much
value to that even if you only get 10
of the value i'm giving you still more
than made the money that you invested
into any of the stuff that i'm doing
but at the same time it's still this
fear and so i want to attack the fear i
teach myself to attack the fear
and i think you should too and even just
attacking it for the sake of attacking
it is
good even if it doesn't lead to a
positive result for your business
it's good because you're building
strength because you're pushing your
comfort zone because you're getting
better
because you're growing that's worth
something that's a ton of value
because if you can conquer your fear of
doing this one thing
that translates to every year of your
life if you teach yourself to have more
courage
that translates everywhere so maybe
you're afraid of
if you're on a cruise ship and they
bring up couples and they do a game show
you're afraid of what might happen on
that game
do it how does that make you a better
entrepreneur it makes you a thousand
times better as an entrepreneur
because that's the same fear that you
face in your business that fear of going
on that game show on the cruise ship
that fear
of taking your phone and recording the
video in public on the street
these fears that seem like nothing they
show up everywhere in your life
they show up everywhere in your business
and so
learning to tackle them especially in
low stakes
starts building the muscle you go as far
as you believe
you can go when the people around you
say you're crazy
when you're putting in massive effort
but you're not getting the results
where you sit alone and wonder did you
just make the biggest
mistake of your life by starting this
business
that is the time when most people quit
and you
need to believe more because if you love
this thing
if you know that it's going to impact
people and you give up
too soon you will regret for the rest of
your life
knowing that you were capable of more
and you just quit on it a little too
early so i look at my new book as an
example i did my tour across
america met with entrepreneurs all
across america and
found that people were struggling with
the same thing they want to know how do
i find
what my purpose is and turn it into a
lucrative business
every city that i went to even though
that was not the topic i was covering
it came up over and over and over and
over again 23 different cities
and so i thought i'm going to write a
book on this this is going to be my next
book i'm going to take people through
the process
because my process works and it helped
people live in
in 10 15 minutes and they're getting
they're getting new ideas
and and results and here we go like they
understand what path they need to take
finally they have clarity on what to do
next and so i told my agent and my lit
agent like
this is the next book i want to write we
told publishers this is the next book
i'm going to write
and from the start it's been this big
pull
it's been it's been fighting it's we
don't like the title we don't like the
concept
no we're not going to publish it no
we're not going to publish it and i want
to do it by january because i want to do
my next tour across
the rest of the united states east coast
texas mexico
i want to do my next tour so i want to
have my book in stores by that time
and it's been this rough slog where if i
didn't believe in myself that this was
so important with the people who are
looking at it saying no we don't like
this concept
nah it's been written before now this
method we don't believe in
it's easy to quit it's easy to give up
it's easy to say forget it
i just know that it's gonna work i know
that the process helps people
i've seen it with my eyes across 23
cities
over 90 days i wrote the draft of the
book and i gave it to
some beta readers and the number one
piece of advice from people who've read
both my books that you're one word and
then this like this is
this is the better book this is the best
book you've written so far
including my self-published ones and so
what do i do i've got these people who
are my audience who love it and then
these people who aren't my audience but
who make decisions saying now we don't
believe in it
i'm not gonna quit i gotta keep going
i gotta do my tour there's there better
be some crazy good reason for me not to
do my tour
right even if i have to self-publish it
no i'm pretty close to making my deal
making it all happen and and getting
timelines and all that but we don't have
a signed
contract yet and anything can happen
we're pushing the time ones because i'm
pushing the timelines because otherwise
this thing could drag on forever
when you have an idea that you love that
you know can have a huge impact
that's just taking longer than you hoped
it would when people are telling you
that it's crazy
and that it's stupid and that who are
you to go off and do this thing
if you love it you have to double down
on it you have to go in on it
you have to be open to getting help
but if that door closes you try to find
another one and that's the story of
every successful person
you're trying to do something different
you haven't become a shark yet because
you haven't decided that your mission is
important enough
now being a shark doesn't mean that you
have to become
aggressive violent and angry it means
that you're pushing to be the best
in your industry a true leader someone
who makes a difference
and it starts with your mission raise
the level of how important your mission
feels to you
and your entire life changes so i look
at my mission as an example i want to
solve the world's biggest problem
it's never going to happen i'm trying to
solve the biggest problem i think in the
world which is
that lack of belief in yourself the
untapped potential it's what i wake up
every day trying to do
and the more that i put myself in a
position of this thing
matters what i do really really really
matters
the more i can put myself in that mind
frame the bigger my thinking becomes the
bolder i get as a human and as an
entrepreneur
and i look at the path that i've taken
over the past x number of years
i look at being able to collaborate with
someone like eric thomas when he
gave a shout out in his video that would
have been something i wouldn't have
thought of when i first started on
youtube i looked at the relationship i
built with
people like tony robbins and gary
vaynerchuk and grant cardone and the
people that we profile
tony robbins i took the people on my
team to go see him at unleash the power
within i brought
five i think of my people down and we're
sitting up in the cheap seats and then
a year later a year later he invited me
as his personal guest to sit right down
in the front row
chairman invited seating and i'm going
back i leave tomorrow i don't know when
this video goes out but i'll leave
tomorrow for dallas to do it again
it's wild right like it doesn't feel
like that
stuff is possible it comes from shifting
the value of your
your mission i deserve it because what
i'm doing
is solving a real problem and we
often feel like we're not capable of
doing these great things and we downplay
our role and we downplay how important
our mission is and we downplay
what we think we can do that's what
needs to shift that's what needs to
change
you need to feel like the work you do
matters you need to feel like the
mission you're on
means something can have a big impact
and if you're approaching life in that
way
everything in your business changes the
reason why you are not further ahead
is you have told yourself that you are
not capable of it
that's it and you'll come up with really
smart reasons that are based in logic
as to why you're not more successful you
are a genius
you are excellent and so you'll come up
with really smart genius reasons as to
why you are not further ahead right now
but at the end of the day you're just
afraid and you don't think you're
capable
that's what i want to change in you
today so i sat down yesterday with an
entrepreneur
who is an up-and-coming entrepreneur
he's had a job for a long time he's now
in his mid-50s
and he got let go from his job and he
interviewed for another job and it
didn't feel it was a quite fit and
and he didn't get the job but he doesn't
want to go back and get another job
he wants to now go do his own thing but
there's that nine little voice in your
head that says who am i to do this who
am i to be an entrepreneur who am i
to bring value to others who am i to
make money off this idea why not just go
play it safe
and get a job working with somebody else
and his one word was getting down to
saying yes like you have to say yes and
so
this is where it's really important when
you know what you stand for when you
know what your core value is
whenever you see it and then you see
your life not
aligned with it you're gonna be unhappy
if you're unhappy if you need more
boldness more motivation more confidence
more courage look to your most important
core value look look at what you stand
for look at who you are because if your
one word is all about saying yes to
things
then you have to say yes right you have
to go off and do it because otherwise
you live your entire life in regret so
here he is this
this entrepreneur who's now in his mid
50s who's been let go from his job who's
now trying to start up
his own career his own thing just got
his first speaking gig
just getting started with his youtube
channel and podcast and building
momentum
and that's what it's all about he has
all the skills he has all the talents
he's been in this industry
for decades he knows what he's doing and
yet he's afraid he's afraid that he's
not good enough he's afraid that's not
going to work out he's afraid that
people won't find his
expertise his knowledge valuable and i
think that's most people
i think i think everybody's a genius i
think you're a genius i think you have
michael jordan level talent skills at
something
you're just doing the wrong thing and
we're afraid you're afraid to take
action you're afraid to do the thing
and so you'll live your entire life with
regret knowing that you are capable of
more you right now know you're capable
of more
even if your friends and family the
people around you say wow you're doing
such a good job
you know you're capable of more and
you're not living up to your potential
that's most people and why are you not
living up to your potential because
you're afraid of what that means you're
afraid of the obstacles you have to
overcome you're afraid of the
difficulties that you have to go through
you're afraid of being judged you're
afraid of
a failure happening and being
catastrophic and you're not being able
to recover you're just afraid
and so we need to crush that we need to
crush that we need to teach yourself
that you do scary things
most people don't concentrate long
enough on achieving their goals
so what happens you don't achieve your
goals if you're focused on something
and you do it every day consistently you
will eventually get results
but if you're constantly jumping from
one thing to another from one
idea to another from one activity to
another
then you'll never actually accomplish
what you're capable of the problem isn't
lack of creativity or ideas or genius
it's a lack of concentration
and if that's you i want to fix it in
this video today
so let's take a quick look at my youtube
journey i started on youtube over 10
years ago it's crazy it's been that long
and i wasn't very good when i started go
back and watch my first videos they're
all still up there i haven't deleted
them you can go back and watch every
single one of them
see how much i sucked i'm an introvert
this is not natural for me it took a lot
of concentration a lot of focused effort
and 6 000 plus videos later here i am
why because i just kept going
because i kept focused on my mission of
my objective it took me 350 videos until
i wasn't completely embarrassed by
myself
350 videos i had to have my sister come
come to the room with the camera focus
on me press record and then leave
because i couldn't film with her in the
room
and that's my sister how is this guy
going gonna be a youtuber and be on
stage and give speeches and
be a thought leader and deliver
presentations if you can't even
do a simple video with your sister in a
room concentration
focused effort that's the key it's been
every single day we've been uploading
videos
we've done three plus videos a day for
the past five years
every single day i've been sick videos
went up i broke my neck in two spots had
a concussion
videos going up i lost my voice video is
going up all the time
every single day for the past five plus
years it's been at least three videos
across my main channel now my multiple
channels
concentration i'm not very good at this
the point of all this isn't to brag or
say look at me
it's saying that i suck that if i could
do it so can you
the difference is i think a lot of you
guys are way more talented than i am i
look at alex for example who works for
me at tds
he's just so much more naturally gifted
in front of the camera he's funny he's
charismatic
a lot of stuff that i'm not and i've
been slowly grinding away
getting better in front of the camera so
i think a lot of you guys are actually
better than me
or better than what i was and if if you
just kept going if you just kept working
on it
you would you would improve and you
would have the results you're after
you're just not
patient enough you're not concentrating
enough you're not putting in the work
every single day
this great story comes to mind that it
is great and sad at the same time
i was meeting a friend in orlando
another influencer
um six years ago or so
and we met up and he said i'm going to
be the next gary vee
okay great i love it pumped like let's
go i'm just starting my youtube career
really starting to take off and he wants
to be his thing and he's going to be the
next influencer i love it
and then he posted something about a
year ago or so and he said
you know five years ago i met evan at
this place in starbucks in orlando and i
told him i was going to be the next gary
vee
and he was on his career to build his
youtube channel and
fast forward now and evan's got you know
a million million and a half subscribers
and i'm still kind of where i was
because i didn't put in the work
and so that's what i don't want for you
right he just he has talent he's a
genius so are you
he just didn't do the five years of work
that i did
and he's someone who's actually i think
way more charismatic than i am and so i
don't want that for you i want you to
concentrate on your effort which will
then lead to results
and i'll give you a three-step process
that you can follow to help you get
there
step number one is flip patients and in
patients people have this
really messed up view on patients and
inpatients
i think people are often impatient with
the results so
you want the results immediately the
human nature you want it immediately
but you're very patient with yourself if
you look at what you're doing every day
like i'll do that tomorrow you get an
idea
yeah i'll start monday i'll start next
week i'll start and i'll start next year
fresh year start off fresh all that
right no you flip it
you flip it you flip patience and
impatience what i want you to do is have
patience with the results
that the results will come and
impatience with yourself
that today matters today you're watching
this i don't know what time it is during
the day you're watching this
today matters what you create today has
to mean something
because if you approached every day with
massive impatience for yourself and your
effort
and you did that every day you did the
work that you were proud of yourself for
your effort i promise you that the
results are going to come
but it will take some time to get to
your big goals
you have big goals right you want to you
want to do something big you have big
ambitions you don't want just some tiny
little win
awesome that's going to take some time
even if you're hustling and grinding
and being proud of your effort every
single day it's going to take some time
so patience with the results
and massive impatience with yourself
number two is think big and act small
this is where i think a lot of
entrepreneurs get tripped up you need to
think big
and act small so you have a big vision a
big mission something that you want to
go off and change the world
my big thinking is i want to solve the
world's biggest problem
right it's never going to happen in my
lifetime and yet i wake up every day
trying to tackle it
you want to have a big vision the
problem with it though for some people
is that
it means you don't start because to make
that big vision happen you need
money you need investors you need camera
gear you need equipment you need a team
you need all this stuff right just keeps
adding up all the stuff you need and
then you never start
that's the problem the reason why some
dummies are winning off of your idea
instead of you
is because they just started because
they acted small
so you think big and that's the
motivating dream that you're chasing
down every day
and you act small what's the smallest
thing that i can do today
just to start building momentum because
momentum is the thing that is missing in
most businesses
you have great ideas you're genius
you're talented i love what you're
trying to do it's amazing you need
momentum
momentum every single day creating a
little bit more momentum to make that
dream come true
think big act small and number three is
schedule for success
look at your calendar success is your
habits right you want to make sure that
your actions
map to your ambitions the actions that
are in your calendar if you did those
things would help you accomplish your
goals your dreams your ambitions
so if you're talking about building a
youtube career amazing show me in your
calendar where every week you're making
time
to make youtube videos if you want to be
an author awesome i'm pumped
show me in your time show me your
calendar where you've blocked it out
that you're going to spend time writing
on your book
most people don't do it and then you
allow all these little things these
distractions to pull you away from the
thing that you want to be doing
you have to put the big things into your
calendar first and block off the time
and protect that time and look at it
from above and not just
your business your your personal stuff
too what's a good relationship look like
what's a good health situation for
yourself look like right habits
put in your calendar and then step above
it and look at the week that you're
about to go off and do
look at your week ahead if you did those
things consistently would it help you
accomplish your goals
and for too many people it's no you're
living in reaction mode to other
people's emergencies and then you never
get to do the thing that you want to do
you got to defend your time you schedule
for success so whatever your big goals
are whatever you need to concentrate on
you need to make sure you're spending an
appropriate amount of time on it so that
you get good at it so you can start
getting results and making the impact
that you know you can make
schedule for success if you live your
life based off the opinions of other
people you will never
do anything great take a look at who
you're worried about
people who are not happy with their life
people who never went and took their
shot
people who spend their life complaining
instead of trying to change something
is that who you want to be so worried
about what they think about your
decisions
if anything you want to do the exact
opposite of what they're telling you to
do
you don't want their life so stop living
your life by their rules
so i had an amazing one-on-one with an
entrepreneur yesterday at my q a session
here in toronto that i do weekly
and i feel for her she's such a talented
amazing gifted entrepreneur
and we talked about your purpose coming
from your pain and she went through some
massive pain that guided her to the
success right now
and on her path to personal development
but she's afraid to share
what happened and she said maybe in a
year or two like give me a year to work
on and maybe i'll share it
because she's afraid of what people will
think she's afraid that if it doesn't
work out
that she may not be able to get another
job she's afraid of all these things
that people might say about her if they
found her the truth
problem is that's your path i don't care
about what where you're at right now i
need to know
where you've come from i need to know
that you look like me i need to know
that
your story is like mine and so by living
in the shadows and being afraid to tell
the truth
what you're doing is one not letting
people connect you as a real person
right this fake perfect version of you
isn't something that people can connect
to
two you make it so that whatever you
went through you're telling yourself
that it's
it's shameful and you're telling other
people that it's shameful too
but if you come out and talk about what
happened then the people who feel
ashamed about it
they now can come out and say huh i'm
not the only one
this happens to other people too i'm a
little bit more normal
and three if you want to build a
business if you want to create a youtube
channel if you want to have a podcast
you want to be an
author you want to write a book that's
the thing that's going to actually help
take you off
that's the thing there was a great video
that i told her about about a woman who
gained 70 pounds
from having a child so she's pregnant
she gained 70 pounds
and she had a 10 pound baby and now she
had 60 pounds
of extra fat on her right
60 pounds so that's a lot and so she's
trying to lose it and she's working out
and she's eating healthy and she finally
gets down to having
a six-pack abs and looking great and
then somebody noticed that when she bent
over
that that they could see the flaps of
skin
when she stood up it was all six-pack
but when she bent over there was flaps
of skin
and what most people would have done is
deleted that video pretend like it
didn't exist
not talk about that comments right only
show the perfect version look how much
weight i lost
but she did something different and said
she said yeah
that's my body now that's what happens
when you gain 70 pounds in pregnancy
and pump out a 10 pound baby and
that became a rallying cry that one
moment of vulnerability
of saying hey i'm still not perfect like
look look at this saggy skin that i
still have
that's what brought people to her now
she's not just another mom who lost
weight and did this
workout plan and meal plan right that
that connection was real
and now she's built a million dollar
plus business from selling e-courses and
her recipes and everything else that she
goes through
that's the thing this is your
competitive advantage
your purpose your pain your story is
your competitive advantage i do not want
to learn from you until i know that
you've been through what i'm going
through
i can't relate to that story right i
can't tell that story i can't tell
a mom who gained 70 pounds how to lose
weight that's not my story i can't
relate to it
but helping entrepreneurs i can because
i struggled and i suffered and i was
making 300
a month and i was eating the same bean
salad lunch every day
and i celebrated with only mcdonald's
french fries because i couldn't afford
to buy it
all of it i struggle with with fear and
embarrassment
and and shame all of it i know what it's
like i've been through that and
why i do what i do now is because i want
to try to make the path a little bit
easier
for the next generation of entrepreneurs
for you i want you to feel like you're
not alone i want you to feel like
there's a place you can come to
with a beautiful community a believe
nation where we're supporting each other
and there's content every single day
across multiple channels
that you can go and digest and dive into
and hopefully hopefully hopefully make
your path
just a little bit easier because i wish
i had this
when i was getting started when i was a
19 year old entrepreneur
who was insecure and and ashamed and
embarrassed and not willing to talk to
anybody
about the problems i was going through
right that's the thing that will connect
people to you
but if you're so afraid of what people's
judgments are going to be you're never
going to get started
i believe humans are built to serve
you're built to serve you want to help
other people it's hard wired into us
studies show that the impact of serving
other people has the same effect on your
brain
as food and sex it's hard wired into you
you want to help other people
and at the same time you're afraid of
judgment so how do you help other people
if you're also afraid of judgment
it's it's having your foot on the gas
gonna break at the same time you know
you're capable of more but then you're
just
standing on the same spot it's the worst
and so you
have to let go of the opinions of other
people some people may not like what
you're doing
that's okay that can't prevent you from
service that can't prevent you from
fulfilling your mission that can't
prevent you from living the life you
want because you're going to be 95 years
old
looking back on your life and regretting
it knowing you're capable of more
but never taking action as soon as you
get that idea why you're feeling bold
while you're feeling inspired to go off
and take some kind of action i call it
the two percent difference
don't worry about trying to get to 100
don't worry about planning and
strategizing and figuring it out and
thinking that's what most of us do you
get an idea
you think you start thinking right you
plan how do i get to that hundred
percent
no you've lost because you're going to
wake up tomorrow a different person
because you're going to go home today
plan plan plan
and wake up tomorrow a different person
and then not take action because you're
scared
because your brain will start talking
you down from that crazy big idea your
brain will talk you down from going off
and living your truth that's what's
going to happen that's what always
happens and so while you're feeling the
energy and the momentum
you got to take some action instead of
planning how to get to 100 of the way
you take action immediately on getting
two percent of the way
two percent the two percent difference
go from zero to two percent if you can't
take immediate momentum to getting two
percent of the way you will never get
100
you have an idea to make a youtube
channel great go make a video right now
today
asap the two percent difference make
your first video right now with your
cell phone
what most people will do is start
researching right what am i going to
talk about what am i going to wear
what's my hair going to look like how
what camera do i need to get
what what phone do i need to get right
what's my lighting going to be what
microphone think think think
think think think think think and then
never do because you're a perfectionist
you're going to perfect your way of ever
living your truth the beginning is messy
it's supposed to be messy go off and get
your two percent difference
towards finding and living your truth
quick example my story i'm here in
albuquerque new mexico right now
i was walking down a beautiful summer
day last year and i decided that i was
going to take nina to every city in
north america with a million plus people
every city in north america one million
plus people that was my decision
great what's my first step action the
two percent difference
so it's not here's what most people do
it's not go home and research
how many cities there are it's not go
home and make a plan for how we're gonna
do this
there's lots of reasons why it's not
gonna work nina still had a full-time
job i had no idea how many cities there
were
i had no idea what the next step was
gonna be just do something
immediate action and so i thought right
away five seconds later here's my gold
grade five seconds later
this weekend let's hit one city
boston nina never been to boston so i
thought boston was the closest city to
toronto
it wasn't pittsburgh actually was and on
my tour the people in pittsburgh told me
they let me know that pittsburgh is
closer but it doesn't matter
this weekend we're gonna go to boston it
was a wednesday that i decided and on
friday night we were leaving for boston
boom i hit two percent just 50 cities
we're gonna hit one this weekend
we're gonna get two percent of the way
done on the way back from boston we
decided to do this tour
that i'm on right now and now we're
gonna hit 50 of the cities on my list
momentum that's the thing that's missing
momentum because you're trying to be
perfect
you're trying to fully understand your
truth but you can't think your way
through your truth you have to
experience it and feel it
and the starting point is a two percent
difference so take whatever idea that
you have and train yourself i want to
burn this into your nervous system this
is one of the most important things you
can do of all time
as soon as you get an idea action idea
action idea action the more you can
shortcut that
that window instead of taking a week to
take action or a day to take action
immediate five seconds
idea boom some kind of two percent
action and expected not to be perfect
expected not to be the best plan my plan
was wrong right pittsburgh was closer
in my head i thought it was boston we
went down the wrong path
but the momentum is what matters and now
we're 50
of the way and now i'm going to close
that gap and get the rest of it
being an entrepreneur is one of the
hardest things you'll ever do in your
life
whether you go all in financially or not
you're going to go all in emotionally
and a lot of people they can't cut it
they can't get the calluses fast enough
and so they quit that's going to be one
of the biggest tests for you
as you get off and build your business
do you have the mental fortitude to keep
going keep driving keep building your
business
in the face of all obstacles it's the
ultimate endurance
test it's the ultimate test to see what
you're made of when i first started my
company
i knew it was going to be hard but i
didn't think it would be this hard
you never think it's going to be as hard
as it actually is i was making 300
a month i turned down a hundred thousand
dollars a year
six figures working for my dream job
company to make 300
a month and own 30 of a company i eat
beans for lunch every day
the same bean salad for lunch beans
with olive oil and herbs and garlic and
salt
a little pepper because it was cheap and
it would fill me up
and when i wanted to splurge i would go
to the store and get the
the chunky campbell soup clam chowder
it's a little bit more expensive would
also fill me up
when we went to celebrate a win we would
go to mcdonald's and get a mcdonald's
french fries large fries and share
between the three of us
because that's what we could afford
couldn't afford the whole meal
and even to this day the smell of
mcdonald's french fries means victory
for me
it's the most unhealthy thing in the
world but it still means victory
for me i made it even harder on myself
and that i isolated myself and i didn't
tell my friends that i was struggling
i had to pick one thing a month that i
could go to one friendly
you know social pizza and beer kind of
thing per month
because at 20 bucks i didn't have
because i'm only making 300 a month
so i isolated myself i turned inwards
i was too embarrassed and ashamed to
tell my friends who are off making
80 100 000 a year starting salary at
university
and i'm making 300 bucks a month i was
too embarrassed and ashamed
and so i told them i'm hustling
i'm living the entrepreneur life you
know i'm grinding
but really i was struggling i had no
idea what it was doing
this thing was tearing me apart
and it got to the point where i actually
quit on my business partner i told him i
quit
it's easy to quit on something and not
get results when you know that you're
not putting in the effort
but i was putting in the effort every
single day showing up to my business
partner's
dining room table because everything
else is too small in his place to fit us
putting in the effort every single day
trying to build and grow this business
and just it wasn't working i felt
worthless as a human
like why are we not getting results when
will we start to get results
and i was fed up and tired and i told my
quit like i need to find a way to
to to be useful
to feel valuable as a human and so i
told my quit
and then i woke up the next day and said
i can't quit because i haven't given
everything that i've got
and so there's a two-step process that
saved me
that i hope will save you if you're
feeling down and out
and it's tough and you're not getting
results
the first step is use regret to fuel you
i imagine my life at 100 looking back on
this moment
saying would i regret quitting
it's very rarely the things that you do
that you regret it's the things that you
don't do
so would i regret not continuing
would i regret not giving it my all and
i try to adopt the mantra that
i would rather know and fail than not
know i would rather know and fail than
not
know so i had to see this through even
if the answer was total failure
even if it never worked out i had to see
it all the way through just to know
because otherwise that regret would
eat me up and so number one use regret
when you're struggling when it's not
working out when you're not getting
results
imagine yourself being 100 years old
looking back and saying if you quit now
if you stop if you don't keep going
will you regret it number two is model
success
the next thing that saved me was i asked
myself that next morning after i quit
and then decided i need to go back
because i can't live with regret
i asked myself who has done this before
who has built the software company up
i i can't be the only person who's tried
to do this
and i looked at bill gates who started
microsoft and not how he makes an extra
million dollars now but zero to one how
did he do that how did that happen
i studied his success i modeled to
success i applied it to my company
and pretty shortly got my first deal for
13 and a half thousand dollars
that may not seem like a lot of money
but to me back then it was
it was hitting the lottery i'm making
300 bucks a month now i just made a deal
for 13 and a half thousand that was hope
that was real that was putting the money
in my bank account
you know that was being able to have a
full meal at mcdonald's
and more important it gave me a model
that i could do again and again and
again i closed another deal and another
deal and another deal
and our business started to take off and
ever
since that was 20 years ago i use the
same two-step process
you need to do things that make you feel
proud when things get difficult
most people will find really smart ways
to talk themselves down from doing
difficult things and the smarter you are
the better excuse slash reason you have
to not to do the thing
but until you own up and go after and
chase down difficult things you'll never
be proud of yourself
and you'll never accomplish the big
goals you have for yourself so i'm here
on my tour
i committed to doing 90 days 23 cities a
new city basically every four days
and i broke my neck two weeks ago i
broke my neck
in denver and i had to cancel my denver
event because it was in the hospital
but then i got up and i did a short
version of my kansas city event and then
i got up and did a full version of a
minnesota event and then i got up and
did a full version of my
milwaukee event here last night i wanted
to work that makes you feel proud
it's difficult it's hard everybody would
have understood
if i cancelled right if i said guys
sorry i broke my neck broke my back have
a concussion
three staples in my head i can't keep
going everybody would have understood
but i wouldn't have felt proud and that
needs to be your asset test
it's not what other people think about
you it's not when other people let you
off the hook
it's not when other people think that
you're great it's what do you think
about yourself
are you proud of the decisions that you
make in your life
you're constantly searching for more
you're constantly comparing
your version of success your version of
life compared to what you see out there
other people's versions you're looking
at what they're doing on instagram on
youtube
and social media and in the tabloids and
in the you know you're looking at those
people you say that's the life that i
want
because you know confidence in your own
version of your life that's the problem
that's what you need to fix i often get
asked on my tour hey evan what's the
perfect morning routine like what do you
do every morning to get yourself started
what i do almost doesn't matter stop
comparing yourself to me
we have different versions of what
success and balance look like
i look at what the rock does for example
he needs to work out for four hours a
day
he needs to do cardio twice he needs to
do weights twice when he has to be on a
movie set by 9 am he wakes up at four
goes and works out for four hours comes
back showers
and then goes to his set and when he's
shooting a movie he'll sleep five hours
a night
i think that's crazy i don't look like
the rock
there's a reason we have different
priorities different version of balance
but this is the problem because you want
to work out like the rock and you want
to be a good dad like this person and
you want to be a good entrepreneur like
this person a visionary like this person
and you're constantly judging your
version of your life versus somebody
else's
it's unobtainable it's not possible
because there's no self-confidence in
what you already have
it doesn't matter what i do in the
morning it doesn't matter what the rock
does in the morning
what matters is you start your day with
the thing that makes you come alive
if you started your day with the thing
that made you feel bold and
self-confident every single day
your life would look dramatically
different one year from today than where
you are right now
it just would but what that thing is is
different for everybody
we have different goals we have
different things that drive and move us
and so it starts with having the
self-awareness to figure out what it is
that you want
and then the self-confidence to believe
in it enough that when you see something
shiny over here
you're not swayed by and think that you
suck because this person's crushing it
in a different field i think most people
are confused about money most people
don't have a healthy relationship with
money there are the people who think
that money is everything the money is
the only important thing in the world
and you need to chase it down and it's
your duty and responsibility and
obligations like it's number one
the person walking into my house and my
place of business that's my next suit
that's my next payment that's my next
whatever it's only focused on money
and there's other people who think money
is the root of all
evil and that money is a bad thing
money is a tool money helps you get a
lot of things done
money helps you go places money helps
you accomplish your mission
money needs to be in your top five it's
just not number one
money needs to be in your top five if
money does not become important at some
point to you if it's not in your top
five
priorities you'll never make money and
you'll always be by yourself
struggling trying to figure out how to
make something work but it's not number
one either
if you put money above all else you'll
end up doing a lot of work that you hate
and you never get good at it just
because you're chasing opportunities
this is a big reason why so many
entrepreneurs fail
you're just chasing the hottest thing
for this year
that you don't have a passion or
interest in and then you lose because
the people who love that destroy you
when i first started doing this helping
entrepreneurs i never thought i was
going to make money
my first speaking gig my first option to
help people was in canada in my hometown
of toronto
was at a ymca it was a free event they
had an entrepreneurship program they
asked me to come and speak to their
members
it was free i wasn't getting paid to do
it just wanted to help out i just sold
my business i wanted to give back
i was saying yes to everything i
actually didn't even know what i want to
do next
and so i show up and this is big room
full of chairs
and only three people show up to that
first event
only three people and as soon as i
walked in the room and i saw three
people my heart sank
i felt like i'm never gonna be able to
make anything from this if only three
people show up to a free event
how am i ever gonna make money from it i
didn't know
but i gave my best to those three people
i know that i helped those three people
and had an impact on their lives
we then went for coffee afterwards and
continued the conversation i know
that i helped them and it filled my soul
and had to find a way to keep doing it
i knew i had to find a way to keep doing
it even if i never made money
and so i did i kept doing speaking gigs
i did my website
i did my youtube channel and slowly
slowly slowly slowly
it started to come in as i figured out
the second key
important piece which is figuring out
how to bring value to other people
when you find something that you love
doing and you combine it with how it
brings
value to other people that's when you
start making
money if it's something that you just
love doing
but nobody else likes it there's zero
value to anybody else
you have a hobby you have a hobby if
you're only chasing stuff that people
like and need
but you don't like doing it you're never
going to get great at it
you might make a little bit of money but
you're never going to get great at it
you're never going to be
all time you're never going to build a
huge business
and so it's that combination of doing
work that you love doing
and mix it with where does an
opportunity that people need it's a
problem that you are solving mix those
things together
you have a super successful business
everything in your life
changes when you learn to tie your
self-worth
to your effort instead of the results
most people tie their self-worth to the
results
to winning you only feel good about
yourself when you win
if that's how you think then you're
screwed because that person
only takes on projects that you know you
have a pretty high chance of winning at
and therefore you play small for life
the key is to tie your self-worth to the
effort
to try and if you do that well you'll
win beyond your wildest imaginations
so let's use me as an example look at
this video right here this video
two minutes before getting on to making
this video
i'm nervous i'm scared
i don't want to do it i'm trying to find
a reason why i don't have to do this
video
now why i've done 6000 of these videos
do i not love it anymore nope that's not
it
i love doing it so why am i afraid
who cares i've done 6000 the answer is
because i don't want to make it the same
way that i've done the past 6 000
i want to push harder i want to push and
do something new
if i was just doing what i've already
done then it'd be easy
right if you're doing the same thing
over and over and over again it becomes
easy but then
you get bored you start to hit your life
you start realizing that everything is
just a photocopy over and over and over
and over and over again
and so how do i push through i put this
pressure on myself to say this video
right now
has to be the best video that i've ever
made that's my intention going in
to every time i'm filming most days i
don't accomplish it
when you're trying something new and
scary and bigger and bolder
most of the time you won't get it you
fail a lot
but i tie my self-worth my respect to
the effort i'm trying
and every now and then you'll make a bit
of a breakthrough you get a bit of a win
and then those accumulate and then you
get another one and another one and
another one
and so the answer isn't have a big goal
and then find a reason why you can't do
it the answer isn't dream big
and then convince yourself of some
logical excuse
for why you're not going to take action
the answer is to push through
the answer is you're scared and you're
going to do it anyway the answer for me
is i'm going to make
another video i'm going to try and push
myself harder and i think that's what
achievers do
because achievers are failing more than
you because most days i get up and fail
most days i'm just feeling it's another
failure another failure another failure
but the more you fail the more you're
eventually going to win i'm going to get
massive results
because you tie your self-worth to your
abilities to get up and try again
and try again and try again and pat
yourself on the back for the effort
you're putting in
not just when you're winning most people
quit on things because they don't have a
powerful mission or they don't know
where their drive
comes from chasing an opportunity isn't
enough because you're going up against
people
who love that thing who might be willing
to die
for that thing if you want to go to mars
you're competing against elon musk
who would die to go to mars you better
absolutely love it or he's going to
crush you
you need to find the thing that you love
that does not
feel like work otherwise you'll end up
working your
entire life and hating it so every
thursday when i'm in toronto
i do this free event for toronto
entrepreneurs at my daint studio tonight
salsa 5 to 6 p.m
thursdays when i'm in the city i do a
free event q a session for an hour
come out meet me talk let's hang out
however i can help give back to the
community and help local entrepreneurs
my thursdays are bonkers my thursdays
are all day long interviews hangouts
podcasts
skype sessions one-on-ones my assistant
books them in 25-minute chunks
and i have 25 minutes on five-minute
break in between
usually i use that break to get set up
for the next one 25 minutes 5 25
5 25 5 the whole day long and then i end
up going to the studio i record my
podcast with mark drager
i then do two 30-minute one-on-ones that
we film for the youtube channel
and then after all of that i do a
one-hour q a
for the entrepreneur community and then
after that i'm doing more meetings with
my team
it's crazy and somebody asked me last
thursday how do you have the energy
for all of that stuff i love it like
i i love being there with the people
that group session is the best for me i
love it i'm not getting paid
for it it's free it's probably not a
great use of my time if i if i had to
pick
for one hour what's the best use of my
time hang out with startup entrepreneurs
ask me their questions or or do
something like write my book or make my
next course or
something else it probably doesn't make
the most sense but i love it and so
therefore it makes the most sense
right and for other people jumping into
my schedule might be
torture and it should be for me to jump
into your schedule should be torture i
should look at your calendar and say
that's ridiculous how do you have so
much energy for all that stuff
and when you jump in the minute you look
the exact same for me when i gear up for
a thursday as an example when i put my
extrovert hat on
i gain energy as the day goes on i'm not
losing energy
by the time i hit five o'clock and i'm
doing the group session with people
i'm carrying the energy of all the
entrepreneurs that i've met
on my 25 minute one-on-ones throughout
the entire day
i love it i gain more steam but most
things
ask me to do almost anything else for
for eight
10 12 14 hours i would hate my life
asked me to make coffee for
for 10 hours a day i would hate my life
asked me to play piano
asked me to do almost anything for that
amount of time i would hate my life
because it feels like work
and so you have to find the thing that
does not feel like work so then when you
go off and do it
it actually gives you energy so paying
attention to the energy
if at the end of every day like oh oh
this sucks
like that's a good signal that you're
doing the wrong thing because you have
michael jordan level talent at something
you are a genius
you should be crushing it at something
and if the work that you're doing
is draining your energy the people
around you are draining your energy
chances are you're in the wrong spot
you're hanging with the wrong people
you're doing the wrong kind of work
self-esteem comes from doing difficult
things
you set a goal you said you'd start
doing something and maybe even you do
actually start doing that thing but then
you hit a roadblock
then it gets difficult it gets hard and
what you do
in that moment will define the rest of
your life
when it's hard when it's difficult do
you rise to the occasion
or do you let yourself off again finding
some really logical reason why you can't
do that thing
it doesn't count until it's hard you
don't grow
until it's hard you don't build
self-respect self-esteem self-confidence
until it's hard and you follow through
i keep these in my office as a reminder
of who i am
of who i am in my best moments my best
self to push me to do more and to push
harder
what are these if you're new to my
channel welcome i'm evan uh i went on a
tour at the beginning of this year
i did a tour 23 cities 90 days and
two-thirds of the way through with a
month left i broke my neck when i was in
denver
i fainted i fell out of a chair i hit my
head against a wall
crack my the back of my head open i had
three staples
on my head i had a concussion and i
broke my neck in two spots
and after that night i had to wear this
i had to wear this for the next
i just noticed this note here nina
signed it
i love you get well soon nina she signed
it
that's that's sweet huh
gotta go thank her anyway had a little
emotional moment there
i broke my neck and i decided to keep
going on my tour
i had a month left everybody was telling
me to go home my agent told me to go
home my friends my family said come home
get get the health care you need
relax stay in bed rest you need to
recover
and i said being with entrepreneurs is
my recovery
and pushing through and doing this tour
is my healing
one physical healing because just
sitting on the bed all day is not gonna
be for someone like me
uh something that's amazing but two just
just pushing through and knowing that i
can
right it doesn't count until it's hard
it doesn't count until it's difficult
and then you get up and you do it and so
if you've seen any of the videos or
pictures of me
at the events i went from standing up
and moving around and having energy to
then i had to sit at the front of a room
with pillows behind me and an ice pack
on my shoulder blade
for three and a half four hours in
massive pain the whole time
answering questions and doing my
workshop and i was so proud of
myself for doing it that's how i built
my self-esteem
by getting up and doing it by showing up
and it inspired the people who came out
they're saying well
you know i lived 25 minutes away i
didn't know if i wanted to make the
drive
commit to it i was kind of tired and
then i saw you with your broken neck
still showing up so i had to show up too
right but that's not why i did it i did
it for me i did it for myself
i had to wear this all day all night
long
this was my first one and then it
started to break so nina put some duct
tape on it here
and then this this was my second one
that once it started to really wind down
i couldn't wear it anymore
i went for this one and 10 minutes a day
is all i could do to take it off for a
shower
so i had to sleep in this i had to do my
workshop in this
everything 23 hours and 50 minutes a day
except for a 10 minute break in the
shower where i took it off and was
paranoid about moving anything because
my neck was broken i had to keep it
stabilized i wore these
when did you decide that your dreams
shouldn't be big
when did you decide that you shouldn't
tell anyone else about your dreams
until you own your dreams and stop
making yourself feel small
those dreams will never happen never
now this is something everybody
struggles with everybody myself
mel everybody we're worried about
playing a bigger game we're worried
about thinking bigger for ourselves and
we're worried about telling other people
because
what if it doesn't work out what if we
don't make it what's that judgment going
to come
how are they going to think about us and
so i think about my own story what i'm
trying to create
the biggest fight that i used to get
into with my agent steve
was he says evan you need to be a
household name you need to be famous
like steve i don't want to be famous i i
i equated famous to ego
if you're famous and you're this big
egomaniac i didn't i don't want to be an
egomaniac it's not
it's not about me it's about spreading
belief i don't i'm nervous getting in
front of the camera even before filming
this video i'm nervous like i wanted to
want it to do well the lights come on i
don't crave it i don't crave attention
i'm an introvert i like just doing my
thing evan you need to get famous
why steve why do we need to get famous
and for maybe two years we fought over
this
because i kept equating fame with ego
and i looked at the people who were
famous
and like i don't want to be like them
and there's a lot that they did that
that bothered me and i wanted to do it a
different way
and that's the key it's finding the
different way to do it
how does an introvert on a mission
become famous
i don't know we're going to go on this
journey together and hopefully find out
what finally clicked for me was him
saying
when you get famous your mission will
spread
if you start tying actions to mission
that's how you get me to move
for other people it might be hey i'll
give you all this money if you do this
or you'll have
the fame or or credibility or have
statues but i don't need statues built
with me
but as soon as you tie it to mission and
service that gets me going
so he said if you actually want to
fulfill your mission if you say you want
to spread believe
then you need to get famous because the
more people know about you the more
people will hear your message
and it finally it finally stuck like
okay
i got to do it i don't know how to do it
i've never i've never tried to do it
i've
i've always wanted to be behind the
spotlight
and so now now this is part of my
mission i need to become a household
name
and get famous so that more people can
believe in themselves if i actually want
to solve the world's biggest problem
then i need to be out there doing it i
need to believe in myself
more right if i'm trying to spread
belief i need to believe in myself more
too
and so i think that's a human condition
that's part of what we want to do you
want to step outside your comfort zone
you want to serve
humans are built to serve we are we are
built to serve
but service requires helping other
people and because we're afraid of
judgment
you don't want to do it so you've got
your foot in the gas and the break at
the same time you want to help people
but you're worried about their judgment
so you don't do anything you know you're
capable of more
you know you're capable of more but you
don't do it bring yourself to other
people
can be a fantastic thing a fantastic
thing but there's only one way to make
it work you have to kick yourself
forward not down you kick yourself
forward not down most people here's what
they do
most people you see someone who's at
success you see somebody with the
ferrari or the car or
somebody who you're jealous of or you're
insecure about yourself when you're
around them
you see them and you you you think you
suck you look at them and say i suck why
am i not further ahead
why is dan who's not even 40 years old
yet have all of the success and here i
am
and i'm not doing it yet right you kick
yourself down that's how most people
do it and in public you might tell your
friends how that person's a scumbag he's
stole he's ripping people off he's a
jerk but when you go home you just tell
yourself man why am i not further ahead
why am i
why am i here why am i stuck why am i
not getting more momentum
you've been kicked but you've been
kicked down where what you want to do is
kick yourself forward
you want to kick yourself forward if you
see dan driving his ferrari or you see
somebody that you look up to and respect
uses the kick forward to say this is
what's possible
this is what's possible and if he can do
it if she can do it then i can do it too
my hero is young les brown i love him
from a speaker just my favorite speaker
of all time
i look at that and i say i can get
better
not that i suck it's like this is what's
possible i need to get better i need to
improve i need to practice i need to
keep going
because that's what's possible paul
newman the legendary actor had an
amazing quote that i love to repeat
he said i check my pulse and if i can
find it
i know i've got a chance you've got a
very important choice to make
you either make the rest of your life
the best of your life
or you settle for what is and live in
your excuses
so you know why i would give up you know
what i'm deeply afraid of i've got two
i've got a short-term fear and a
long-term fear
my short-term fear is of disappointing
people my biggest short term in the
moment fear is disappointing people
that i would show up to an event and let
people down that i wouldn't give them
value that people would
come and waste their time spend their
money and i didn't give them value
i'm deeply afraid of it and still am
i put pressure on these videos i want
these videos to be great every time i
get in front of this camera
and start making a video i put pressure
on myself that this needs to be the best
video that i've ever done
i want to not disappoint you guys every
single time and this little
pause hesitation before filming
and i'll i'll spend a couple minutes
procrastinating because i'm
i'm afraid i'm afraid of disappointing
you and making a crappy video
i'll procrastinate and then i'll do it
and i'll feel great
doing it but my biggest short-term fear
disappointing people
my biggest long-term fear is of regret
is that i won't live my life is that
i'll look back and say i could have done
more
i i should have pushed harder because
you rarely regret the things that you
did it's the things that you didn't do
the things you were too afraid to do the
actions not taken that's what you
normally regret
and so my biggest short term appearance
is important people maybe it's a
long-term fear is fear of regret
and those things they fight each other
right they fight each other because if
i'm afraid of disappointing somebody i'm
not going to take the action that i
should be taking and then i'm going to
regret it later on
and so i try to use that pure potential
regret
to push me into action to say if i don't
make videos today if i don't do that
speech if i don't get up and make that
presentation
if i don't do the thing that i'm afraid
to do because of disappointing people
potentially then i'll regret it
and i'll put the pressure like this is
the video this video right here this is
the video
that's gonna blow up everything that'll
change the whole game for me
and if i don't record it because i'm
afraid of disappointing somebody
i'm gonna regret that my whole life and
i make it so painful for myself that i
have to act
and that pain pushes me into action and
out of procrastination mode
i'm going to teach you a strategy right
now that will change your life it's
called the two percent difference
the two percent difference is as soon as
you get an idea for something
as soon as you get an idea for a new
thing that you want to try out you go do
it
and it's called the two percent
difference because most people when they
come with an idea what they do is they
think about it they plan they strategize
right you got an idea to go launch
something
great you go home you strategize you you
tinker you plan you think about it
but then you wake up tomorrow a
different person you wake up tomorrow a
different person you were feeling bold
yesterday you came with this great bold
bold vision for yourself amazing you're
feeling on top of the world yesterday
you wake up tomorrow a different person
and then you don't do anything about it
maybe you research a little bit more and
then that idea is dead
i believe that the decisions that you
make when you're feeling bold
unstoppable and confident
are actually the right ones for you and
then your head talks you down from doing
them
we just don't live in the land of bold
and confidence 24 7. we spend one
percent of our life if that
feeling bold and confident and the other
99 feeling
scared and afraid and back down to where
we were before so the decisions you make
when you're feeling bold and confident
are the right ones for you and therefore
the first step you need to take
is not planning it's not strategizing
it's not thinking
it's action the two percent difference
what that means is instead of going home
and strategizing and planning on how to
get to a hundred percent of your goal
build immediate momentum on how to get
to two percent of your goal
focus on taking action to get two
percent of the way close to hitting your
goal
and then that momentum will carry you
forward to helping you get through to
the rest of the hundred
so here's an example i'm filming this
from las vegas i'm on this tour right
now
i promised nina i made a decision i'm
going to take nina to every city in
north america with a million plus people
that was the goal that i had
great most people would go home start
researching
thinking how many cities are there in
north america with a million plus people
how are we gonna do it nina has a
full-time job on and on and on and on
about all the reasons why you're not
gonna be able to do it you start
planning and strategizing great
no that's not the way to do it because
you'd wake up tomorrow different person
and say
i don't know about that goal okay i
can't do that and you start talking
yourself down from it
so while you're feeling the boldness of
it when you're feeling capable
when you actually feel capable of
accomplishing that goal you go off and
you do something
so i said great this weekend i'm going
to go to boston nina had never been to
boston so this weekend we're going to go
to boston and i messaged her to say nina
i've decided i'm going to take you to
every city in north america with a
million plus people on this weekend
we're going to go to boston
turns out there's 50 cities on the list
i don't know how i'm going to get to my
50 cities yet
but i can hit one and that's two percent
if you cannot
get to the first two percent immediately
you will never get to the 50 you'll
never get to the 100.
it's just never gonna happen this is the
problem for most entrepreneurs
you playing too much you strategize too
much you think too much you're too smart
we're smart and so you find really smart
reasons why you can't do something
you're a perfectionist you're worried
about putting something out before it's
ready and then you never release it
the people who i've met on this tour i
feel so bad for them i
it blows my mind of people who've waited
decades plus
to move forward in their idea that idea
that you have that you're sitting on you
need to go do something about it right
now
that's the difference there are dummies
dummies dummies
who are winning in your industry who
don't have as much intellect as you who
don't have as much passion as you
who don't have as much of a of a heart
and a cause of wanting to do something
good to serve
as you do and they're winning and you're
not why because they're actually
off doing the work and you're sitting on
your couch at home strategizing
researching planning thinking about it
and being too afraid to go off and take
action and so the two percent difference
the next time you feel yourself coming
up with an idea and we get ideas all the
time
you get an idea train yourself idea
trust that it comes from somewhere right
that idea comes from somewhere don't
judge it
don't be critical of it it came from
somewhere you have a responsibility to
do something about it
idea to action idea to action train
yourself idea to action you thought of
something today
you thought of something in the shower
great idea do something idea to action
the two percent difference stop planning
your way on how to get to a hundred
percent of your goal
and figure out what can you do right now
today immediately to get two percent of
the way
start applying that principle it will
change your life
i'm gonna give you the most important
strategy that the next time you're
feeling frustrated
you're feeling defeated you're feeling
like giving up will save you and help
you find that inner strength and next
gear
here it is tell yourself it's the best
the next time you're feeling down
frustrated depressed
angry tell yourself it's the best
because now this is your chance to show
yourself
and the world what you're made of the
next time you're stuck at a red light
and you're frustrated complaining
it's the best the next time you're
working out and you feel like you're on
your last set and your
your lungs are on fire and you can't
push again it's the best the next time
you're frustrated in business that
you're not getting the sales you need
and you feel like you're waking up every
day and there's no momentum
it's the best it's the best this is your
chance
this is your chance you can complain for
seven and a half seconds
and get frustrated and then tweak it
inside your brain to say
this is the best why what does it do
first it switches your mindset to one of
hopelessness
to one as resourcefulness it switches
your mindset
from one of hopelessness that this sucks
that i'm giving up i'm defeated it's
over
why this is happening to me why does
this suck to one of resourcefulness that
this
is the best this is my chance because
you grow
through challenges and this is the next
challenge in front of me that i am going
to grow through
so listen everybody's going to have an
opinion on what you should do with your
life everybody your
your friends your family your culture
your society your community
your customers online haters everybody's
got an opinion on what you should do
with your life and it's tempting to want
to take the advice
one because it gives us advice but two
it's also somebody to blame right like
if it doesn't work out it's not my fault
it's that person's fault they said i
should do it
at some point though you have to decide
that you are going to be an adult
that you are in control that you want to
go off and build your own life and you
only you know what that looks like and
you have to have the courage and the
confidence to step up and say
i'm in charge this is my life now i get
to decide what i want to do
and some opinions will matter and some
opinions will make a difference and
others you have to let bounce off you
you're not going to be able to please
everybody everybody has an opinion on
what you should do with your life
and the only one that really matters
truly is this one right here
so how do you decide how do you know
what the difference is how do you know
which opinions you should take which
you should listen to because on the one
hand it's you want to take
advice you want to take counsel you
don't know everything and on the other
hand
it's it's your life you got to decide
how do you make those two things work
together number one
is understand what your one word is your
one word is your most important core
value mine is believe
yours is whatever it is it's worth going
through the exercise i think it's one of
the most important exercises you can
ever do in your life
it becomes a filter through which you
see the world and so for me it's belief
and belief is around believing in
yourself having self-confidence
believing in the work that you're doing
having passion for it and believing that
it's going to work out believing in the
impact believing that there is light at
the end of the tunnel
even if you only see darkness around you
right now that's believe and so
all of the decisions that i make are
through the lens
of believe every new piece of content
that i put on my channel
is through the lens of believe and so if
you give me advice
that has nothing to do with believe it
may be great potential advice but it's
not for me
how do i know what's for me because i'm
sitting on my rock of believe and if you
don't know what value you stand on
it's easy to get pulled in a lot of
different directions most entrepreneurs
don't win because they're not consistent
enough
it's not because you don't have talent
or skills or energy you're just not
consistent enough
you're not consistent enough too many
entrepreneurs get all pumped up and
motivated and you're working like crazy
and you have an amazing day
and then the next day you wake up and
you're back to normal life and you're
not consistently putting in the effort
the reason why my youtube channel has
won
is because i made videos every single
day for for five years
five years ago plus i had 7 000
subscribers on my youtube channel
now we're over 1.8 million not because
i'm super talented i'm not
go back and watch my videos you'll see
how i sucked at the beginning
super nervous awkward in a suit sitting
down just
terrible but by making videos every
single day
i got better and i was able to conquer
what i didn't have any natural talent in
because i learned to develop the skill
by beating on my craft every single day
and so this is
one of the major problems for
entrepreneurs i think
a lot of people could have done what
i've done i think a lot of you watching
you could have done what i've done you
have more natural town than i do the
difference is i got up every day for
five years and did it and so i don't
think it's that special
i think it's just putting in the effort
and the hustle every single day
and that's a big reason why so many
entrepreneurs don't win you are just not
consistent enough in your effort
i like to say that everybody has michael
jordan level talent is something
i believe it i think i think you have
michael jordan level talent at something
i think you're a genius
a legit bonafide genius you should be
out there changing the world i believe
it
i think you have that talent i think you
have that capabilities
most people don't most people one they
don't believe in themselves enough to
actually go off and chase it
and most people too don't go off and
explore to find the thing that they have
genius at
that they could be michael jordan at
warren buffett and instead you try to
photocopy somebody else's life you try
to be the next somebody no
you're a genius let's go let's chase it
down
that's why i'm on my mission i want to
solve the world's biggest problem
untapped human potential i think
everybody is that genius
and they either don't know what the
thing is that they should be doing or
they don't believe in themselves
hard enough to go and chase it down so
let's work through those two things
whatever camp you fall into there's
going to be advice that will help you
one you don't know what your genius at
amazing what's the path
you explore you test you try people
settle way too early in life you settle
you settle
how do you know if you like sushi not
until you taste it you don't you should
be trying everything i think everybody
should try to be an entrepreneur
everybody should try to have a youtube
channel everybody should try to have a
podcast everybody should try to be an
accountant like
you should try should pick up everything
just to get a sense say yes to
everything once adopt that mindset
mentality
we get locked in to career paths way too
soon
why because that's what our parents did
because that's what we went to school
for why you're gonna now
live the rest of your life doing
something because you've only tried five
different things and now you're gonna
pick
like that's the recipe for disaster
that's why 95 of america wakes up and
drives to the job that they hate you
have to try
you have to say yes and don't tie
yourself forth to the results
you will suck at the beginning whatever
you first start doing you will suck it
will not work out my first youtube
videos
sucked sucked go back watch it so you
can see
how bad i was when i first started my
videos i sucked i was awkward i was
nervous i was introverted
it took me 350 videos until i wasn't
completely embarrassed by myself
350 videos and so the acid test needs to
be
do you like the process do you want to
go back and do it again you may not have
been good at it but you
do you want to go off and do it again a
whole bunch of things when you don't
know what you want to do in life you
need to say yes to almost everything
as long as it falls within your personal
you know values ethics you're not
harming yourself
you know most things you should go off
and try i think you should try i don't
think you've tried enough if you don't
know what you want to do in life you
have not tried enough
stop trying to be perfect one of the
biggest things that holds entrepreneurs
back
is you have an idea in your head and you
want to launch it but you're afraid to
launch anything until it's perfect
you're afraid to put anything out into
the world
until you have the perfect plan the
perfect product the perfect competitive
advantage and that does not exist
and the biggest danger of all is that
just stays an idea for you
for the rest of your life that it never
actually gets created
because you can never reach perfection
because you're afraid of releasing the
thing
out into the world and so you never will
where everybody who you look up to the
people who've had massive success any
entrepreneur
they released something before it was
perfect
they got feedback they adjusted they
listened to it
and that became the thing that propelled
them to massive success
and so you need to move from that place
of trying to have everything be 100
perfect before you launch
and just get used to actually creating
actually doing actually putting stuff
out there into the market
instead of sitting on your couch hoping
wishing dreaming
planning strategizing but never actually
doing
whether you believe you can and you
can't you're right right
whether you believe you can or you can't
you're right
one of the biggest reasons why
entrepreneurs don't win because you
don't believe in yourself enough it's
why
why do i have this channel why is my one
word believe look look at the back of
nina's sweater
there it is right believe believe that's
it
it's so important there's so many you
guys are geniuses there's so many
geniuses massively talented people out
there with amazing ideas that can change
the world
but you don't go off in question because
you don't believe in yourself enough i
think the two biggest problems in the
world are
one recognizing that you have michael
jordan level talent at something
believing that you have something in you
that you're not meant to just wake up
and photocopy your life every day
working for somebody else
just believing that and two then
believing in that ability
believing that you have michael jordan
level talent as something and then when
you found it
believing in it enough to chase it down
every day to get better because you need
to beat on your craft
because it may be something that's
totally outside what is normal in your
family
because it may be something way outside
what is normal for your culture
or your society or your community but
you have to go off and do that crazy
thing and it's really hard to believe in
yourself enough to chase it down
especially when it's against what
everybody around you is saying
and what they believe and so great yes i
need to believe in myself amazing how do
you do it
what's the process how do you gain
self-belief you need to eliminate
the negativity in your life and replace
it with belief
so think about what are the thoughts who
are the people what are the things
around you that keep you where you are
to keep these negative patterns in your
head
is it your parents is it your friends is
it the tv shows you're watching
the media you're consuming like what is
it that is toxic
that makes you feel small and as much as
possible you either cut it out of your
life
or reduce the exposure if it's your mom
who's always on you and says you can't
go be an entrepreneur
maybe you just don't talk about your
career with your mom you put boundaries
up
i don't want to talk about this there's
other things that we have in common you
focus on that stuff
you lay out the ground rules you make
them respect you
and you don't talk about the things that
you know is going to lead to conflict
and for other people you may need to
just
completely cut them out of your life if
it's your best friend from growing up
just because you were friends in grade
four doesn't mean you should still be
friends of adults
a lot of our friendships are out of
convenience you're with people just
because it's convenient to be with
people but you've grown apart
and you have to recognize that if
somebody is toxic around you
you shouldn't be with them and if you
are it's micro doses
and so you need to cut out a lot of the
crap in your life
anything that's causing negativity or
self-doubt needs to be eliminated from
your life as much as possible
great now you have a vacuum now you've
got this hole not as that is this void
inside you great what do you do
you fill it up with positivity you fill
it up with belief
my channel is a pretty good resource i
got this channel i got the other
channels we got three videos plus a day
coming out across my channels
that if you want more belief in your
life here's a great resource for you
but forget about me it's not about me
it's about you what makes you feel
belief if it's watching videos great if
it's listening to a podcast reading a
book
doing an act of service meditating
prayer whatever the thing is that helps
you feel belief
do that every single day fill yourself
up with it i inject myself
with so much vitamin c belief i see
belief as this
injection that i put into myself every
day i have so much of it in me
that if somebody sneezes their toxicity
on me
i'm not gonna get sick because i've done
the work because i'm surrounded with so
much belief
that's what you need for your life as
well step number two is your why
why do you do what you do your purpose
comes from your pain your purpose
comes from your pain the thing that you
will enjoy
the most in life is helping people who
currently are going through whatever you
massively struggled with
think about the biggest pain in your
life whatever that was growing up
the biggest pain the thing you'd never
want to have to repeat or go through
again
that pain that pain that deep dark pain
you wouldn't wish upon your enemies that
pain the worst day of your life that
pain
your greatest joy in life will be
helping people
who are currently going through that
pain and getting them through it that's
it that's your purpose for life that
will never get old that will be with you
for life
and so for me starting up as an
entrepreneur was my biggest pain
i felt worthless i was making 300 a
month i was suffering and struggling and
just felt defeated as a human being
that's why i love helping out other
entrepreneurs and that's going to be it
for life that'll be
my purpose for life you need to do
things that make you proud of yourself
you need to do the difficult things when
it's hard and you do it
and you try and you keep going that's
when you feel proud about yourself
when you quit early even if everybody
gives you
a logical reason for doing it say hey
it's okay don't worry about it
quit you should quit take it easy
but you know deep down inside yourself
you can't quit you have to do the work
that makes you feel proud because
if you face difficulties and then quit
that's what you're teaching yourself
that's the story inside your head
and there's no way you're going to go
off and accomplish those big bad and
possible
dream goals of yours if you quit every
time it gets hard
i had a guy come to my columbus workshop
and he had a goal
to do six days a week cold showers
it was friday night saturday night was
his day off from cold showers it was
friday night across my workshop and says
it's been winter here in columbus i'm at
my girlfriend's house all day today
it's been freezing i've been inside the
house it's been freezing all day
i didn't do my cold shower today evan
what should i do should i take my cold
shower
i said well are you proud of the reason
why not
are you proud of the reason that you're
in a cold house all day and so that's
that's good justification for you said
no i'm not proud of the reason great
then you have to do it
you have to go take your cold shower and
after the workshop he got home at 11 30
at night and
he took an instagram video from from the
waist up getting into the cold shower
and freezing his face off
and then i said you have to go off and
do it again tomorrow too even though
saturday's your day off you have to get
up and do it again tomorrow
just to show yourself just to prove to
yourself what you're made of
when it's difficult and you try that's
when you win
that's when you actually feel good about
yourself when it's difficult and you
keep going
even if the results suck even if past
the 40
your results are starting to decline you
feel great about yourself because you
kept going
but if you quit as soon as it gets hard
that's what you're teaching yourself to
do
and so i see entrepreneurs and leaders
as trees you're a tree
your responsibility as a tree is to eat
poison carbon dioxide
right you eat poison you eat it
you grow from it and then you spit out
positivity and oxygen for the people
around you
right for yourself and the people around
you you grow from it your job is to eat
adversity
your job is to eat judgment your job is
to eat difficulties
and you grow from it and then you create
opportunities and possibilities for
yourself
and the people around you that's your
job
and so the next time that you find
yourself in a difficult situation you
want to quit you want to give up
you're at that mark your brain wants to
quit on you remind yourself
i'm a tree i'm a tree
i'm going to grow from this this is my
chance to get better
this is my chance to eat it to grow from
it and then create
possibilities for other people that's
your job
if you want to be an amazing leader and
an amazing entrepreneur
and i'm cheering for you lack of
consistency is one of the biggest
reasons why entrepreneurs fail
one of the biggest reasons you're a
genius you have great ideas
you want to serve you know you're
capable of more and you have these
moments of inspiration and moments of
boldness and moments of massive
productivity and focus and clarity but
it's not consistent
and that's why most entrepreneurs will
lose
because you might crush it on a saturday
or sunday or
monday but then tuesday wednesday
thursday friday
you fall back down until the next
saturday when you're up and flying again
it's not enough it's much more about
what you do every day
you are what you consistently do it's a
huge problem for entrepreneurs so let's
fix them
number one if you are a part-time
entrepreneur if you work for someone
else
you're part-time entrepreneur you need
to make sure that every single day
you're working on your business
every single day you have to work on
your business no matter what universe
for 15 minutes at night
every single day you cannot let momentum
die
even just to show yourself that you
can't even if it's a crazy long day
and your boss is yelling at you and you
come home and your spouse is
angry and your kids are even then you
have to spend 15 minutes on your
business half an hour in your business
every single day you cannot let the
momentum die don't disappoint yourself
number two if you're already full time
in your business great you need to have
ceo
time every day in your business ceo time
time where you spend being the ceo what
does that mean
it's different for different
entrepreneurs but when you're working on
the business instead of in it if you
spend all time
just working in the business just
putting up fires and never growing
guess what you're never gonna grow if
you never have ceo time built into your
business you will never be a ceo
and so you need to make sure that every
day you have ceo time built into your
business again maybe it's only half an
hour
but in that half an hour you're spending
time growing your company you're gonna
start seeing results
and my last tip is i want you to start
your morning off powerfully i want you
to chart your start i want you to have a
morning routine
that inspires you that makes you feel
bold most people what do they do when
they wake up
first thing they do is they hit the
snooze button what does that mean it
means last night you set a goal
i'm going to wake up at a certain time
right i'm going to wake up at 6 00 a.m 5
a.m 7 00 am 12 00
noon i don't care what time you have to
wake up you set a goal you're gonna wake
up
and then the very first thing that you
do how you start your day every day just
say i am not going to hit my goal today
that's how you start your day that's how
most of america starts your day they say
i'm not going to hit my goal today
how do you think you're going to go off
and have an amazing day and crush it and
go
hit your crazy big goals and ambitions
that you have as an entrepreneur
when you tell yourself and you reinforce
it every morning that you are the kind
of person who doesn't hit their goals
you got to change that you got to wake
up wake up when you say you're going to
wake up
get out of bed when you say you're going
to get out of bed that's step one
then step two is what is a morning
routine that sets you up for success
most people wake up like it's an
accident they wake up you check your
phone
you're responding to other people's
emergencies and their agenda for your
time
that's not how you need to start your
day successful people they own their
morning
what does your morning look like and
we've all felt inspired and bold at some
point
you felt it you've been bold you've been
inspired at some point in your life
great whatever that thing was it made
you feel bold unstoppable inspired
put that into your morning routine maybe
just watching the video maybe it's
reading the book maybe it's doing an act
of kindness
maybe it's meditating maybe it's prayer
whatever it is
with intention because some of you have
a morning routine already i'm talking to
you
you have a morning routine already but
you're not crushing it every day you're
not coming out of that morning routine
feeling bold inspired consistently
that's what we're talking about
consistency here sometimes you just go
through the motions of your morning
routine
sometimes you just pray but you're not
really connecting sometimes you just
watch a video but you're making your
breakfast you're brushing your teeth and
you're not paying attention
with intention to your morning routine
you must come out of your morning
routine
every single day feeling bold
unstoppable and confident if you did
that
if you woke up every day on time like
you say you're going to you're not
getting the snooze button you get out of
bed
and then you did the thing that made you
feel bold powerful and unstoppable every
single day
holy cow i guarantee you your life one
year from today will look dramatically
different
than where you are right now consistency
is the game
you are what you consistently do and i
want to see you win
the more you live your life based on
what other people think of it you're
going to lose
you're going to lose listen you're an
entrepreneur you want to do crazy things
you you have a
bold ambitious vision for what you want
to accomplish in your life
you want to change the way something's
done in the industry right that's what
we want to do we want to change the
world
you know what there's a lot of people
who want to protect the world the status
quo they want to protect the way things
are done you want to come in and shake
up an industry
there's a lot of people who want to
protect that industry there's a lot of
people who don't like change there's a
lot of people who are so afraid of
seeing you be successful because it
means that they suck
right there's a lot of people who who
are in your environment in your family
in your home your friends people who
they don't want to see you win
because it means they suck because
you've left them because it means that
they're not good anymore because they
judge themselves based off of what
everybody else is doing
and a lot of people have someone in
their family who went off and crushed it
and they tried it and then they failed
right they tried it
they may have had some success and then
they failed and now nobody else around
them is allowed to be successful
all they want to do is pull everybody
else down they took their shot
ultimately didn't work
you know they pull everybody else around
them you can't let that be you the more
you want to go off and have a bold
ambitious life for yourself
the more you're going to have to learn
to what i call inoculate yourself
against judgment
you need to inoculate yourself against
judgment the judgment of your friends
your parents the people around you the
general public social media
inoculate yourself against judgment as
long as you care
what other people think of you you will
lose you will play small
forever you will not be living your
version of your life and so how do you
do it how do you inoculate yourself
against judgment
here's how it goes anytime you feel your
heart beating boom boom boom boom boom
boom
boom your heart's beating you're nervous
you're scared you're worried about what
someone's gonna think of you
you have to do the thing you train
yourself even if it's not an expression
of you even if you don't really care
about doing that thing or not
you have to do it just to train yourself
something like this
would have been really difficult for me
10 years ago filming on the street
was really hard i'd be worried about
what people think of me should be
worried about
me standing here san francisco people
walking by
what they think of me yelling into my
phone yelling into
this microphone here talking to you guys
right here it's scary
and so because this potential judgment
you get scared and then you don't do the
thing teach yourself to do the thing if
filming in public sounds like a scary
thing to you like oh i couldn't do that
go do it go find the busiest street that
you can find
and then go make a video and here's the
thing expect it to suck
you're not going to be great the first
time you do something that's okay expect
to suck expect it to be the worst video
you've ever
made and then pat yourself on the back
and say i did it the first thing most
people do after they make a decision
is they plan they strategize they tinker
they think and it's the worst thing you
can do here's why you make a bold
decision you say i'm gonna change my
life i'm going to go off and do this
crazy amazing thing and then you go home
and you think of all the ways that you
can happen and you start planning and
strategizing is amazing you feel great
and then you wake up tomorrow and you're
a different person
you wake up tomorrow a different person
and that person said you can't do that
you can't follow through on that who are
you to take on that big idea and then
nothing happens nothing happens
and so the solution after you get
immediate idea is actually
don't worry about planning even
imperfect action just
action because you need to build it into
your nervous system that you're the kind
of person who follows through
because you need to make some commitment
so that by the time you wake up tomorrow
you've committed to following through
that's the biggest problem i call the
two percent difference
so what most people will do is they'll
plan to 100 you get an idea you got a
plan you got to go home you got to plan
plan plan plan you got to plan all the
way to the end
and it's amazing and you think about it
it's such a great place to live in
as entrepreneurs as perfectionists as
over planners we love living in that
world
don't worry about planning to 100
percent instead find the two percent
difference
what can you do right now to get two
percent of the way
if you don't get two percent of the way
immediately through action you will
never get to 100 of the way
most entrepreneurs can't handle a major
setback you can't
you can handle a whole bunch of little
setbacks a little bit of punch to the
face but
you can't handle a major setback when
there's a major meltdown what do you do
do you get back up do you find another
way or do you quit and most
entrepreneurs most businesses will quit
look at how many companies are still
around
look at the biggest companies in the
world how many of them were around 100
years ago
not very many most companies go out of
business because they can't adjust they
can't evolve
they don't love the dark clouds enough
let's look at youtube as an example
whenever there's a major algorithm
change everybody's upset everybody's
complaining everybody is freaking out
like oh
i don't like it i don't like it right
they complain i get pumped
i get pumped because it's my chance to
win now
it sucks because it's a lot of work
because you got to figure out a new path
but everybody who's ahead of you who's
complaining
that's your chance to win and so i'm
going through it right now i look at my
channel
and making three videos a day might be
a setback for my channel even this video
i don't know where it's going to be it
might be on my main channel might be on
a sub channel that i'm making it's a big
potential strategic shift for me
to say going from one channel to three
or eight
i haven't fully figured it out yet but
i'm pumped i'm pumped while other people
are suffering and struggling and
complaining that this is the new youtube
i'm gonna test it out immediate action
let's go
it's not that loving the dark clouds at
least for me it's not that love in the
dark clouds you want negativity to
happen you
want there to be controversy you want
chaos to happen you want your
competitors go out of business you want
it to be difficult it's not that it's
that
that's your chance to win and so the
best thing i recommend is
flip it in your head learn to tell
yourself that this is the best
when everybody else is complaining when
everybody else is struggling even when
you when you
put all this work into doing something
and now it's collapsing on you
it's really hard to say positive tell
yourself this is the best
this is my opportunity to prove to
myself and the world
what i'm made of and that if you can
move from a place of resourcelessness to
resourcefulness
and find a path while everybody else is
ahead of you and complaining
that's your chance to win entrepreneurs
generally don't have a lot of patience
and
that's actually a good thing we want
things now we want to hustle hard we
want to see
the results of our labor paying off we
want to see you know change happening we
have
a big vision we know what can work and
we want it to happen right now and
that's that's
that's amazing i want you to hold on to
it and
at the same time i want you to have
incredible patience
because what ends up happening is
entrepreneurs often quit too
soon you had the right idea you had the
right vision you even had the right
execution and starting it up
but you just quit you thought it was
going to happen in three months where
it's actually going to happen in three
years
for what you're doing every single day
you need to be applying yourself
and close off every other opportunity
for four years
and then you'll be successful four years
ago
on my youtube channel i had seven
thousand ish
subscribers four years ago how did i get
here
with 1.2 million by making videos every
single day
every single day we haven't missed a day
in four years
and in the past two or three years has
been three times a day
or at least two times a day just
grinding it out and
in those little micro moments in those
micro videos
it's super impatience right it's like
this video has to deliver
this video and i have to deliver this
next one this one right here
has to deliver there's a lot of
impatience to make things happen
and it's knowing that this is going to
take me years to get to where i want to
go
most people aren't happy in life because
they're living somebody else's truth
you're not living your truth you're
living somebody else's version of it
your parents your family your culture
your society
you're living somebody else's version of
it and so you're never happy because you
never explored it
you never picked at it you never found
out what you could be and you settled
for something less than what you're
capable of you know you're capable of
more you may not know what the thing is
that you should be doing but you know
it's not this thing right in front of
you
i can't tell you how many people i've
met on this tour who have that story to
share i had a woman whose father told
her that
women should not be doing any kind of
entrepreneurial ventures
that women are meant to be teachers and
so she spent 15 years being a teacher
before having the courage to jump off
and start her own business
and now she has a multi-million dollar
construction business
i had a girl come up in albuquerque
where i am right now who studied
for years to be an accountant why
because her mom was an accountant
so her mom made her go study to become
an accountant and she didn't know what
she wanted to do so she said okay great
yeah i'll be an accountant
she just graduated and realized i don't
want to be an accountant this isn't for
me
it's easy it's the path that my parents
took like it's great for me to get into
it i can get
easy money you know my mom said i'll
like it when the money starts coming in
but money's coming in and i don't like
it
i want to do something else i know i
meant for something greater and so she
told her mom
i don't want to do this i want to learn
how to be a manager and consultant and
i'm going to go back to school
that takes a lot of guts that takes a
lot of courage
most people do not have that courage
most people do not have the courage to
stand up to their parents
and say i don't want this life it
doesn't mean you have to hate them
you have to attack them you have to tell
them they're wrong this is for you
you don't want that life most people
never had that courage
and the story that comes to mind for me
is accio marita and use this as
motivation as wisdom if you are trying
to
battle your parents or your culture your
friends or your society remember akio
morita
he started sony now he came from 11 or
12 generations of sake brewers
japanese background the japanese culture
is super
family oriented and the oldest always
takes over the family business the
oldest has to follow in line with what
the family was doing
and so he was expected to take over the
sake business and it's not just one
generation you're talking 11 to 12
generations
in a japanese society and he said i
don't want to do this
i want to start my own business a
technology company
at a time when japan was known for super
low quality products
this is the man who put japan on the map
for high quality products that products
coming out of japan meant something
was a stamp of quality because of akio
marita
and he went on to build one of the most
successful brands in the world sony
but it starts with having the courage
having the courage to say
that's not my life this is why i keep
going with my youtube channel
this is the reason why i keep going with
my youtube channel because
yes your spouse is important and yes
your friend's important and the people
that you hang out with
are super super super important and
all the other people that you hang out
with by reading books and consuming
content watching videos
all of that makes an impact too the more
that you spend
hanging around people and ideas and
wisdom that bring you up
the more you're going to rise up and the
more you're around people who are
complaining and negative and pulling you
down
guess what happens the more you're gonna
be pulled down
and one of the big reasons for me in
creating this channel was
i wanted to be around successful
entrepreneurs i wanted to be around
people who would push me to go off and
do more
because in my life i'm super fortunate
to have a very understanding wife
a very supportive family friends who
encourage me and you know always support
the things that i'm doing
but i don't have people who are pushing
me to do better you know i don't have
people who say you know what
what you're doing is great but you
should be out here like
you could be making these adjustments
and playing a bigger game you can have a
bigger impact
and so i needed more of that in my life
and so my solution to finding it was
was the videos was i want to hang around
elon musk and i want to hang around
steve jobs i want to hang around
warren buffet i want to hang around
these people who are thinking on a
bigger scale because the more you do
that
the more you ingest this content the
more you're going to think like them
the more you're going to act like them
the more you're gonna pick these pieces
to not only just be like them
but to be the best version of you i
think people struggle with goals because
they struggle with self-awareness
because they don't know who they are
and so they're constantly adjusting the
goals that they have themselves based
off what other people
think of them and based off what they
see out in the media or on instagram or
on youtube
they don't have self-awareness you got
to figure out what your one word is what
your most important core value is
who are you as a human being i wrote a
whole book on this but just as a quick
brainstorm opportunity
for you right now think about what is
your single most important core value
what is it if you pick one core value as
a human being what is it for me it's
belief
i like believing in people i need to
believe in people i i
hate negativity i hate toxic people i
hate the haters
right i don't want to be around people
saying that you can't do this
i am the opposite i need to believe and
so already right there
already having that awareness of what
your one word is what your who is
when you figure that out it allows you
to make better decisions it means that
if you're in a work environment if i was
in a work environment
where people didn't believe in each
other i wouldn't i wouldn't be able to
handle it
i would be frustrated be upset and be
angry and now i know why because my one
word is belief
and so what is your single most
important core value figure that out
it's one of the most important exercises
you can ever do in your life
it's super helpful it's valuable it's
important you need to do it
self love comes from doing difficult
things self love comes from
doing things that you think are beyond
your comfort zone that you're not
capable of doing
and just getting up and trying to do it
that's when you love yourself
when something is easy and you win you
actually don't feel that great about
yourself if you were to go and
run a race against three-year-olds and
you won great yeah you won
you might even post about it on
instagram but you don't love yourself
you don't feel good about yourself
because you played small because it was
easy because you were expected to win
because it's inside your comfort zone
when you play inside your comfort zone
always you don't love yourself it comes
from doing difficult things
that's how you build respect that's how
you build credibility it's how you build
self-love for you forget about
how other people respect or look at you
it's how you feel about yourself that's
the game
and that comes from doing difficult
things so if you ran a race against
three-year-olds and you won great
who cares you don't feel great about
yourself because you were expected to
win
but if you ran a race against usain bolt
and he ran backwards on one leg he would
still probably destroy you
but you should feel great about yourself
because you did the thing
when it was hard to do the thing you
might have lost to the same boat but you
got in the race against him
that's how you build self-love when you
tie your self-respect when you tie your
self-worth
when you tie yourself love to the effort
that you put in on a daily basis
that's when you start to win when you
tie yourself love to winning
to getting results you lose when you tie
your self love to how many likes you
have on instagram reviews or subscribers
on youtube
you lose it's about the effort are you
putting in the effort every day
because if you are proud of your effort
on a daily basis
i promise you you are going to crush it
but if you are only proud of yourself
when you win
here's what's going to happen you're
only going to take on small things
you're going to play small your entire
life because you're only going to take
on projects that you have a pretty high
chance of winning at
because that's how you have love for
yourself and that's a losing game
because you're capable of more you're
capable of doing a lot more stuff
you keep a little playing a bigger game
you're capable of having a bigger impact
you have to it's your duty it's your
duty to love yourself
when you love yourself you'll be able to
spread that more and help other people
and so how do you love yourself it comes
from doing difficult things
it comes from when your heart's beating
like crazy and you're scared
and it's a big project and you say i'm
gonna try
i'm gonna try to do that scary thing i'm
gonna try to record a video in public
where people may be watching you doesn't
mean your video has to be great chances
are it's gonna suck
but you tried and you should feel great
about yourself
people aren't lazy they just don't have
dreams that inspire them they
default to thinking i'm a lazy person i
don't have ambitions i don't know what i
want to do in life i'm just
i'm just a loser no you don't have a
dream
that makes you want to go off and do
something and until you figure that out
you're going to be in this constant
cycle of feeling like a loser
it's one of the most common questions
that i get asked on my ig streams i go
live every single day on instagram
at least right now while i'm on my tour
and every single day i get asked some
variation of
evan i'm lazy how do i get out of it
evan i'm procrastinating
how do i get out of it one you don't
call yourself a lazy person
there's no such thing as a lazy person
if you are procrastinating or you're
being
lazy but you are being lazy doesn't mean
that you are a lazy person
there's two reasons why you're doing it
there's two reasons why you are being
lazy
one you don't have a dream that's big
enough you don't have something that
inspires you you don't want to get out
of bed in the morning if i was an
accountant i would be a really lazy
accountant i would hate my life
not to knock accountants it's just not
for me if i was a video editor
i would be i would be lazy i would hate
my life i don't want to be a video
editor i don't want to be an accountant
actually there's most things in the
world that i don't want to be
and if you forced me to do that i would
be lazy that's 95
of america i think 95 of america wakes
up and drives to the job that they hate
and then they're lazy there but they
have dreams
they have ambitions you have michael
jordan level talent at something
you just have to find it and so if you
don't know what that thing is then it's
your duty to go off and explore
you test you try you see you say yes to
a lot of stuff like this is the most
important thing that you need to figure
out in your life if you don't know what
your dream is
you have to go off and try things just
like you won't get married until you go
on dates
you won't get married to an idea until
you go on dates until you try until you
say yes
and the acid test is did i like it do i
want to go back does this fill me up did
i enjoy the process of it can i see
myself doing this and having fun because
when you're having fun
doing the work that's when it will fill
you up
that's when you won't be lazy and there
has been times in all your lives where
you felt that
where you felt the joy the energy the
ambition the drive and so you need to
capture that and say yes
and find what it is that your big dream
is you're trying to change yourself to
fit into a social circle because you
feel you're not good enough
you feel you're not good enough you feel
you won't be accepted otherwise you feel
you have no friends
the reality is you're different you're
weird that's amazing
that's great and it's never been easier
to find your tribe it's never been
easier to find people
who build you up who support you who
cheer you on who want similar things to
you
and until you find that group you're
always going to feel like an outcast
you're always going to feel like a fake
you're always going to feel like you're
trying to impress people who you don't
like but what's your alternative because
you have no friends otherwise
and so here's a process you can use to
follow to help you be around the right
people
and start building the life you want
step one eliminate
negativity think about the people in
your life right now who just make you
feel low
who suck your energy who you don't feel
good about yourself when you're around
who just make you feel oh you don't want
to be around them anymore
maybe those are some friends that you
grew up with and that they're not your
friends anymore
and that's okay i think a lot of us stay
in relationships based out of
convenience just because you went
to elementary school with somebody
doesn't mean that you should still be
their friend now
you're just in that relationship out of
convenience you guys have grown apart
and you need to accept it if you're
around negative people like that or
maybe it's your parents
then either limit your exposure to them
or cut off access completely
you know if it's a friend who's toxic
don't be around that person anymore if
it's people who make you feel less sin
don't be around those people anymore
if it's your parents or it's a close
friend that you still have some
connection to but there's just one thing
that when you talk about
makes you feel bad don't talk about
those things anymore
if you're talking to your parents and
and they don't like your entrepreneurial
aspirations
don't talk about that stuff anymore put
boundaries up because there's still
enough
of a connection around other things
hopefully if not maybe you don't want to
be talking to those people
but if there's enough of a connection
still with your mom with your dad
talk about that stuff and put boundaries
around talking about your career because
you know what's gonna cause
controversy people to get upset and
negativity so step one is
you need to eliminate the people or
limit access
to you from the people who are causing
you to feel bad about you there's no way
you're gonna create
amazing things build an amazing business
if you're around
negative people who bring you down all
the time it's just not possible
so step one eliminate those people or
limit access step two
now you've got this hole you've got a
gap in your schedule you've got extra
time
now on your hands and now what you want
to do is fill it with positivity and i
see two paths here
one you want to start trying to hang out
with people who feel the same way you do
and so
look for entrepreneur events look for
meetup groups look for conferences that
are coming to your town
i'm here making this video in las vegas
at every stop along the tour that i've
been doing over the past
x number of days 45 days or so we got a
45 more days ahead
it's been amazing to see the connections
that people make
by being in a room of other successful
entrepreneurs who have the same mindset
of wanting to go off and accomplish
something great
somebody just dm me two days ago of
people who met in my los angeles event
they had never known each other before
they met at my la event and then they
went running together
they went running and caught the sunrise
together in la that's what i'm talking
about
when you start going to events where you
start meeting people who feel the same
way you do who want to build similar
things as you are
it just lifts your energy so much
finally holy cow there's other people
who believe the same thing i do i want
to hang around those people more
and so say yes look at what events are
happening in your city and go to them
some might be free some might be paid
depends on what your budget is but go to
them start meeting people say yes be
around that environment because you're
not getting that right now
with your parents your friends the
circle that's around you immediately you
need to step
out and start hanging around these
people and start going to events maybe
you only meet one person at that event
that's okay that's the start surround
yourself with those people
you're not in a big enough hurry because
you don't view patience and
impatience properly you were trained and
conditioned with a perspective that does
not serve you
today we're gonna break that we're to
set you free
so you can start hitting your goals a
lot faster most people
are patient with themselves but
impatient with the results
i'll say that again you're patient with
yourself
but you're impatient with the results
you want the results to happen
right away you're impatient like when am
i going to get these results but you're
patient with yourself you'll give
yourself a break you'll let yourself
down like i'll do that tomorrow
you're patient with yourself but you're
impatient with the results
i want you to flip it this is the
perspective shift that if you understand
and make in your business your entire
life will change
you need to flip it you want to be
patient with the results
and impatient with yourself you want to
be
patient with the results and impatient
with yourself
know that the results that you're after
will take time you're chasing down big
goals you're an entrepreneur you want to
do amazing things it's going to take
some time for that to happen but the
impatience you need to put on a daily
basis
is on yourself that you do the most that
you can do today
and every single day to move a little
bit closer to achieving your goals
so look at my business as an example my
next goal is to hit 10 million
subscribers
on my main youtube channel that's a big
goal it's gonna take me a while to get
there
right it's not gonna happen tomorrow no
matter how much work i put in no matter
what i do it's not happening tomorrow
it's gonna take some time
i get that i'm patient with that and
i'm insanely impatient with myself it's
like what can i do more
today to get me closer to that goal if
you don't get this right
your business will fail it's not just
about what you love doing and the skill
sets you have it's about
having similar core values as the people
that you bring on board
you need to know what your who is you
need to know what you stand for
as a human being you need to know what
your mission is and bring people on
board
who have similar core values this is
where so many entrepreneurs fail
if you only do a self-assessment and say
well i'm good at this
i'm going to be the technician i'm going
to be the artist i'm going to be the
coder
i'm going to be the one doing all of the
actual work
and i need to partner up with somebody
who's a business person who's going to
be doing the deals in the media and
raising the capital and talking to
investors and
doing the sales pitches it's not enough
to say well
i'm good at this and you're good at this
so let's get together and that's what so
many people do
that's why so many business partnerships
fail because you're just looking at it
on paper
you're just saying well they have the
skill sets i don't have great let's work
together boom we're in business
and often times entrepreneurs will then
say hey well let's do 50 50.
right you're bringing this i'm running
this so
here we go 50 50 partnership and for
those who've been through it before
you know how much of a disaster that can
be because everything looks good on
paper
but you can't make a decision just based
off of paper it's like
going to a dating website and putting
your ideal person
and then deciding to marry that person
without ever going on a date
it's about core values why do things
fall apart because you don't share the
same core values
and a lot of times you don't even know
what your own core value is to start
with
so you figure out your one word your
most important core value that's the
starting point you have to figure it out
i mean it'll serve you
not just for your business but for any
relationship for life
this is what you stand for as a human
and then you want to attract people who
not just have the skill set
and the desire but the same core value
because you know what
the skill set is actually easier to
teach than the core value
to make somebody change their beliefs i
don't know how to do it it's crazy it's
it's ridiculous to give somebody a new
skill set
is way easier to teach you spend too
much time
focused on the small decisions that
don't actually move your business
forward
instead of focusing on the ones that you
actually get pumped for
so look at my business i look at my
youtube channel my goal right now is i
want to get 10 million subscribers
on my main youtube channel i'm excited
i'm pumped let's go do it
i'm chasing it down and i've got a list
of ideas a giant list of ideas
and as people watch my videos and i talk
to my friends about it they give me more
ideas
and the list just keeps building is this
something that you can resonate with
that list of ideas just keeps growing
and growing and growing i keep it in
evernote i don't know where you write
down your ideas
the problem is most of those ideas they
could be fantastic strategic ideas it
just makes total logical sense to do
those things
but i look at them and they're like yeah
okay yeah
man it's okay yeah that's good we should
do that
yeah yeah
if you're not emotionally attached to it
you won't have massive success
doing it it has to be a hell yes and so
when my tour came along the idea of
doing a
23 city 90-day tour i don't have time
for it
logically it makes no sense i don't have
time to do this it's crazy look at this
giant list of ideas i have to do
hell yes i want to do that and off we go
23 cities 90 days i just got back hey
back in my
entrepreneur lane setting here for those
of you who are
og for my channel you have to chase the
hell yes decisions and stop getting
stuck
in the meh in okay land i hate spending
money until i'm making money
if you do not have money it's because
you are
spending your money on things that are
not making you money
this is what happens in so many
entrepreneurs businesses when you're
starting
you go and you spend a whole bunch of
money on different gear equipment
samples
products and then it doesn't work out
instead of going out and spending money
at the start
find a way to get started on the cheap
invest in your energy
your hustle your drive your initiative
but not your money
here's what happens someone wants to
start a t-shirt business okay great
to get the price discounts that you want
so that on a per t-shirt basis it's
cheaper
you have to order 5 000 t-shirts so you
go out and you spend all your money
ordering 5 000 t-shirts or worse you go
take a loan
so you can get your 5 000 t-shirts the
t-shirts come in
you sell three of them and then you have
4 97 t-shirts sitting in your mom's
basement
that's most people you'll spend money
because you've got this ambitious dream
and vision and you
see in your head how it's all going to
work out but then when you get started
it never works out that you think it's
going to work out when i first started
on youtube
i had a team of eight or so people
already in my other business in my main
business
and so i'm gonna try this thing on the
side just as a fun thing and see how it
goes
i did everything myself myself i did
everything myself
invest my energy my heart my hustle my
drive my
intuition into making something happen
and once i started making some money
then i could invest
into building a team into getting gear
into building this business up
so now we've got 24 people on the team
when i first started doing my instagram
live morning shows
it was me and my tripod and a cell phone
and
a guest and we went live on instagram
every day
and then people said hey you should get
a microphone okay great i got
a quick little microphone that connected
and we went
now this thing might be the future that
may be all i do i might even close down
youtube and just do instagram lives
and if that happens then i'll invest in
a team and making that happen
maybe in three years if i'm still doing
it there'll be 20 people in the room
from a producer and camera people and
editors and everybody's in the room
guiding the show right that might be the
future
but i don't know i gotta start by just
doing one show
you do not have money because you're
spending your money on the things that
are not working and generating money
back for you
so stop spending money stop stop it
right now stop spending money on things
that don't make you money
instead invest your energy your hustle
your time
your drive as a default until you're
making a little bit of money from that
thing
a little bit of money from that thing
and then you can invest that money to
make more money
if you are thinking about how many hours
you're working and you're frustrated and
you're complaining i think you've lost
like i think if you are counting down as
an entrepreneur how many more hours to
go
until the day is over until you get to
go on your vacation until
you know the weekend is here i think
you've lost like i genuinely think
you've lost
you have to love the work if you look at
at all of the people that i've done
profiles on across
entrepreneurship athletics singing
everybody they love the work you have to
love the process
not just the results it's why you have
to love it so much to put through
all the crap all the negativity all the
burnout all of the stuff that happens to
you as an entrepreneur you have to deal
with it
and the only thing that gets you through
is you love it
i love making videos i'm here in
albuquerque
nina's getting her nails done danny's
getting his
phone charged in the car and i'm making
videos because i love making videos
because i can't wait to make videos
i've done six thousand plus videos on my
channel and i can't wait
to make more i love it i love the
process i love helping entrepreneurs i
love the result
and i love the process and yes that can
cause personal issues that can cause
health breakdowns that can cause you to
get stressed out
that can cause you to push beyond your
limits that can cause you
health issues it can relationship issues
i can and it does for so many
entrepreneurs
and yes you need to guard for that you
need to watch for that you need to be
able to create
an intentional life not just working
working working working working working
all the time and then you die
but you need to love the work you need
to love the process
it's not painful to do it saying pay the
price it's not painful to pay the price
for you stepping into my schedule making
6 000 videos you might think is really
painful for me it's not
like i love it it's great it's amazing
and that should be the same thing in
your business
people who say it say we'll do whatever
it takes no you won't
you won't do whatever it takes because
as soon as it starts getting really hard
you're going to quit
where somebody who actually loves that
thing will keep going
because they love it and you don't and
whenever you're up against somebody who
loves to work and you don't they will
destroy you
even if you have more natural talent
they will destroy you
because they love the work and you don't
it makes all the difference in the world
your entire life changes when you decide
to take responsibility for where you're
at
for for your happiness for your success
for where you're at in life when you
decide
that i am responsible everything changes
we don't want to because it's easier to
blame somebody else
it's easy to blame somebody else we
don't want to blame the person in the
mirror we don't blame ourselves it's
somebody else's fault right
it's nina's fault that i'm not happy
where are you nina
[Music]
it's nina's fault that i'm not happy
right it's so good to put the blame on
somebody else
because that means i don't have to do
anything but when you take the personal
responsibility when i say
it's my fault that i'm not happy it's my
fault that i'm not more successful it's
not my team's fault that my company is
not
blowing up as big as i wanted to it's my
fault i need to get better
it's not my trainer's fault that i'm not
getting results in the gym it's my fault
right i got to eat better i got to work
out more it's my fault
it's your fault you are where you are
because of you
and when you accept that then you choose
to now live a life
of being able to make progress most
people don't want to do that most people
would rather
consume entertainment instead of
education
most people would rather consume
entertainment and sit down and watch
netflix and forget about their crappy
life
and try to fix it most channels on
youtube that blow up are not
education related they're entertainment
because people want to shut off their
life
shut up their brain and just be
entertained instead of trying to
actually fix the problem
if you're a subscriber here you're
probably on the education side but are
you the kind of person
who's going to take responsibility and
fix your life
or just shut up the world blame complain
wait till you can't
have that next vacation you can't wait
till that next weekend or the evenings
are coming up
because your life sucks your life sucks
is it your fault or somebody else's
when you take ownership that's when life
starts to change nobody wants to work
with somebody who doesn't have integrity
but what is integrity what does that
mean for you how do you find it how do
you know what you stand for for me it
all comes down to values
when you understand what you stand for
as a human being when you know what your
most important core value is then you
know
how to live with integrity and you know
how to build a business based around
integrity as well
and so the process that i go through is
your one word i wrote a book about it
you can read it you can pick it up and
understand how to apply it to your
business and your life
but at the course figuring out if i had
to stand for one thing as a human being
what is that thing and so quick process
let's go through this quick exercise
together you can pick up the book later
right now think about
one who was your favorite teacher
growing up you've had
lots of teachers growing up through high
school university elementary school
who was your favorite teacher it wasn't
because they taught you grade 10 math
there was a reason what was it who was
the person and what was it
two what was your favorite movie growing
up pick your favorite movie and why
and then three who's your favorite
entrepreneur who's the person
you looked up to the most who did you
learn the most from who do you most want
to emulate
if i run through that scenario for
myself number one my favorite teacher is
madame farr growing up
at my school crescent school she always
believed in me she always helped me she
always guided me
she helped take me from being a b
student to
a plus student in my final year she made
me feel like it was possible
two my favorite movie is seabiscuit it's
about this
racehorse that's too small and a jockey
that's too big and an owner that has no
money
and a trainer that's down on his luck
and they all seem to come together
to build this racehorse that goes off
and wins a whole bunch of races
and helps lift the nation based off a
true story i've seen that movie at least
30
times three my favorite entrepreneur is
ap giannini he started bank of america
he was the guy who first gave immigrants
in america
money as a loan he lent money to people
based off of a handshake
and a look in their eye if you can
imagine he gave walt disney the money to
have his first feature-length cartoon
everybody thought he was crazy
and so what's a common thread through
all that between madame far
seabiscuit ap giannini they may all seem
totally disconnected
they're not if i had to write down three
characteristics this is what you should
do you write down your three names
and then you have three characteristics
for each one the word believe pops off
the sheet for me
i think about all of them and believe
comes out madame far believed in me
my other teachers were really nice they
really helped me it was amazing but
she really helped move the needle
because she believed in me seabiscuit
i've seen lots of movies i love them all
it's great
but the the idea of believe coming
through
that racehorse i love it it's a cheesy
movie
but i love it and then epigene is the
believe banker
let money the people and bet on them
when nobody else believed in them
my one word is belief as a result i've
built my entire business around it
right my life and my business are built
around believe my videos my newsletter
my website my speaking gigs the books
that i write everything i create
it's not just a strategy it's a way of
living
and that's having integrity with
yourself so why don't i make a top 10
video series on the stupidest things
that people say
because it's anti-belief because it's
negative
my channel would actually be bigger if i
did the negative side of things people
would rather
be entertained and laugh at others than
educate themselves
and get better people would rather sit
at home and watch four hours of netflix
every night
then go off and spend four hours
learning and try to build a business
they just would we'd rather be
entertained and educated
but i don't want to be in that business
i don't want to be
in a negative business i don't want to
be in the hater business because my one
word is believed
and so that's having integrity with
myself and then integrity with
you guys my audience my customers the
people that i work with
and so yes integrity is at the core of
everything if you don't have integrity
people do not want to work with you but
how
do you figure out what that means of
course you're not going to go lie to
somebody
right of course stealing is gonna be bad
but what else how do you get more
specific
the biggest problem is lack of clarity
people don't know what they stand for
and as a result you're living up to
other people's expectations and versions
where i want you to live inside yourself
i want you to be standing on a rock
when everybody else is sending on
quicksand you have clarity you have
definiteness of purpose
and it starts with figuring your one
word so you pick up the book or you can
go through that three-step process
think about who your favorite teacher
was and why write three words down for
it
think about what your favorite movie is
and why write three words down for it
and think about who your favorite
entrepreneur or hero is of all time
and why write three words down from it
look at what's similar
your one word will pop off the page and
now you know what integrity means to you
people sabotage themselves because they
care too much what other people think
you're spending money that you don't
have on stupid things that you don't
need because you
value what other people think of you
more than what you
think of you if you can't get out of
that trap you'll never build the left
that you want
you'll just constantly be in reaction
mode doing what other people expect of
you
so i think you should attack judgment i
think it's good i think whenever you
feel that you were playing small because
of somebody else's
opinion of you then you have to go off
and do that thing you need to attack
judgment
i think it's one of the greatest skills
that you can ever teach yourself
one of the greatest practices you can do
on a daily basis i think we play small
by
default as humans i think it's baked
into us i think because of our
survival characteristics of how we need
to fit into
society to win i think we play small by
default
and so you need to learn to attack
judgment so here's an example my agent
steve i was on the phone with him
and i was telling him about my new
morning routine you know
i can't do much for myself right now i
broke my neck i broke my upper back
i had a concussion in the early days
when i first fell and hit my head
and and all i can do is speak which is
great for making videos but i can't move
i i couldn't put my pants on by myself i
couldn't do a lot of stuff by myself
and so my agent steve says you need to
film your new morning routine
you need to show your audience what
you're going through you need to do an
instagram live
and show us what's happening like
really i'm thinking to myself
you want me to show off me putting my
pants on in the morning and
i'm feeling self-conscious i've gained
some weight because i haven't been able
to move around
i've never made a video in my underwear
before
you know all this all of these thoughts
going through my head and because that's
part of the reason because i'm worried
about
your judgment then i have to do it i
have to do it
the next day right like asap you have to
go do the thing
learn to attack judgment because as long
as you
play small because you're worried about
somebody else's opinions of you
you'll never go off and do the crazy
things that you want to do you're
entrepreneurs
you want to go off and change the world
you want to do amazing things you've got
visionary ideas of things that you want
to go off and do
that means you're going to attack the
status quo there's a lot of people who
want to protect the status quo
a lot of people so you're going to get
judged you're going to get attacked
you're going to get criticized because
your ideas are different
you're a weird duck be proud of it and
so anytime you catch yourself
playing small worrying about somebody
else's opinion learn to attack it
entrepreneurs don't have to be giant
risk takers
some entrepreneurs have to go all in
it's the only way they can operate
burn the boats have no plan b have no
escape
no parachute all in one way trip
it's the only way they operate but
there's tons of successful entrepreneurs
who win by building sustained momentum
by taking
small successful risks over and over
again
but never putting it all on the line i
love small starts
i love finding ways to get started on
tons of different ideas
and seeing what sticks and where my
heart lies and following those through
but i'll never put in tons of money
before putting in the effort and energy
to see if i'd love it to try to get
results so i look at youtube as an
example
it's 10 years of having this channel
it's wow that's crazy i started it just
as an experiment i had a successful
website i had eight people on my team
building up this new web business that i
was a part of
and i just wanted to try youtube i
wanted to make visual content i love
learning from successful people and so i
wanted to tell those stories in a visual
way
that plus people kept asking me
questions i had sold my company
and so they asked me questions evan how
do i do this how do i do that
great so i would make videos answering
questions for people
but i did it all myself right like i got
some friends to volunteer
to help me make some of my early videos
and then everything was me
i had money i sold my business i had a
team working on my website
but i was doing this little skunk works
project
all by myself just to go just make it
happen just to see
just to see if i like it see if i can
build some momentum
and so i researched and i edited and i
filmed
i did everything and as it started then
to make some money
then i could invest that money back into
my business and then it slowly
built up to the point where we're at
right now
you need to be people's chief goal
officer if you want to move them into
action
if you want them to win you have to
speak to them in their language and the
things that they care about
the worst advice you could give somebody
is what you would do
if you treat everybody who works with
you and for you
like the way you would be treated you're
going to lose forever you're never going
to build the organization you want
because people have different goals and
it's your job to understand what they
are
so i'm doing this tour right now 90 days
23 cities i often get asked by people
hey evan what book should i read what
video do you recommend
from your channel for an entrepreneur
i've done 6 000 videos the worst advice
i could give is to give a generic answer
the worst advice i could give is to one
that i would watch like here's a video
that i love the most
for me to give a good answer to you i
need to know your problem i need to be
your chief goal officer i need to
understand what you're struggling with
i could give you the greatest book
recommendation of all time but if it's
not the thing that you care about right
now it's not going to serve you
and so before you give advice before you
try to help somebody else out
be their chief goal officer there's two
ways to do it
understand or who and understand their
why their who is their most important
one word core value
and their why is their purpose and their
purpose comes from their pain so look at
their who i'll use an example with alex
who who runs toronto dance salsa for me
his who is belong his one word is belong
he wants to create a place where people
feel like they belong it's the one word
for him it's one word for tds i know
that's what he really cares about
for me belonging doesn't really matter
if i don't feel like i belong in a room
i'm not bothered by it i don't care what
other people think of me it's
so low down on my list of priorities and
values of what i personally care about
but for him it's number one
he wants to make people feel like they
belong that's his one word most
important core value that's his who
so i understand a little bit more about
him i understand how to push him the
next is your why your purpose comes from
your pain
for him he struggled so much in in
making friends and feeling accepted
he had super sweaty hands and when he
held the girl's hand he would
slide out because he sweats so much and
it tied into him never feeling like he
belonged and so
this is now his purpose for life is to
help other people feel like they belong
that there's a space
for them to come to and feel like they
belong his favorite movie of all time
is hercules the disney movie the cartoon
where in that song they said something
about a place where you belong
and when he hears that song he cries
great this is
alex right i might play that song for
myself and think that's a good song
i might play that song for somebody else
and they hate that song
screw hercules amazing everybody's
different
you need to be their chief goal officer
so if i'm talking to alex and trying to
motivate and push him and have him build
an amazing company that he's proud
of i'm going to use words like belong
i'm going to use movie references like
hercules
i'm going to talk about creating a place
where people can come together and feel
like they're finally accepted
because that's at the core of what he's
all about that's me being his chief goal
officer and so you need to do that for
everybody on your team you need to do
that for every customer
that you work with stop treating
everybody the same way
there's the classic rule of doing to
others as you would have them do unto
you and that's great and that's treating
people with compassion and care and
kindness
but everybody's motivated by different
things and if you can only treat people
one way the way that you would like to
be treated
you're going to only have success with a
very narrow band of people
a very narrow band of customers a very
narrow band of employees
a very narrow brand of partners you're
going to stay in this tiny little lane
your entire life and never build a huge
company but if you can learn to be
somebody's chief goal officer
if you can learn to understand what
drives them moves them pushes them what
their
who is what their why is why they're
here what they're trying to accomplish
you start building an eight-lane
superhighway you can build a company
that can take over the world
i much more want to enjoy the process of
the work that i'm doing
than than getting the end result when i
made my youtube channel and
we hit a million subscribers everybody's
asking me
what's the celebration what are you guys
gonna do what's the plan
i don't know i i didn't need to
celebrate
we ended up doing a live stream because
i wanted to celebrate with you guys
because it was important for you but for
me
i don't i don't care to celebrate like
let's keep going i love
this is the celebration making these
videos
is the celebration not getting the
plaque not crossing a milling not
xyz i mean results matter of course but
the process
enjoying the process and doing difficult
things
is how i get myself to take action
not visualizing the end result
you need to learn to love struggle you
need to learn to tell yourself that the
struggle
is the best because if you're not
chasing down difficult things you're
living a life so
safe so inside your comfort zone that
you're never happy
i had a woman come out to my event last
night here in milwaukee
and i gave her some advice on how to
build her business and she said wow that
sounds so
hard yeah
teach yourself that you're the kind of
person who does hard things
i love hacks i love shortcuts i love
optimizing i love it it's amazing it's
the best
and i love doing difficult things
otherwise
you stay inside your comfort zone and
you only do the things that you feel
safe to do and then you hate your life
if you're not pushing up against your
comfort zone if you're not stretching
further if you're not going into the
struggle
you hate your life the people who are
the most fulfilled are the ones who are
off
pushing the envelope doing difficult
things i look at this i broke my neck in
denver
right i broke my neck i continued to
tour
we still had i don't know five or six
more stops that we had to make almost a
month of touring
you still had to go off into the tour i
cancelled one stop
then i did a short version in kansas
city and then
i did all the way through we're still
going full three hours
i had to still make videos right videos
still have to go up
last week i was still suffering from a
concussion
so i i hit my head on on a on a
baseboard cut my head open
had three staples in the back of my head
broke my neck broke my
upper back got a concussion still got to
make videos
right i still have to make videos i love
it
because it's in the difficult times that
you show yourself what you're made of
when it's easy and you win you don't
care if you win a race against
three-year-olds who cares
but if you go up and race against usain
bolt and he beats you
backwards on one leg you're still pumped
because you got in the race against
usain bolt
the self-pride the self-respect the
confidence the growth
comes from doing things that you
struggle with not from always doing the
easy thing
you hate your life if you're just doing
the easy thing
i think you need to be your customer's
chief goal officer i think if you want
to win in business you have to
understand your customers you become
their chief goal officer if you want to
accomplish your goals
the best way to get there is help your
customers accomplish their goals if
you're helping them
you're solving problems guess what
you're going to make money they're going
to pay you to do it
now you have to combine what they want
right you're the chief goal officer this
is what they want
and combine it with what you love doing
can you help them solve that problem are
you the person to solve it or do you
want to refer somebody else
off to them to solve that problem when
you can mix those things together the
thing you
absolutely love doing with what the
customer so desperately wants
that's when you start to win having a
cause will make you feel like a
superhero
it'll allow you to do things you never
thought you'd do and give you the
courage you never thought you'd have
all of your heroes had a cause and if
you want to stop selling sugar water and
change the world
it's time to find yours i love the steve
jobs story i'm a huge fan of steve i
have his poster on my wall
as one of five people that i look up to
on a daily basis but one of the things
that i really find
most valuable about having a cause is it
can allow you to have the courage
to be the evangelical person even if
it's not naturally who you are
i look at steve jobs and i see someone
who is naturally talented who's a great
salesperson
who has the gift of gab who loves being
in the spotlight who is that person who
likes being up front and center
and so it's easy to go off and be that
person now you combine that with a cause
and you get a company like apple but
having a cause can make you evangelical
even if you are introvert and shy and
don't like the spotlight
i know because i'm talking about myself
i
am an introvert i don't like talking to
people i don't talk to the person next
to me on the airplane being in front of
the camera makes me nervous
being in front of a giant audience makes
me shy much rather be at the back of a
room
than be the center of attention one of
the things i used to fight the most with
my agent about was
he would say that evan you don't want to
be famous that's a problem
like yeah i don't want to be famous it's
not about me it's about the cause
and recently it started to sink in that
by me becoming more famous i could
spread the message more but it's one of
the biggest things that we
kept fighting over because i don't crave
the limelight where a lot of people they
absolutely have to have it
but when you have a cause it forces you
to the front
i make videos because i want to help
entrepreneurs i make videos because i
struggled so much your purpose comes
from your pain i struggled so much and
started my business
i want to make the path a little bit
easier for the next generation of people
coming through
i'm making videos and content and
speeches for
the 19 year old version of myself that
needed to hear this stuff
and so i feel it's my responsibility
it's my obligation i have to do it and
it forces me out into stages
that normally i would say you're crazy
i'm on this tour right now
right i gave up a quarter of my year 90
days to hit 23 cities
and do the thing that i'm most afraid to
do which is get up and potentially
disappoint people
every four days by doing another event
and i kept going even though i broke my
neck i broke my neck
three weeks ago in denver and
and we kept going i only cancelled one
event completely
and it just got up and kept going and so
having that cause
feeling like the work that you do is
important and meaningful is the whole
thing
the problem is you're not proud of
yourself you might post about some
accomplishment you've done on facebook
or instagram
but when it's you by yourself all alone
deep down
you're not actually proud of yourself so
why where does that come from
it's because you've taught yourself that
you set goals
and you don't consistently follow
through so now when you set a new goal
for yourself
you don't believe that you're actually
going to follow through and that
continues to cycle
on and on and spirals down into you not
being proud of yourself
we need to change that today so it
starts with this when you set a goal you
have to follow through the only
acceptable reason for not following
through
is you being proud of yourself are you
proud of the reason
why you didn't follow through so a
couple examples when i started my tour
the very first stop the pre-tour stop
was boston
i had a goal at that time that i was
going to run 30 minutes of cardio every
day
we drove the bus and i drove the whole
way didn't sleep a wink
got in at two in the morning i hadn't
done my cardio what do i need to do
i need to do my cardio why because i
told myself i committed to doing
30 minutes of cardio every single day
the cardio was the worst cardio of all
time
barely moving right just kind of half
eyes closed
trying to struggle my way through the 30
minutes health-wise i burnt zero
calories
it would have been better for me to go
to sleep mentally though
for the mindset i'm pumped it's when
it's
hard and you do the thing that you
actually build your self-respect
your self-pride your self-love your
self-confidence
when it's easy and you win you could
post about it on instagram
congratulations but you don't feel great
about yourself because it was easy
but when it's hard and you try that's
when you start building
self-respect self-accountability
self-pride
that's where it comes from and so in
boston i woke up the next day and i was
tired and i had a sluggish
hard day trying to get through it which
was not great for my body
but mentally i'm pumped like i did the
thing when it was difficult
if i just went to bed i would have had
to ask myself am i proud of the reason
why i'm not doing this
other people would let me off the hook
i'm sure the people i went down with
nina my wife danny my camera guy would
have said it's okay go to sleep it's two
in the morning you drove
all this way it's like it's a strange
day it's not a typical day
you have every reason in the world not
to do it people will let you off the
hook all the time
because they don't hold themselves to
high standards and then they
infect you with their lower standards i
would not have been proud of myself if i
didn't do my run
even though the results sucked
it's the effort that's where the pride
comes from
just be yourself is one of the most
common pieces of advice that you hear
from successful people
just be yourself everyone else is taken
just be yourself your
unique snowflake yes amazing but how
how do i do it how do i find it and once
i find it how do i have the confidence
to actually live it how give me the how
you're in luck i'm going to give you the
three-step process on how
to actually find out who you are and
have the confidence to live it
we're going to go through three steps
who why how your who
your why your how you figure that out
you're set up for life it's one of the
most powerful exercises you will ever do
in your life
let's dig in number one you're who
you're who is your one word most
important core value
what is your single most important core
value
mine is belief when you understand what
you're saying for you're less likely to
be pulled in other people's directions
so quick tips on how to find it what's
your favorite movie of all time
mine is seabiscuit it's about this horse
that's too small and a jockey
too big and an owner that has no money
and they find each other and they start
winning a whole bunch of races
right what's your favorite song of all
time who's your favorite teacher of all
time and why
and if you look at all these things that
you have loved it wasn't because
mrs jones taught you math in grade eight
it's because of the characteristic
there's a common thread between all the
things that you love that make you happy
that's your one word that's your most
important core value when you figure
that out
now you can live a life on purpose and
bring those things to you
so for me believe i'm not going to make
a video that's trashing somebody
i'm not going to make a top 10 stupidest
things that this person ever said
even though it might make me more money
even though might bring me more
subscribers even though it might get me
more attention
i don't want to do it because it's
anti-belief and knowing that
knowing what i stand for then makes it
easy to put that shield up to say no
i don't care about your opinion i don't
care that you think i should go do that
thing
i know what i stand for it gives you a
rock to stand on where most people are
sitting on quicksand
figure out your who step two is figure
out your why that's your purpose
your purpose comes from your pain think
about the most painful moment in your
life your purpose for life will be to
help other people
who are currently experiencing that pain
to find somebody who is going through
the thing that caused you the most pain
in your life
will lift you up and give you so much
joy i can't explain it and your who and
your why
your one word and your purpose are for
life so for me my why
my purpose is helping entrepreneurs
because i struggled so much as an
entrepreneur
because i turned down huge jobs to make
300 bucks a month and earn 30
of a company and i hated my life like i
felt worthless i felt like i wasn't
giving any value it sucked
i eventually made it through and i i
want to help entrepreneurs because i
remember struggling so much as an
entrepreneur
i don't want other people to have to
struggle the same way that i struggled
and so my one word is believe i could
believe in anybody i could believe in
lots of people
everybody needs believing in but i love
helping entrepreneurs more
because that's where i came from because
that was my biggest struggle
it's my biggest pain and so think about
your most painful moment of all time
helping the people who are currently
experiencing the thing that you went
through
is going to be the thing that will fill
you up for life your who and your why
are for life they will never change
they're with you for life and so it's
worth going through that thought
experiment
to find it because most of america has
no idea what they stand for and what
their purpose is
step three is your how now it's figuring
out how did you get through the thing
that you went through right i struggled
as an entrepreneur
the thing that saved my business was
modeling bill gates how did bill gates
build a software company that's what i
had i had a software company
i wasn't working i copied bill gates's
strategies i applied it to my business
had my first sale shortly after for 13
and a half thousand dollars
it made it seem like a lot of money but
for me it was it was
money it was money it was bank like holy
cow something's actually working
and so ever since then that was when i
was
19 20 years old ever since then whenever
i don't know what to do
i model success i modeled bill gates
success and put that to my company
i had success and so what have i done
for the past 20 years
made made content made videos look at my
channel profiling different successful
entrepreneurs to model their success
the path that i use to get out of the
hole
is the path that i teach the path that
you use to get out of the hole that
you're in
becomes a path that you teach it's a
it's a system
it's replicatable you can teach other
people how to do it because a lot of the
people
who are struggling with the thing that
you struggled with they never find their
way out
you can help them by showing them the
path that you took
and so your who your why your how
when you figure that out that's how you
are yourself
and now you've got this amazing rock the
stained on when other people think you
should go do something else
you don't care it doesn't hit you it
bounces off you because you're confident
in yourself
and so yes be yourself and it's going to
come up over and over and over and over
again look at the top 10s look at the
espressos look at all the videos look at
the interviews look at the people that
you look up to they're all gonna say
just be yourself but how this is the
process
figure out your who figure out your why
figure out your how
go through those three steps and you're
set up for life
and i'm so pumped to see the journey
that you go on most people are so afraid
of losing that they don't even try
you'd rather stay average because going
for greatness means you might fail
adopt this mindset it's better to know
and to fail than not to know all of your
heroes failed on their path to success
and if you are unwilling to risk failure
for greatness
you will stay on your exact same path
that you're on right now
so i was recently faced with an
impossible choice where i didn't know
the outcome where two people who i
respected told me
opposite bits of advice and it was
around splitting up my youtube channel
i have had my youtube channel my main
one for over 10 years it's crazy
10 years of creating content i got up to
making three videos a day on my main
channel
i get on a call with matt guillen who's
one of four people in the world
who they gave me advice on youtube i
would really
strongly deeply think about it i respect
him and three other people that much and
he told me evan
you need to split up your channel evan
doing three videos a day on the same
channel
hurts you and you should split it up
into multiple channels
that was an impossible choice i mean for
me it was it was
scary it was difficult i don't know the
outcome
so i asked some other friends of mine
somebody else in the top four
and he says that is the biggest mistake
you can make
don't do it it's a huge mistake for your
channel
it'll hold you back so now what do i do
there's four people in the world whose
opinions i respect and trust on this one
topic
and two of them are giving me exact
opposite advice
what do i do for me the decision was
easy
the action was difficult it was tough
but we do tough things
right we're entrepreneurs here's my
decision making process i would rather
know and fail than not know
going my current course of making three
videos a day on one channel
i know what that looks like i'm liking
my success i'm liking my growth
but splitting up my channels and going
down to one video a day on my main
channel
i didn't know if that would work and if
i don't try
i'll never know so even though one
person i really respect tells me
it's the biggest mistake of my life it
may be it may be the worst decision that
i ever make
in my youtube career but i won't know
unless i try
and would rather live my life without
regrets
knowing that i got the information
instead of being afraid to act
and so i split it up and listen right
now it's actually not working
right now the views on my main channel
are down the subscribers on my main
channel are down
the amount of money i make for my main
channel is down and my other channels
like this one haven't grown enough
to combat it to replace it
but i'm still soldiering on i'm still
continuing down this path
now if it's a year and it's still the
same thing okay
maybe i have to go back to my old
strategy but at least i would know
and so you can look at that and say well
you lost all that opportunity
yeah i made a mistake but i'd rather
know
and fail than not no because if you only
take safe bets
if you only take the bets that you know
you're going to win at with 100
certainty
then you play small for life then you're
only going to take on the projects
that there's zero risk of failure at
which means you stay in this tiny circle
i don't want to live in a tiny circle i
want to change the world i want to have
a huge impact
that comes with a great deal of failure
just like all your heroes
you need to be more impatient with
yourself but patient with the results
flip it most people are impatient with
the results
you want the money right now you want
the customers right now you want the
views right now you want the subscribers
right now but you're patient with
yourself
you let yourself off the hook all the
time you procrastinate and don't put in
100
effort that needs to change flip it
be more patient with the results and
impatient
with yourself because if you're
impatient with yourself
if you demand 100 percent effort of
yourself
every single day i guarantee you the
results will come
the decisions that you make when you're
feeling bold are actually the right ones
for you
and your head starts talking you down
from doing them when you're feeling bold
unstoppable confident powerful and you
make a decision you make a choice you
say i'm gonna go off and do this thing
that is actually the best thing that you
need to go off and do
you have to listen to it you have to
take that jump
otherwise you will still be in the same
spot you are currently in
right now five years from today so i
just came back from doing a tour
90-day tour 23 different cities it all
started because
i was walking down the street on a warm
summer day last year and i decided i'm
going to take nina my wife
to every city in north america with a
million plus people crazy goal right my
next evolution the next leap the next
jump
every city north america with my wife
let's go
and then your head gets in the way then
your head starts thinking
how many cities are there how do we plan
for this nina has a full-time job how
are we going to make it all work what's
the timeline going to be
your default first step needs to be
action instead of thinking
what most of us will do as soon as you
come with an idea is you go home and you
think and you plan and you ponder and
you strategize and you think
and you use all of your creative bold
confident energy
into planning the problem is you wake up
the next day a different person
you wake up the next day thinking i
can't do that i can't
go to every city in north america with a
million plus people i can't do this
i can't do that you come up with all the
reasons that are logical
that are practical as to why you can no
longer do that thing
you were feeling bold and confident
yesterday but today you can't do it
that's why your default first step needs
to be action
use that bold creative powerful energy
into action into committing yourself to
doing something
and taking what i call the first two
percent the two percent difference
that means don't go home and plan your
way to hitting a hundred percent of your
goal
immediately take the first two percent
action to move a tiny bit closer to your
goal
and so i said i'm going to take my wife
nina every city in north america a
million plus people great
what's my first step not researching how
many cities not trying to figure out how
nina's gonna quit her job
not any of that stuff not planning not
strategizing it's
this weekend we're gonna go to boston
because i knew boston had a million plus
people and i knew nina hadn't been there
yet so we're gonna go to boston
it was actually the wrong plant it
wasn't the closest city i thought it was
the closest city but there's
multiple cities that are closer but the
imperfect plan that you act
on is better than the perfect plan that
you sit on and never do anything about
and so we went to boston that weekend it
was a wednesday
afternoon i decided by friday night we
were leaving and driving to boston
action this is the thing that most
people are missing you don't have enough
action the two percent difference stop
planning to 100
and figure out what the smallest
possible simplest version of
doing that thing is right now
immediately
today there are three ways to use
technology and most people pick the one
method that costs them
money you can be entertained you can be
educated
and you can create entertained educated
create the first one costs you money
entertainment
the second one is an investment
education and the third one
makes you money create the answer isn't
to dump your phone and delete
all social media it's to use these
insanely powerful tools
to help you make money and achieve your
goals so what i want you to do is now
evaluate how are you using technology
and where does it fall into those three
categories
entertain educate and create i'll use me
as an example i'll go first
you go next so for me let me look at
youtube as an example
great number one entertain
very little the only entertainment
content that i consume on youtube
is gonna be one music which is really
more just getting my
state into an energetic positive one and
two
on the weekends league of legends
watching my team
tsm hopefully carry the day
other than that i don't spend any time
on entertainment content people send me
links to videos
if alex comes in and wants to show me
some silly videos like dude i'm working
i don't want to be entertained right now
i got stuff to do i want to go crush it
on my goals on my dreams i got a lot
that i need to get done today don't send
me this stuff two
educate i use youtube a lot youtube is
my number one source for education
more than books more than podcasts more
than anything else conferences anything
youtube is where i learn
video content is where i learn most of
my time spent on youtube
is researching and reviewing video clips
that i am
personally getting inspired by that then
i want to share with you
if i am making a video that i'm sharing
with you on any of my channels
is because i have learned something from
them so i'm spending most of my time on
youtube being educated
and then number three is create and i'm
creating a lot
we're doing three videos a day across my
seven channels
so i'm creating so i'm using youtube not
just as a way that cost me money
right that i have to go spend money to
buy something but i'm using it to invest
into myself
as well as to create content and then
generates a return as i can build a
business around it
expecting excellence starts with you
expecting excellence from yourself
people want to work for people who they
aspire to be like
if someone excellent is working for you
but they have higher standards than you
do
they will eventually leave you your
company's limit
is your standards so i look at alex as
an example who helps me run toronto
dance salsa i invest into the company
a number of years ago i became the 100
owner in it and then i'm training alex
to run
it one of the things that alex had an
issue was was showing up on time he had
low standards for himself of being on
time if you said be here at 10 o'clock
he would be here at 10 15 or 10 20 and
that just became what he was known for
everybody knew alex is the guy who
didn't follow through who came late to
things and that was alex
great some people are willing to put up
with it some people will tolerate it
because they like his energy his
enthusiasm his fun his bravado
they like it and they have low standards
for themselves but high achievers
people who have high standards that
would drive them nuts
and people would leave the business
people would not want to work with them
people would
want to go somewhere else because their
standards
are higher than the person that they're
supposed to be working for
nobody wants to be in a situation you do
not want to work for somebody
who has lower standards than you do and
so the challenge became alex we need to
raise your standards
you need to start showing up not just on
time but early
for him now it's 10 minutes early so if
you said he's going to be here at 10
that means you're there at 9 15. you're
there at 10 to 10
you have to be so you're late if you
show up at 10 o'clock
for alex him is his own standards not
somebody else
if you're showing up at 10 o'clock and
you say you're going to be there at 10
o'clock
he's late to himself that's a starting
point
and as his standards have risen so have
the people
underneath his team who are willing to
follow him as your standards rise as you
care more about yourself
and what you're doing and what you will
no longer accept and tolerate
then the people who are working for you
their standards rise as well
and you're able to now attract a much
wider pool
because they want to level up people
want to be around you
yes for your mission but they want to
level up it's your responsibility
to help people level up
and so if you're only at this point as
soon as somebody gets here they're
leaving
but as you can go here then you can
attract a lot of people underneath
who want to level up and they're going
to learn from you not just the knowledge
but the abilities the mindset the hustle
the energy the drive that you pour into
your business
will be an inspiration to other people
when you raise your own standards
you need to stop judging your version of
balance against someone else's
i think this is something that plagues
at least the north american culture
we're constantly comparing what makes us
happy against somebody else's life
you have a version of balance you have a
version of happiness you have a version
of passion it's different for everybody
i can't judge you for what you're doing
the only test is are you proud of
yourself
do your actions map to your ambitions is
what's in your calendar a reflection
of what will make you happy and i think
as soon as you can get into your own
head
as soon as you can understand what
happiness and balance and success looks
like for you
and stop comparing it against somebody
else's version
in your life or on instagram that's when
you can actually go off and find the
success you're after
you need to tie your self-worth to the
effort not the results
if you tie yourself worth to the results
to achieving your goals
then you'll only take on things that you
think you have a high chance of winning
at
you'll constantly quit on your big goals
and only go after the small ones
tie yourself forward to trying to the
effort
to doing it when it's hard make yourself
proud
with the effort that you put in not just
when you win
but if you keep getting up every day and
putting in
effort that you are proud of you will
wane on a level that you never
thought was possible number one is chart
your start
what you do in the first 15 minutes of
your day matters
chart your start have a plan of action
most people wake up like an accident
most people wake up
they're tired you pull out your phone
you start looking at your email and what
are you doing when you're looking at
your email or looking at social media
you're responding to other people's
emergencies
you wake up you're tired and the first
thing you do is you start responding to
other people's emergencies
i want you to control the first part of
your day
chart your start understand what it is
that makes you come alive
understand what is the action that helps
you feel bold
creative unstoppable we've all had it
you've all had moments where you felt
bold courageous and unstoppable
what led to that reverse engineer
yourself what led to you feeling bold is
it watching a video is it reading a book
is it having a conversation
is it doing a meditation is it taking
your dog out for a walk is it cutting
the grass like i don't care
there's no judgment i don't care what
the thing is that makes you feel bold
and courageous and unstoppable
i just want you to do it daily i want
you to start your day with intention
most people don't start their day with
intention and that
makes the difference between the people
who achieve success and the ones who
don't and so chart your start
figure out the thing that makes you come
alive that makes you feel like
that big crazy idea of yours is actually
possible
and put that into the first 15 minutes
of every day if you did the thing that
made you feel bold courageous and
unstoppable
in the first 15 minutes of waking up
every single day
not every day will be amazing but i
guarantee you that your life will look
unrecognizable
from where you are right now chart your
start
your chances of success go up in direct
proportion to your ability to
one pick the right things to work on and
then
two focus on executing those things
it's so easy as an entrepreneur to get
distracted we love shiny objects right
we love
dreaming up new ideas and chasing these
different projects
but if you look at a typical
entrepreneur you'll see that
so many of their projects start and stop
and start and stop and you take
something
10 through or 50 through or sometimes
even like 80 percent through
but unless you're willing to take it to
a hundred you're not gonna get the
results
you're not gonna get the fruit of your
labor because you're just planting a
whole bunch of seeds
constantly but you're never taking care
of that seed you're never watering it
right if you wanna grow a plant
you got to plant the seed you got to
care for the soil you got to add
nutrients you got to water it daily it's
got to have enough sunshine
you got to look after that seed where
most entrepreneurs they don't
they're starting to stop and starting to
stop and start stopping and you never
actually get to where you want to go
people talk about diversification you
need to diversify you need to diversify
and while that's really great as an
investment strategy if you don't know
what you're investing into it's good to
have a big portfolio of different things
so that if one thing doesn't do well
something else is doing well but it
really sucks as business advice because
if you're trying to do
10 different things at once they're all
going to be mediocre they're all going
to be
below average because you're going up
against people who are doing that full
time
and have their focus on it and so it's
much better as an entrepreneur
to one pick the things that you want to
focus on right and then two
actually focus on it do that work andrew
carnegie
was once the richest person in the world
and he had a great quote saying how he
likes to put
all of his eggs in one basket and then
you watch that
basket carefully right it's only a major
risk if you're not
watching the basket if you if you take
your eye off the ball you start looking
elsewhere
and then something happens to your
industry right and so
being the expert being the best at what
you do
will always yield more results more
value more money to you
than being okay at 20 different things
be the best
at one thing focus this is the secret to
getting ahead in business and in life
bring value first you want somebody to
notice you bring value first
you want someone to pay attention to you
bring value first you want somebody to
buy from you
to hook you up with a partner to talk
about you and a speech on stage like you
want people to do stuff for you
bring value first don't go to them
asking for help first
go to them with value first so that
they're stumbling all over themselves
to try to find a way to help you out too
bring
value first most people will never
figure this out most people will
constantly
be begging other people be tweeting at
them and dming them and saying please
help me please help me please help and i
feel so
i feel so bad i feel i feel frustrated
and i feel so bad for these people who
are just asking for help because
you know that they need help but they're
going about it all wrong
by spamming people and begging for help
you're not going to get it instead focus
your efforts like you will never get it
you will never get it this way you're
not going to get to your outcome you're
not going to solve this problem
by begging people you'll get a little
bit like even beggars on the street get
a little bit you'll get a little bit but
you'll never get to where you want to go
ever by begging
instead flip it and spend your time
trying to figure out how you can bring
value to other people first so they
can't wait to help you out too
if i had to give advice to somebody to
have success in any field not just
entrepreneurship
in any field you look at the people who
have the most success in any field
they enjoy the process and too many
people are attached
just to the outcome if you want to make
a blockbuster hit if you want to make a
successful movie
you have to enjoy the process of making
movies
as an entrepreneur if you want to have a
successful product you want to have a
great service that's making a lot of
money you want to have
a huge business whatever you define as
huge or successful
then you need to enjoy the process of
the work that you're doing
on a day-to-day basis and not everything
is going to be amazing you're going to
have down days
but net net you have to enjoy what
you're doing you have to wake up and
look forward to the day that is ahead
and too many entrepreneurs are spending
80 to 90
of their time doing stuff that they're
not good at that they don't want to be
good at that they hate because they feel
they need to do it
to grow their business and only 10 to 20
of their time
on the stuff that they can be genius
level at
and you will not have success in any
endeavor
if you're only spending 10 to 20 of your
time
or less on the stuff that you have the
potential to be
the best in the world at and that you
enjoy if your goal
is just to make a lot of money and
you'll do whatever it takes
just to make that amount of money you'll
never get there because you don't enjoy
the work
where the secret to success is enjoying
the day-to-day
grind because it doesn't feel like a
grind
it feels enjoyable chasing money makes
you do stupid things
money is important it has to be in your
top five it just can't be number one
your heroes the people that you look up
to the people that you want to be like
the ones who went off and changed the
world and made a lot of money in the
process
they had a mission money was not number
one for them look at whoever you look up
to respect
love admire your heroes understand them
look at their story
money's in their top five but it's not
number one and so when you go up against
somebody like that when you go up
against somebody
who's chasing down their purpose
and you're coming into the industry
because you think it's a hot opportunity
for this year
they're gonna crush you you will always
get crushed
by the person who loves the thing
if for you it's just an opportunity and
so that's why
chasing money makes you do stupid things
you get into an industry because you
think it's going to be a hot chance for
you
but you're going to lose because you
don't love it the people who love it
will always win
and so it's much better for you to go
off and chase down something you love
and make money in the process of doing
that thing it's why the number one rule
for success that comes up
the most consistently across all the
people that i profiled
across all different kinds of industries
and backgrounds is you have to love what
you do
i think people should quit way more than
they actually do you stayed in the
business for too long
you stayed with an employee for too long
you stayed in a relationship for too
long
you should have quit on them years ago
but because you've tied yourself worth
to winning
your pride prevents you from quitting
staying in
something even if you hate your life
just staying in it
means that you don't have to admit to
yourself that you're a quitter
and so you stay but you're actually
losing
in my first business with a software
company i i struggled with this
i was 19. i thought i was gonna make it
rich and be a super successful
entrepreneur
and i sucked and i struggled i was
making 300 a month
and and i didn't know what to do
i was too embarrassed to tell my friends
that i had no money and i couldn't go
out with them and that the 20 bucks for
pizza and beer was too expensive for me
and it took me to a rock bottom moment
until i could actually be strategic and
realize that i needed to change
what happened was i told my partner that
i quit we were working
long hours like this was my entire life
working on this business crazy hours and
just not getting results
and so i finally had enough i felt like
a worthless human being and i called my
business partner i said i i'm out like
i have to go do something where i feel
like i can contribute to the world
somehow
and so i told him i quit and then i hung
up the phone and i and i cried i cried
my face off
and i woke up the next day and said i
can't quit on this yet
because i would regret it if i did but i
have to find another way to stand like
this is taking
too much out of me and so i asked myself
who had done this
who had built a software company before
and i looked at bill gates and how he
started microsoft
and i used his strategies to help my
company grow
and then we started to win then we
started to make money and started to get
some customers and clients
and eventually sold my business but i
almost didn't come
back to it if i hadn't been strategic in
that moment and said okay i can't quit
because i'm gonna regret this decision
for the rest of my life
if i didn't step out of that emotional
zone just for a few seconds to realize
i need to keep going and look at who had
done this before
i wouldn't be where i'm at today swap
your nose for not yet
no it's so final no means it's over
there's no path back right it's a no
it's final it's over
finish line we're done right not yet
means there's still hope
there's still a path and i think for any
entrepreneur part of what we're doing is
so visionary it's so different it's so
new
there's going to be a lot of people who
don't agree with what you're doing
because
you're challenging the status quo
because you're trying to do something
that hasn't been done before
and there's a lot of people who like the
way that it's happening right now and so
most people make decisions from their
brain just the logical practical side of
their brain
we're entrepreneurs what we do best is
we make decisions from our heart
and so the brain can only imagine a
world that currently exists right it's
logical it's practical it's what
currently exists
where your heart can create something
brand new that hasn't existed yet before
yet and so you got to turn the nose when
somebody says no
it's not gonna happen you're never gonna
make it you're not good enough you don't
have the resources you don't have the
knowledge you don't have the connections
you don't come from the right family
you're not born in the right country
right whatever that no is
just turn it into not yet just wait
just watch me i'm coming if you want to
be a successful entrepreneur you're
going to have to deal with a lot of pain
there will be a moment when you feel
like things just can't get any worse
you're at the bottom and then pow life
hits you in the face
and that moment will define you either
you're gonna quit
and give up go back to having a job or
you're gonna learn to rise above
and start having success as an
entrepreneur the strategy that i like to
use
is it's the best you take whatever
negative situation you're in
whatever that thing that feels
overwhelming all-consuming impossible to
deal with and you tell yourself
this is the best this thing's happening
to me right now
is the best this is my chance to show
myself and the world
what i'm made of it's the best and in
actuality it is the best because we
very rarely get chances to show
ourselves what we're made of
we very rarely actually put ourselves
into these situations
where we get hit in the face making a
product that people love starts with you
making something that you
love really think about it would you buy
from you
would you subscribe to you would you
comment and tell your friends
about you in our rush to get rich to
make money
we push products out that we don't love
and if you don't love them
people around you won't love them either
so look at my youtube channel as an
example
i love my youtube channel i make my
youtube channel
for myself i learn it's selfish it's for
me
the top 10 rules videos the espresso
videos the content that i bring together
i need it it's my education i love my
channel i would share my channel with
other people
if i saw my channel and i wasn't
creating i'd be the first thing that i
subscribed to
it would be much watch youtube for me i
need it
and if you guys didn't like it i would
still create it for myself i wouldn't
have as much editing and fancy effects
and all that stuff but i would still do
it
because i need it for me i make it for
myself
selfishly and then i share it with you
guys and thankfully you guys like it
enough that
i can turn a business from it and
continue to hire team and create more
content and pump more stuff out but
as much as i think that my channel still
needs to get better and grow
and improve and i still suck and i need
to continuously
get better at the work that i do i think
my channel deserves a nobel peace prize
like i think my channel is amazing
and you have to love what you do you
have to feel like
the thing that you're doing yes can
always get better
but it's really solving a problem your
product your service what you create
your expertise solves a problem
you know that it's genuinely helping
people if you don't have that belief
you're never going to win you already
know what you want to do
you're letting the opinions of other
people get in the way of you taking
action
people are not afraid of failing they're
afraid of failing in front of other
people
you will sing all day in the shower but
you won't get on the street corner and
shin because you're embarrassed
of the judgment and what you need to do
is inoculate yourself
against the judgment and learn to take
action on your ideas because the
alternative
is a life filled with regret you have to
decide at what point are you going to
take ownership for where you are in life
like at what point do you decide my
goals my ideas my dreams my ambitions
are important enough to me that i'm
willing to risk
failure i'm willing to risk
embarrassment i'm willing to risk having
to go
tell my friends that it didn't work out
because
this is my path because otherwise i
never get to do the thing that i want to
do
at what point are you going to decide to
step up and say
i need to do this for me i need to know
it may not work out i may be embarrassed
but i need to know
i don't want the rest of my life to sit
around wondering
what if what if what if if you want to
succeed as an entrepreneur you need to
work both
hard and smart you need both everybody
who's had massive success
did both forget about trying to work a
four-hour work week
forget about passive income yes you can
make a little bit yes it might be
supplemental income to help you along
your journey but if you want to do
something impactful you want to have a
a big change in the world you want to
really be somebody special and have a
ripple effect out from you you got to do
both you got to work really hard look at
whoever your heroes are
whoever it is that you look up to
they didn't get there by having things
handed to them
and they didn't get there by trying to
create passive income
or work four hours a week and i love the
four-hour workweek book there's a lot of
principles you can use in there
except the fact that when you are
committed to something and you love it
you gotta go all in on it
stop being lazy lazy people don't change
the world lazy people don't have a huge
impact
i want you to have a huge impact and so
hard work is just your ticket in
hard work alone is not the answer
there's lots of people who work really
hard
and they never rise up they never reach
their potential
right you can work really really really
hard as a cashier
but if you're not thinking on a bigger
scale and you're not working smart as
well
then you'll just continue to work really
really hard as a cashier and make
whatever cashier makes and that's where
you stay hard work does not guarantee
your success but there is no success
without hard work
period it doesn't exist show me somebody
who you really look up to and really
respect
who hasn't put in a ton of effort hard
work
and smart work to make it happen and so
i think if you are
just looking for shortcuts if you're
just looking for ways to make that
passive income or
ways to work four hours a week and then
spend the rest of the time lying on the
beach
you're being lazy and you haven't really
tapped into the thing that you love
doing
because i can tell you you get tired of
lying on the beach you may not agree
because your life sucks right now
because your work sucks right now
because you're just trying to escape
but people want to do things that have
meaning
after you've escaped your life and you
spent a year on the beach you're going
to get tired you're going to get bored
you're going to do something that fills
you up
we want to contribute human beings want
to contribute
we want to feel like the work that we're
doing matters and we like to work
we like to feel like the activities that
we're filling up our day with
mean something to somebody else so
you've got to find that
and when you do you don't want to just
work four hours a week
it fills you up you want to do it a lot
it doesn't mean you're spending 24 hours
a day doing it
you got to find the balance for you but
when you find the work that you love
you want to go all in on it you want to
keep going because it fills up your soul
so you've got to work hard and you've
got to work smart it's the only way to
succeed as an entrepreneur
rejection is part of life as an
entrepreneur you are going to get
rejected
over and over and over and over again
it's just part
of being an entrepreneur and being a
business the first thing you put out
won't be very good people will hate on
it people give some constructive
criticism
as well people will say no because they
don't know you trust you like you
and so you won't get those first deals
it takes a lot of time to build up a
business and make it successful and even
when you've gotten to that point where
you're feeling happy and you're bringing
on a team and
building the business you're still going
to get rejected constantly it's just
part of life as an entrepreneur and so
if you can't handle that
it's going to be a really hard road for
you to be an entrepreneur
i think the way to get through rejection
there's two ways to do it one is use
rejection as fuel
kind of like what jack ma did like i got
rejected 10 times by harvard one day i'm
gonna go teach
there right when they're gonna go speak
there to use that as she was like you
turned me down
i'm gonna show you i'm gonna beat it i'm
gonna
come back and be the teacher there right
you turn me down for this deal i'm gonna
go get a deal 10 times as big
right so that's one you can easily you
can use rejection as fuel to help you go
off and do something
bigger and motivation to i'm going to
prove them wrong
the second way is just to forget about
it just
get used to it that's more what i do i
don't really use rejection as fuel
doesn't really bother me when somebody
turns me down or when a new
series doesn't work i was trying to
think when i was preparing for this
video what's the recent rejection that i
have
because there's been so many but none
really stick out as being super
memorable
the one that i came up with was i tried
a new series on the weekend
a while ago about the best of
kickstarter and it was a new series that
i was testing of
showing different kickstarter ideas that
i thought might be helpful for you
and that video didn't do as well as i
would have liked didn't do as well as
other videos
and we're probably going to kill that
series but that's okay like i've killed
tons of series
it happens all the time on the channel
and i couldn't even tell you all the
series
that i've killed because they didn't
perform you guys rejected them
it's okay i just moved past it and so
either one you have two strategies to go
for use the rejection
as fuel to say i'm gonna show you
how wrong you are and prove it to them
or just forget about it get used to it
it's gonna happen just part of the game
and you move on and just think about the
next thing that you can go off and build
use either one of those strategies but
don't get stuck in the rejection
most entrepreneurs aren't patient enough
most entrepreneurs end up losing their
business they end up shutting down
because they think it's gonna happen in
a couple months
or even six months or a year and really
it's going to take them four years
five years before they hit their mark
they don't have enough patience
they don't allow enough time for
momentum to build up and they quit
and they end up going back to a crappy
job that they hate and maybe never ever
take a shot at getting entrepreneurship
because they feel it's not for them
where really
they missed out you missed out on your
destiny you missed them creating
something amazing
because you just didn't have enough
patience now
i believe in patients in the macro i
believe in patients and knowing it's
going to take a long time
i also think inpatients can serve you
greatly but that's in the micro that's
in the daily the impatience of did i do
my best today
did i do my best today can i do better
can i drive more can i drive harder
and knowing that even if i give my best
every single day
it's still gonna take time it's still
gonna take a number of years
for something to happen i want it to
happen as soon as possible
i'm gonna drive and be impatient as
crazy to get it going
but i know it's gonna take time too it's
embracing both
that's when you start to win i look at
my my youtube my instagram my social
media strategy
youtube 7 000 subscribers four years ago
1.2 million subscribers now four years
by making videos
every day every day and i'm impatient as
anything because i want it to be amazing
i want to make every video better than
the last and
looking for all the hacks and seo and
thumbnail strategies and title
strategies and
all of the stuff that we're supposed to
do right i'm on top of it
and i know that it's going to take me
four years to get there i know it's
going to take me a while to get to my
next
2 million 5 million 10 million i look at
instagram follow me on my instagram
journey i'm starting from nothing you
can see
how to build it up from zero i had 8 000
followers many of you already have more
followers than i do on instagram
but i'm gonna win i'm gonna pass people
i'm gonna get mine because i'm gonna
make
daily consistent content three to four
times a day for four years
i'm gonna be impatient as anything and
that the post today has to be amazing
has to be something
that i want to show my grandkids right
that's the intent every time i create
anything
i want my grandkids to watch this video
i want my grandkids to watch the next
instagram thing that i put up it's the
best that i can come up with in the
moment
and i know it's gonna take me four years
maybe three years maybe two years but
it's not going to take me two months
i realize it's going to take working
hard and working smart
together always successful people don't
make excuses
successful people don't complain if you
look at whoever you want to look up to
look at the most successful people in
the world in any industry look at the
top
and look at how much they complain they
don't complain
when you complain when you blame
something else when it's the
government's fault
or interest rates fault or the bad
economy's fault or your partner who
screwed you over
or the customers who don't care as long
as you can blame somebody else right the
education system your parents
your friends your upbringing there's
always somebody else to blame
and when you blame somebody else when
you're in that mindset
then you never grow you're making things
easy on yourself
it allows you to coast it allows you to
play live super safe because it's not
your fault that you're not more
successful
of course it's not your fault that would
be difficult that would be hard
it's somebody else's fault so you can
just stay where you are because
people are holding you back from
accomplishing the thing that you want to
accomplish
where successful people take
responsibility for where they are in
life
and they say i don't care about the
government i don't care who's president
i don't care about
regulations that you have or things that
you're holding me back on i will still
go out and get mine
and of course there are other factors of
course the country you come from matters
of course
education you had in the and the
connections you had growing up
of course it matters but so what
you have to play the hand that you are
dealt you have these cards
you have to play those cards and you can
have success
one of the things i love looking at and
this is why i do all these profiles is
successful famous entrepreneurs
there is always somebody who has done
way more than you have done
with way fewer resources than you
already have
so no matter what terrible situation
that you have and i'm empathetic
maybe you come from a broken home maybe
you have a really severe disability
that's
physically holding you back from doing
some of the things you want to do
you know maybe there's a lot of pressure
on you maybe you have some disease maybe
you
have zero money in your bank account
these are real
pressures and i'm empathetic to that
but so what the longer you believe
that those things are gonna hold you
where you are then they will
there are people who have worse
conditions
less money are in worse situations
and they came out of it and accomplished
amazing things because they believe that
they could
and if somebody looks like you has gone
on and accomplished big things
then you can too and it only happens
when you accept responsibility for where
you are in life
you have the power to control your world
how you think how you act your mindset
with the words that you speak
when you use weak language you signal to
yourself that you are weak
you signal to yourself that your goals
aren't important you signal to yourself
that you are not
worth it you lose respect for yourself
and the people around you don't respect
you either we need to stop using weak
language and pay attention to the words
that you're speaking to
others and to yourself now this is not
an easy task
because most of the words that you're
using the way that you talk to others
into yourself you're on autopilot you're
on cruise control it just happens you've
been doing this for years or decades
and so switching it is not going to
happen overnight but if you pay
attention to the next three things that
i'm going to share with you it can have
a dramatic impact on your
self-confidence
on the goals that you have for yourself
and on the outcomes you create for
yourself and the world
let's do it number one i can't i'm not
i don't what you say after those three
things shapes your identity it
speaks to how you think and speak about
yourself
so i can't i can't be an entrepreneur i
can't be a leader i can't be a youtuber
i can't
i can't i can't i can't i can't
especially this one
when you say i can't pay very very very
very very very close attention
to what follows and try and try
and try to shift it from i can't
to either i choose not to or i can't
yet i'm not i'm not a good salesperson
i'm not funny i'm not the kind of person
who follows through
again pay close attention and try to
shift it to not
yet i don't i don't program
i don't know how to make money i don't
think like that
switch i don't do i don't yet
i can't i'm not i don't those statements
are final
those statements don't allow for growth
those statements are how you feel about
yourself and don't allow for the stretch
they don't allow you to get better and
so either eliminate them from your
vocabulary or
change them to yet number two is catch
your cruise control
the way that you have been speaking
about yourself the way that you have
been talking to yourself
has been happening using the same words
for years
maybe even decades it's so automatic for
you
you are on cruise control you are on
autopilot you think small and talk
negatively about yourself
without even thinking about it you need
to catch your cruise control
and listen don't be too hard on yourself
this is so ingrained these patterns have
been around for so long you are just
auto defaulting to cruise control that
most of these times you will not even
catch it you will not
catch 99 of these moments of these words
of these languages that you're using for
yourself
but if you have the awareness if you
have the intention if you have the
desire
every now and then you will catch it
another quick hack is to enlist a friend
and list the people around you your wife
your husband your team your kids
kids especially my son hayden loves
calling me out on things
enlist their help tell them this is
where i want to play a bigger game
this is where i'm frustrated with myself
this is where i keep talking badly about
myself and putting myself down these are
the words the language that i need to
change
and every time you hear me talking this
way i need you to bring it to my
awareness
and let me know because i want to catch
my cruise control for me personally it's
around complaining anytime i complain
i want my wife i want my team i want my
son i want the people around me to say
evan you are complaining
right there that was a complaint eat it
right i'm happy for them to hug me with
it to yell at me with it i just want
them to let me know
now when i told everybody they said
listen you barely complain you're like
the least complaining person that we
know
awesome thank you i'm humbled but i
still complain
and i probably complain a lot and a lot
of the times i'm missing it and so
please please please please please
please please
even if you think i'm great at it if you
catch me complaining i want you to call
me out on it
so enlisting your friends can be really
helpful because you will likely not
catch most of them yourself
but it's imperative that you start
working on catching your cruise control
step number three is manual override you
have caught your cruise control you have
found the autopilot it's about to happen
again this negative talk
that you're about to speak out into the
world about yourself or your ideas
you putting yourself down is about to
come out again or has just come out
what do you do about it because this is
really important
if you catch yourself playing small or
talking negatively about yourself if you
catch it and you don't do anything it
actually makes it worse it's better that
you don't even catch it at all
if you catch it and you recognize i am
playing small right now
and you ignore it and you don't change
your behavior
you are building that identity for
yourself that you are somebody
who is playing small you are consciously
building that identity for yourself and
you need to stop it
it makes it worse where when you do
catch it
when you find yourself falling into
those patterns those behaviors that you
don't want anymore
whether you find it yourself or
somebody's calling you out on it what do
you do
you need to kick your manual override
into action and take the action that you
want because that starts building
the positive habit that starts building
the positive respect
this is how you build respect for
yourself this is how you start building
the muscle
this isn't just a zero-sum game this
isn't just we go back to
neutral when you catch it you either go
sliding down
or you go propelling up the choice is
yours when you catch yourself playing
small when you catch yourself coming off
a cruise control
you have to do the thing that builds the
self-respect up
and speak positively about yourself and
do the thing that you are scared to do
if you woke up and did the thing that
made you feel bold and unstoppable and
powerful and confident every single day
if you started your day with that thing
your life would look dramatically
different
one year from today compared to where
you currently are right now
the problem is most people wake up like
an accident most people they wake up
they check their phone and they're
immediately responding to other people's
emergencies and demands on your time
you're not in control
you haven't decided to take control of
your day that your day is important that
your life is important and you are going
to take ownership of it
and so you need to block off the time in
the morning maybe five minutes maybe you
need 15 maybe you need an hour and a
half
whatever it is the thing that makes you
feel
bold unstoppable powerful confident fill
your cup
every single day because other people
have demands your time
and they won't fill your cup for you you
have to say this is my
ownership right here nobody's touching
it i'm taking charge
now that looks different for different
people how oprah does it is different
than how i do it is different than how
dwayne the rock johnson does it dwayne
johnson has to get his four hours of
work out in every day when he's working
on a movie set and he has to be in by
nine he'll wake up at four
in the morning so he can go work out for
four hours
and then go back and and shower and get
ready for his movie so he's only
sleeping five hours
a day when he's doing movies i think
that's crazy but to him that's balance
that's him filling his cup that's him
reminding himself of what he's doing he
loves working out
that's why i don't look like dwayne the
rock johnson right there's a difference
between us
i would rather sleep i would rather do
something else in the morning and so we
tend to look at
what we're doing against somebody else
you tend to look at oprah and say well
she's doing it this way i need to do
that
dwayne's doing it this way i need to do
that evan's doing it this way i need to
do that you judge yourself against other
people's
routines and methods of filling their
cup and i think that's actually a recipe
for failure
because you are not that person because
what works for them is not going to be
the exact same thing that works for you
here's the good news you already know
what fills your cup
you already know what makes you feel
bold and alive and full of momentum and
confidence
you have had that happen to you in the
past you're just not living there
consistently you know what has helped
you feel
full but you're living there one percent
of the time
and 99 of the time you spend reacting to
other people
their demands their emergencies their
issues for your time
and so reverse engineer for yourself
when was the last time you felt filled
up
motivated confident bold excited what
happened what were you doing what led to
that thing to happen
were you watching a video were you
listening to a podcast were you reading
the book
were you going to an event a seminar
were you outside you know i'm sitting
here on a swing here outside
where you're outside you need to get out
of nature do you need to meditate you
need to have a shower do you need to
dance to music like
what's the thing without judgment
without caring if anybody else has to do
that thing
maybe you need to wake up every day and
pet your frog and that's the thing
that makes you feel amazing great do
that plan for it every single morning
because i guarantee you if you did the
thing
that helped fill your cup that made you
feel bold and unstoppable and confident
and powerful
if all you did was wake up every day and
did that thing
your life would be dramatically
different one year from today compared
to where you are right now you will not
recognize your life so please stop
waking up like an accident and put this
into your morning routine
every single day finding your purpose
guys is not that difficult
it's not that difficult it's one of the
most common questions that i get
here's how you do it you think about the
time
in your life where you felt the most
worthless think about the time the
lowest low that you've ever experienced
in your life what was that moment
your purpose now where you will get the
most fulfilled
of all time will be helping people who
are currently going through
the thing that you went through that's
it
think about the most painful moments of
your life the thing that you would never
want to experience
ever again think about the thing you
would never wish upon your worst enemy
definitely not your friends your family
your kids think about that moment
your greatest purpose your greatest
enjoyment your greatest fulfillment in
life will come from helping people
who are currently facing that thing that
you faced
that is your purpose for life it will
never get old
helping those people will never get
tiring
self-improvement is the answer to
whatever obstacle is staring you in the
face right now
the only difference between you and
greatness is the willingness to grow and
improve it's not talent it's not smart
it's the willingness to improve yourself
the difference between you and tony
robbins is he has spent more time
constantly improving himself than most
people on the planet
here's a guy who had multiple fathers
growing up had an abusive mother who at
17 he had to run away from home
so he could become a janitor and never
go to college
he then decided to be a success he read
700 books in seven years
he studied under mentors like jim rohn
and today he's the founder or owner of
companies with over six
billion dollars in annual revenue if
tony robbins can go from being
an abused janitor with no college
education to being one of the most
influential people in the world why
can't you
the difference is he made the investment
to constantly improve himself
and you haven't yet at that level so i
look at my channel as an example my
youtube
channel and i've learned so much over
the past number of years
in confidence and growth and abilities
and skills
by consuming the content because i love
the top 10 series and the mentor me
series in the international series i
make them for me
and then i share them with you and
thankfully you guys like them too and
i can build a business off of it and
keep pumping out more content
but it helps me i've grown i've learned
and one of the biggest moments that
helped me realize how much i've learned
is when i signed a three-year deal with
sage i was working with stephen kelly
who was the ceo
and every month we'd be on a call we'd
be doing a hangout on my youtube channel
answering questions from people and i
was driving with my dad and i remember
him asking me
how do you get the confidence to be on a
call with stephen kelly
and be seen as his equal all the time
and he wasn't asking me to put me down
he was asking me
in in genuine of he was so happy for me
that i was playing a bigger game
and it dawned on me that he was right
the evan of five years ago wouldn't have
been able to do that the evidence of
five years ago would have felt less than
the evidence of five years ago would
have said
there's no way i'm capable of doing that
and then when i'd signed the deal
i felt like it's great i love stephen
he's amazing
but i feel like i'm hanging out with
oprah and kanye
and steve jobs and bill gates and these
super successful people
and they're infiltrating my brain on a
daily basis
right a daily basis three videos every
single day on this channel
and so bit by bit it pulls me up now i
recognize i still have a long way to go
i still have so much more to learn i
still need to believe in myself even
more
and every time i consume more content it
allows me to
grow my comfort zone a little bit a
little bit a little bit a little bit
more
and the funny thing is all of these
moments are are little tiny incremental
parts of your growth
i couldn't point you to one point in my
past where i said that was the moment
that i changed that was the moment that
i had more confidence
but as i studied every day every day
every day
i could look back three months six
months a year and say wow i've really
changed
i've really grown i've really learned a
lot but in the daily from today to
yesterday
i'd say i didn't grow at all and so
sometimes on your journeys you're trying
to learn and get better you may feel
like the growth is really slow on a
daily basis
but if you keep going you keep investing
you keep learning you keep seeking out
mentors you keep trying to get better
and improve
not every day will be amazing but if you
try every day to get better and learn i
can guarantee you that in three months
six months one year when you look back
of the person you've become compared to
what you are right now
they'll be a big change and that's
because you continue to invest in
yourself
you're never going to accomplish
anything great if you're coming from a
place of negativity if you are just
complaining and negative and blaming
other people
you're never going to accomplish
anything it's just not going to happen
you can't create amazing things
from a negative spot it means that you
have zero resourcefulness
because there's no hope and so you need
to flip it now i'm gonna give you
a wild mind trick that that i use that
maybe is a little too weird duck for you
but i want to test it on you because if
if one of you picks it up it'll
dramatically change your life
it's my philosophy of changing negative
situations and doing a quick mind trick
in my head to say
it's the best so whenever i'm hit with a
negative situation
something that is beyond my control
something that i can't do anything about
i will complain i will be unhappy i'll
be negative
for eight to 24 seconds and then i'll
tell myself
it's the best that this is the best
thing that happened to me
and then i'll figure out why it's the
best so as an example i'm on an airplane
i'm coming from
vancouver to l.a i'm speaking at an
event in la i'm on a flight it's a five
hour flight i get on this is
really smelly dude next to me really
smelly guy
i he probably hadn't been on you know in
a shower in a couple days
probably had multiple transfers and
stopovers and i have empathy i'm not i'm
not pissed at him i'm pissed at the
situation right
i'm sure he's normally a nice smelling
guy and
takes care of himself but in this
situation
he was super smelly and i had to deal
with it so what am i going to do i got a
five hour flight what are my options
i can not go you know i could miss my
flight and then
not do my presentation i could sit on
the airplane
and be upset for the next five hours and
then be upset for the rest of the day
and allow this
minor situation to own me and to be
better than me
and ruin my entire day or i could say
this is the best
and that's what i did for around eight
to 24 seconds i'm sitting there
trying to figure out my options what
options do i have how can i do how can i
fix this
there's no options i'm screwed and then
i'm upset
you know i'm upset this sucks come on
really this is what i have to deal with
the next five hours
and then this is the best and what do i
do
[Music]
yep breathe it in breathe it in give it
to me
because this is making me stronger this
is the best this is actually the best
why because it's my chance
to show myself what i'm made of that
this smelly dude is not going to own me
that i am
stronger than a little bit of smell on
an airplane and that the next time i get
faced with a similar situation
i'm able to handle it it's easy it rubs
off me
i think that's how you actually build
self-confidence that's how you actually
build self-esteem
because when it's easy it's easy winning
the race against three-year-olds
is easy doesn't mean anything you're not
gonna clap that up yeah
i beat a bunch of three-year-olds but
when it's hard
and you try that's when you actually
build self-esteem and so
flip it flip it in your mind flip it
this is the best whatever negative
situation is in front of you right now
tell yourself it's the best so people
often ask me what is your business model
11 how do you make money
this is it this is my business model i
kick up
as much noise in my industry i get as
much attention as possible
in my industry and then i find ways to
monetize it
that's it when you have a lot of
attention in your industry people will
find you and
throw opportunities at you my biggest
challenge is trying to figure out now
which opportunity to go after
i get speaking gigs because of the
attention i built to my youtube channel
i get opportunities to connect with
people like tony robbins and have them
be
interviewed on my channel i get brand
deals with people wanting to partner
with me i get book deals
everything has come because of my
youtube channel because i built up
a quarter of a billion views because i
have one point whatever million
subscribers
i just kick up a lot of attention in my
industry
and then deals come to me and that works
really well for someone like me
because i'm introverted because i'm much
better at marketing than i am at sales
and so instead of me spending time which
would be more wasted time
going out trying to connect with people
trying to reach people because i'm
introverted
i just get to work on creating amazing
content and i have people then find me
and find me out the places and pay me to
do things because i built up the
marketing attention machine
when you have a mission you're not for
sale when you know what you're doing
when you have a deep purpose and you are
off
chasing it you are not for sale money is
really important but
if you look at the success of people
look at anybody you look up to who you
respect
who's your hero who's you're here who's
your greatest most
famous entrepreneur of all time that you
love and you would love to emulate
money was not the most important thing
to them there was something above money
now money is important
money is important for every business
money is important for every
organization if you're a charity money's
still important but it's not number one
and you gotta figure out what you would
put ahead of your money so many people
are just chasing money money money money
and i get it it's important
i had i had a woman who was at my
seminar last night here in indianapolis
who she has eight different side hustles
and now she's trying to get into real
estate to try to make money and the
problem is
none of it's purpose-driven and none of
it is actually making her enough money
she's making just enough just little
tiny bits from these side hustles
that she can barely survive it's the
wrong path the people who only
prioritize
money never make money they never make
the real money
you make just enough to survive because
your will to win is for sale
you've got to figure out what your
purpose is you got to figure out who you
are you got to figure out what the
mission is that you're on when you do
that
then no matter how much money is being
thrown at you
you're not going to accept it because
you're on a deep purpose for life
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that
it's time for the question of the day i
want to know what was your single
biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week
when you just watch a video and you get
motivated the sign says you have a 35
chance of actually following through
that's not good enough believe nation we
need to take some action
but when you watch a video you get
motivated and you create a specific
plan of action that number jumps from 35
percent
to 91 chance of you following through
and when you publicly commit to other
people like leaving a comment down in
this video
your number jumps to 95 chance of you
actually following through on the plan
you set for yourself
so i want to know your single biggest
takeaway from this video
and your plan of action for the next
week leave it down in the comments below
so i can celebrate you the fastest way
to grow
is to be around people who are doing
what you want to do period when you are
around
people who are building and growing and
taking on the world and trying to
accomplish their dreams and you're in
that environment
and you're learning even just being
around them it's going to seep into you
and get you motivated and pumped up and
fired up to go off and chase your dreams
most people have a pretty crappy
environment most people if you're an
entrepreneur
most people they don't have a bunch of
entrepreneurs in their family most
people when they tell their family and
friends what they're doing they think
they're crazy
they think that you shouldn't go off and
do that thing you should go and get a
safe normal
typical job a lot of people have a lot
of negativity around them if you are
constantly
surrounded by negative people people
bringing you down
it's really hard to be the one person
trying to go off and make a huge
difference
and so that's you if that's your
situation then you need to change your
environment you need to be surrounded by
people
who are like-minded who are off chasing
their goals and you need to find some
mentors
let me give you some quick tips on how
to do it because if you don't
you're never going to get to where you
want to go you won't staying
right now where you are needs to be
unacceptable
needs to be unacceptable because you
will never get to the spot
that you want to be at if you stay
exactly where you are
with the people in the environment that
you have around you step number one
is limit the exposure to negativity
that may mean you cut off some friends
just because you were friends in
elementary school doesn't mean you
should still be friends now
it doesn't doesn't mean you have to be
rude to them you've just grown apart
it's okay
it's okay it's great you'll get new
friends we need to
limit exposure to negative toxic people
if those are your parents
you may not want to completely eliminate
them from your life although for some
people that's an
important step it may just mean cutting
off exposure to some topics
if you know that your friends or your
parents talking to them about your
business ideas
is always going to lead to a fight
negativity just don't talk about it say
i don't want to talk about that and find
something positive that you can relate
to and talk about
step one you have to eliminate the
negativity or limit
exposure to it in your life you will not
do great things if you are constantly
bombarded by negativity
step number two now you have to fill the
void you got to fill the void with
positivity
and so that's reaching out that's
joining communities that's going to
events that's going to groups
i'm on my tour right now i'm in
albuquerque new mexico i'm doing an
event tonight here in albuquerque
and when people come together who are
like-minded all the people who come to
my events
they're all entrepreneurs and they all
want to go off and do something amazing
and for a lot of the people coming out
they're the only ones that they know who
are off trying to do something and now
they meet
local people who are also similarly
minded you need to be around
similarly minded people and so check
your local city
check your local groups see what's
happening see what's coming up get
involved get out of the house
stop being in your regular routine your
your current environment is not helping
you you need to get out and meet new
people
and you may go to an event and meet only
one person that is potentially
like-minded
amazing collect people i like collecting
good people collect them
i'll even be super awkward about it
almost intentionally where
if i really like somebody and we have a
great conversation
i'll say you know what i really like you
um that sounds weird
i'd like to find a way to spend more
time together maybe we meet up once a
month
for a coffee and just talk about
business
that's how you do it you just ask and if
you had that
with four or five different people then
every week you're meeting somebody
on a regular basis who fills you with
positivity and energy and so
you have to go off and find those people
you have to say yes and go to those
events
to meet to be around the positive energy
because it'll make such a big difference
for you accomplishing your big goals
and then step number three is get more
mentors you need to get mentors
and one are aspirational mentors and
that's what i see through what i do
right through my content i learn through
the aspirational mentors
i learn from kanye i learn from dutton
upon me i learn from oprah winfrey i
learn from
mel robbins i learn from these people
they make me better even though i
haven't met most of the people that i
profiled on my channel
i learn from them they make me better
being around them and their energy and
their wisdom
gets me fired up seeing people going off
doing amazing things
and i get that three times a day on my
channel right like it will shift you it
will
if you are watching content you may
never meet dandapani but if you're
watching his content if he inspires you
and you watch his content on a daily
it will shift you because now he's a
voice of positivity in your life
and then you can get real mentors as
well for those of you who are following
my path to 10 million subscribers series
i'm having people who i respect and look
up to coach me on different things that
i need to get better at
who they'll watch my stuff and say hey
here this is where you're great but here
you suck you got to get better at this
thing
you need to make the decision to change
your environment you need to make the
decision that your life is important
that your mission is important that
being where you are right now is not
acceptable that you don't want to be
here again
in a year like one year from today you
can't be in the same environment you
can't be
around negativity and toxicity every
single day you need to follow those
steps
you need to remove the negativity from
your life you need to seek out positive
energy and be around people
who build and lift you up and you need
to start seeking out mentors whether
they are face-to-face mentors or
aspirational mentors to help you get to
where you go
your life is important your mission is
important you need to start treating it
as so
if you want to watch brandon brochure's
inspiration video check out the video
next to me
i think you're going to enjoy i will see
you there continue to bully
ambition ambition but too many of us
back away from it because it got made
bad right
i was scared to have ambition because
you know what if you have ambition too
big for your britches